STARTED HERE.
THE ABSENCE OF ANY OTHER
COMMITTEE MEMBERS BUT THE SHOW
GOES ON RIGHT.
SO WE ARE GOING TO HAVE A
HEARING TODAY ON THE REMAINDER
OF THE UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA
ISSUES FROM A FEW WEEKS AGO AS
WELL AS HAVE A ACROSS CUTTING
DISCUSSION ABOUT.
STUDENT MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES
AND WITH THAT WE WANT TO START
WITH THAT ISSUE ISSUE NUMBER A
ONE WITH THE UCC ISSUED
COMMITTEE COLLEGES ALL.
PARTICIPATING ON A PANEL
IMMIGRANT IT CHANGE IT UP A
LITTLE BIT SO I'M GONNA ASK --
AT ADRIAN SHELTON FROM THE SAME
BRINGS IT TO TO HOLD BACK FOR A
SEC.
AND WE'RE GONNA HAVE THE
SEGMENTS COME FIRST NUMBER GONNA
HAVE -- INITIALS AND COME UP
WITH A STUDENT ON THE SECOND
PANEL WILL TALK ABOUT THIS ISSUE
SO -- PLEASE COME ON UP.
THE YOU YOU SEE REPRESENTATIVE
THE CSU -- TO CSU
REPRESENTATIVES AND THE
REPRESENTATIVE FROM THAT
CALIFORNIA COMMITTEE CALL
CHANCES OFFICE.
OKAY END UP BEFORE WE BEFORE WE
GET GOING I JUST WANT TO SAY
FROM THE OUT OUT SAID THAT THIS
IS.
CRITICALLY IMPORTANT ISSUE. FOR
FOR JET DECADES AND GENERATIONS
BUT I THINK IT'S BEEN -- MORE
CUTE -- IN RECENT YEARS THE THE
THE IMPACT ON MENTAL HEALTH
SUCCESS AND COLLEGE SUCCESS.
AND WE JUST HAD AT A ROUNDTABLE
DISCUSSION TWO DAYS AGO AT CSU
SACRAMENTO.
WHERE HER FROM STUDENTS TALKING
ABOUT THE ISSUES THEIR FACE
SAYING NOWADAYS SPECIALLY THE
THE FINANCIAL PRESSURES AND?
ANXIETY AND DEPRESSION AND HOW
THAT IMPACTS THEIR STUDIES IN
GETTING THEIR THEIR THEIR
COURSES COMPLETED IN AND GETTING --
A AT THAT WHAT THEY'RE LOOKING
TO GET OUT OF IT OF HIGHER
EDUCATION SYSTEM.
BUT ALSO THE STUDENTS THAT ARE
THAT ARE UNFORTUNATELY.
GOING THROUGH SOME EPISODES IN
TRYING TO GET HELP.
THEY GO SIGN UP IN THE WELLNESS
OFFICE.
WHICH I THINK A GOOD THING IS
NOW IN IN IN INCORPORATED WITH --
THE HOW THE HELL SERVICES WAS ON
OUT LIAR THING SO HOPEFULLY CAN
REDUCE THE STIGMAS BUT EVEN IF
THEY DO GOOD IN THERE AND FIND
SOMEBODY THAT CAN HELP.
NOW IT'S COME BACK IN SEVEN
WEEKS WELL THE CRISIS TODAY THE
FINALS NEXT WEEK -- TUITION RENT
SO FOR SO THESE ARE -- EACH
ISSUES WE NEED TO ADDRESS AS FAR
AS THE OVERALL SERVICES AND THE
TIMELINESS OF IT SO WE WANTED TO
TALK ABOUT WHAT THE STATE CAN DO
TO STEP UP IN THIS -- SPACE
ESPECIALLY WITH OUR A UC AND CSU
AND COMMUNITY COLLEGE -- THE
PARTNER SO WITH THAT -- PLEASE
BEGIN WE'RE GOING TO START WITH
THE REPRESENTED FROM THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIRMAN CARTY --
AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS -- MY NAME
IS BRAD BUCKMAN I AM THE THE
CHIEF MEDICAL OFFICER OF US TO
HEALTH AND COUNSELING AT THE
UNIVERSITY CALIFORNIA. FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO ADDRESS THIS
IMPORTANT TOPIC WITH YOU TODAY --
I'M JUST GOING TO PROVIDE A VERY
QUICK OVERVIEW OF THE SCOPE OF
SERVICES WE PROVIDE -- QUICKLY
REVIEWED SOME OBSERVE
UTILIZATION TRENDS WE'VE SEEN
WITHIN YOU SEE OVER THE PAST TEN
YEARS WHAT UC'S RESPONSE HAS
BEEN AND WHY ARE WE ARE
REQUESTING YOUR ASSISTANCE AND
TO MAINTAIN AND AND EVEN GROW
OUR CAPACITY IN A IN A IN A
BACKDROP OF REALLY.
ESCALATING DEMAND FROM OUR
STUDENTS AND SO THE WORSENING
SEVERITY OF ILLNESS -- GONNA
TALK BRIEFLY ON GAPS WE MIGHT
ANTICIPATE IF -- CURRENT FUNDING
RESOURCES THAT WE HAVE NOW DO
NOT CONTINUE AND THEN -- AT THE
END JUST BRIEFLY TALK ABOUT
FURTHER -- STABILIZATION OF OUR
CAPACITY FOR SERVICES AS WELL AS
EXPANSION OF SERVICES IF NEW
MONIES ARE IDENTIFIED AND
APPROVED.
SO WE GO TO SLIDE ONE JUST A
QUICK OVERVIEW OF OUR CORE
SERVICES -- THE FIRST CATEGORY
OF THOSE HIS DIRECT SERVICES SO
I THINK MOST PEOPLE ARE FAMILIAR
WITH DIRECT FACE TO FACE
COUNSELING VISITS -- WHICH IS --
A VERY -- SIGNIFICANT PART OF
THE SERVICES OUR COUNSELORS
PROVIDE -- BUT AS YOU'LL SEE
THERE'S MANY OTHER SERVICES THAT
ARE COUNSELORS ARE INVOLVED WITH
SO GROUP COUNSELING VISITS.
URGENT CARE ARE CRISIS VISITS
AND THAT CAN OCCUR WHEN A
STUDENT IS ACTUALLY SEEN IN OUR
MEDICAL CLINICS.
AND IS VERY DISTRESSED AND THE
MEDICAL STAFF MAY ASK FOR A
URGENT CONSOLE FROM A FROM A
COUNSELOR OR THERAPIST TO COME
OVER AND VISIT WITH THEIR
STUDENTS.
THEY PROVIDE BACK UP FOR OUR
AFTER HOURS CALL SERVICES.
WE HAVE -- PSYCHIATRY
CONSULTATIONS AVAILABLE A
REFERRAL FOR LONG TERM CARE FOR
STUDENTS WHO HAVE MORE
CHRONICALLY ILL OR OR VERY
SEVERE INSIGNIFICANT ILLNESSES
THAT REQUIRE.
WEEKLY IF NOT MULTIPLE VISITS
PER WEEK TO MANAGE -- AS WELL AS
CASE MANAGEMENT AND A GOOD
EXAMPLE THERE'S EATING DISORDER
PATIENTS WHO MAY NEED --
COORDINATION OF THREE OR FOUR
DIFFERENT CARE PROVIDERS -- TO
APPROPRIATELY MANAGE THOSE
PATIENTS FROM AN OUT REACH
STANDPOINT OUR COUNSELORS ARE
INVOLVED IN -- LOTS OF
PREVENTION ND EARLY
INTERVENTION CAMPAIGNS -- OUR
STUDENT LEADERS AND PEER
ADVOCATES ARE ALSO A HUGE
RESOURCE THAT ALL OF OUR
CAMPUSES AND EXTEND OUR ABILITY
TO PROVIDE SERVICES BY USING
PEERS TO GET OUT AND GET THE
WORD OUT.
AND DE STIGMATIZE OUR SERVICES A
BIT AND TRY TO GET STUDENTS AND
WHEN THEIR PERHAPS NOT AS ILL AS
IF THEY LET THEIR SYMPTOMS
CONTINUE AND AND PROGRESS --
WE'RE ALSO VERY INTEGRATED WITH
WELLNESS WORKSHOPS AND SEMINARS
THROUGHOUT THE CAMPUS.
WE ADDITIONALLY PROVIDE
SATELLITE CLINICS -- TO AREAS
AND DEPARTMENTS THAT WE HAVE
BEEN OBSERVED THAT THESE ARE --
DEPARTMENTS THAT TYPICALLY OUR
STUDENTS ARE HIGHER UTILIZE RISK --
SOME GRAD DEPARTMENTS ARE IN
THAT CATEGORY INTERNATIONAL
STUDENTS -- SO THERE'S A NUMBER
OF AND ANY NUMBER OF UNDER
REPRESENTED STUDENTS THAT
REPRESENT VULNERABLE GROUPS THEY
ALSO PROVIDE EDUCATIONAL
RESOURCES THE LAST CATEGORY OF
CAMPUS CONSULTATION -- SO IN
ADDITION TO PROVIDING DIRECT
SERVICES TO OUR STUDENTS ARE
COUNSELORS ARE ACTIVELY --
INTEGRATING WITH OUR FACULTY AND
STAFF PROVIDING TRAINING
PROVIDING CONSULTATION TO CAMPUS
ADMINISTRATION -- MAINTAINING
LIAISON RELATIONSHIPS WITH SOME
OF THESE HIGHER RISK DEPARTMENTS --
AND THEN A VERY KEY COMPONENT IS
THEY PROVIDE CRISIS RESPONSE AND
WE HAVE A TERRIBLE EVENTS HAPPEN
ON OUR CAMPUS OR WE HAVE AN
UNEXPECTED DEATH OF A STUDENT OR
AN OVERDOSE.
MANY STUDENTS ARE IMPACTED
FACULTY STAFF AS WELL -- BUT OUR
OUR COUNSELING CENTERS ARE VERY
GOOD AT MOBILIZING SERVICES --
TO ADDRESS THE NEEDS OF MANY
STUDENTS DURING A TRAGEDY I THE
NEXT FLIGHT IS -- IS JUST A
QUICK OVERVIEW OF OUR OBSERVED --
INCREASE IN UTILIZATION OVER THE
PAST TEN YEARS AND ON THIS GRAPH
YOU CAN SEE THAT OVER THAT
PERIOD WE'VE HAD ABOUT A 78%
INCREASE.
IN THE NUMBER OF UNIQUE CLIENT
SEEN EACH YEAR SO THAT COMES OUT
TO ABOUT AN 8% INCREASE PER YEAR
IN UNIQUE STUDENTS COMING TO OUR
COUNSELING CENTERS.
AT THE SAME PERIOD -- THE
ENROLLMENT GROWTH THAT YOU SEE
INCREASED ONLY ABOUT 27% SO YOU
CAN SEE THAT THERE ARE SOME
OTHER.
SIGNIFICANT FACTORS DRIVING
DEMAND -- AND THE LAST QUICK
EXAMPLE -- IT THE NUMERICAL
EXAMPLE IS THE PERCENT OF A
STUDENT SEEN AS A PERCENT OF
ENROLLMENT UNIQUE CLIENTS -- TEN
YEARS AGO WAS ABOUT 9% OF OUR
ENROLLMENT AND NOW IT'S ABOUT
13% -- IN THE LAST ACADEMIC YEAR.
THE OTHER THING OUR COUNSELORS
REALLY HARP ON IS JUST THE THE
REALLY INCREASE IN SEVERITY OF
ILLNESS THEY'RE SEEING MANY
STUDENTS ARE ARRIVING AT UC
ALREADY ON MEDICATIONS.
OTHER STUDENTS WHO ARE COMING TO
ACCESS COUNSELING SERVICES MORE
THAN 50% OF THEM HAVE ALREADY
BEEN IN COUNSELING WHILE THEY
WERE IN HIGH SCHOOL -- THERE'S
INCREASING ANXIETY AND
DEPRESSION AS WELL AS INCREASE
IN SUICIDAL IDEATION WITH ABOUT
TEN ALMOST 10% OF OUR STUDENTS.
REPORTING SERIOUSLY CONSIDERING
SUICIDE IN THE LAST TWELVE
MONTHS.
THIRD SLIDE -- TALKS ABOUT WHAT
HAS YOU SEE DONE TO TRY AND
RESPOND TO THIS ESCALATION IN
DEMAND.
YEARS AGO -- THE REGENTS
APPROVED A STUDENT MENTAL HEALTH
FUNDINGINITIATIVE WHICH A PLAN
TO INCREASE OUR STUDENT SERVICES
FEE BY 5% FOR FIVE CONSECUTIVE
YEARS.
AND THAT WAS APPROVED IN LATE
TWENTY FOURTEEN AND IMPLEMENTED --
THE FOLLOWING YEAR -- AND THIS
IS A FIVE YEAR PLAN -- WITH
ABOUT 50% OF THE REVENUES
GENERATED FROM THAT INITIATIVE --
BEING EARMARKED FOR STUDENT
MENTAL HEALTH.
LAST YEAR OR THIS CURRENT
ACADEMIC YEAR THAT WERE ENDING
IN THE NEXT SEVERAL MONTHS --
YOU SEE DID RECEIVE A QUITE
GRATEFULLY A FOUR POINT EIGHT
MILLION DOLLARS IN STATE GENERAL
FUNDS -- IN LIEU OF THE STUDENT
SERVICES FEE SO LAST YEAR WE DID
NOT HAVE TO TAX OUR STUDENTS AN
ADDITIONAL 5% IN THEIR STUDENT
SERVICES FEE -- KEEP COMPONENT
OF THAT THOUGH IS THAT IT'S ONE
TIME MONEY AND WILL EXPIRE ON
JUNE THIRTIETH.
SO TO BRIEFLY SUMMARIZE OUR
REQUEST WE'RE ASKING TO MAKE A
PERMANENT A ONE TIME FOUR POINT
EIGHT MILLION DOLLARS IN STATE
GENERAL FUNDS THAT YOU SEE
RECEIVED -- LAST YEAR -- IN LIEU
OF OUR STUDENT SERVICES FEE
INCREASE THAT WE DID NOT HAVE TO
ASSESS OUR STUDENTS.
ADDITIONALLY YOU WERE REQUESTING
THAT THE COMMITTEE CONSIDER
APPROVING A FIVE POINT THREE
MILLION DOLLARS IN STATE GENERAL
FUNDS PROPOSED BY THE GOVERNOR
FOR NEXT YEAR.
ON THE NEXT SLIDE WHICH IS SLIDE --
FIVE I WANTED TO JUST BRIEFLY
TOUCH ON THE IMPROVEMENTS THAT
WE'VE BEEN ABLE TO MAKE THROUGH
THIS FUNDING INITIATIVE THAT
STARTED IN.
IN TWENTY FIFTEEN SIXTEEN WE'VE
HIRED ALMOST SEVENTY F. T. OF
COUNSELORS.
A WE'VE BEEN ABLE TO DECREASE
THE AVERAGE WAIT TIME FOR OUR
STUDENTS -- COMING IN FOR A
ROUTINE INTAKE FROM TWELVE TO
EIGHTEEN DAYS PRIOR TO THE
FUNDING ARRIVING -- WITHIN THE
FIRST YEAR OR TWO WE GOT IT DOWN
TO AN AVERAGE OF ABOUT NINE DAYS
AND THAT'S DRIFTED BACK UP TO
ABOUT ELEVEN DAYS IN THE CURRENT
YEAR.
ANOTHER A MARKER THAT WE USE TO
MEASURE HOW WELL WE'RE DOING IS
THE PERCENT OF STUDENTS THAT ARE
SEEN IN A AND FOURTEEN CALENDAR
DAYS.
ADDITIONALLY AFTER WE STARTED
THIS -- FUNDING INITIATIVE WE
FOR AT LEAST THE FIRST YEAR WERE
ABLE TO GET 80% OF OUR STUDENTS
WITHIN FOURTEEN DAYS.
THAT HAS GRADUALLY DRIFTED DOWN
OVER THE LAST COUPLE OF YEARS
AND 278% AND 74% -- BECAUSE OUR
ENROLLMENT GROWTH IS CONTINUING --
TO INCREASE AND AS I'VE
MENTIONED BEFORE THERE ARE OTHER
FACTORS THAT ARE VERY MUCH
DRIVING DEMAND FOR OUR STUDENTS.
WE'VE ACHIEVED VERY MUCH IMPROVE
STUDENT SATISFACTION -- SCORES
WITH OUR ACCESS -- WE'VE ALSO
BEEN ABLE TO DO SOME INNOVATIVE
THINGS -- WHICH INCLUDES
IMPLEMENTING CASE MANAGERS FOR
COMPLICATED ILLNESSES THAT
INVOLVE COORDINATED CARE BETWEEN
A NUMBER OF PROVIDERS.
MANY OF OUR CENTERS HAVE MOVED
COUNSELORS INTO THE URGENT CARE
OR INTO THE MEDICAL CLINICS TO
TRYING BE IMMEDIATELY AVAILABLE
WHEN A DISTRESSED STUDENT
ARRIVES -- FOR ANOTHER REASON IN
A MEDICAL CLINIC OR DECIDES TO
GO THERE FIRST -- WE'VE ALSO FOR
THE PAST THREE YEARS BEEN ABLE
TO HOLD CULTURAL COMPETENCY
TRAINING FOR ALL OF OUR MENTAL
HEALTH PROVIDERS AND IN IN YEARS
PAST THAT HAS BEEN IN
COLLABORATION WITH CSU IN A
COMMUNITY COLLEGES SO WE'RE
CONTINUING TO WORK.
ON TRAINING OUR MENTAL HEALTH
PROVIDERS -- TO BE CULTURALLY
AWARE AND PROVIDE CONFIDENCE
SERVICES LASTLY WE'VE BEEN ABLE
THE PILOT -- DIGITAL
TECHNOLOGIES WEB BASED --
TECHNOLOGIES TO ASSIST STUDENTS
AND AS AN ADJUNCT TO CARE TO
COUNSELING CARE AS WELL AS
FELLOW BEHAVIOR HEALTH SERVICES.
NEXT SLIDE WHICH IS SLIDE -- SIX
TALKS ABOUT -- CONSEQUENCES FOR
ARE YOU SEE STUDENTS IF OUR
CURRENT FUNDING IN THE CURRENT
YEAR DOES EXPIRE ONJUNE
THIRTIETH -- UNFORTUNATELY WE
WOULD NOT BE ABLE TO MAINTAIN.
ABOUT TWENTY FIVE F. T. E. OF
COUNSELORS THAT WE HIRED -- JUST
PRIOR TO THIS YEAR -- THIS WOULD
BE A SIGNIFICANT LOSS FOR US
BOTH IN -- THE PERCENTAGE OF NEW
HIRES IN THE PAST THREE YEARS --
ALMOST A THIRD OF THOSE ARE
SLIGHTLY MORE THAN A THIRD IN
ABOUT 10% OF OUR COUNSELING
STAFF IN ITS ENTIRETY.
WE ARE QUITE SURE THAT THIS
WOULD WORSEN ACCESSIBILITY AND
CREATE DELAYS FOR STUDENTS IT
WOULD DEFINITELY DECREASE
PROVIDER DIVERSITY THOSE ARE
SOME OF THE HARDEST -- PROVIDERS
TO BE ABLE TO RECRUIT AND RETAIN
AND A MANY OF THEM HAVE BEEN
HIRED RECENTLY AND WE BELIEVE IT
WOULD AFFECT SAFETY AS WELL AS
STUDENT SATISFACTION.
IF -- WE WERE DID HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO RECEIVE
ADDITIONAL OF FUNDS IN ADDITION
TO MAINTAINING OUR OUR CURRENT
ONE TIME FUNDS WHAT WOULD WE DO
WITHOUT -- YOU SEE IS PREPARED
TO HIRE THE REMAINING --
THIRTEEN F. T. EVER COUNSELORS
THAT WE HAD ORIGINALLY PLANNED
IN THIS FIVE YEAR INITIATIVE.
THAT WOULD ALLOW US TO STABILIZE
FUNDING FOR SOME OF OUR EXISTING
HIRES AND STAFF WERE ON
TEMPORARY FUNDS.
AND REALLY ALLOW US TO START
WORKING ON TARGETED PREVENTION
WORK -- OVERALL NET EFFECT WE
WANT TO BE ABLE TO MAINTAIN AT
THE VERY LEAST IF NOT IMPROVE
OUR CAPACITY -- CONTINUE TO
ENHANCE OUR PROVIDER DIVERSITY.
AND TRIED.
TO MINIMIZE THE CHANCE THAT OUR
ACCESSIBILITY IS GOING TO GO
DOWN WE WANT TO MAINTAIN STUDENT
SAFETY.
AND THEN FINALLY REALLY WORK ON
A CAMPUS WIDE AND THEN VERY
TARGETED AND FOCUSED PREVENTION
WORK ON ARE VULNERABLE STUDENT
POPULATIONS.
WHICH I'LL JUST NOTE INCLUDE
UNDOCUMENTED STUDENTS TRANSFER
STUDENTS ALWAYS TYPICALLY HAVE A
MORE DIFFICULT TIME FIRST
GENERATION STUDENTS.
VETERANS STUDENTS AND ANY NUMBER
OF UNDERSERVED VULNERABLE RISK
GROUPS.
THANK YOU [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
BAHASA QUESTIONS WILL WAIT UNTIL
WE HAVE DAHLE THREE PANELS THAT
CSU.
YES SAID THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK HERE TODAY
MY NAME IS DENISE PROBABLY
OVERSEE -- STUDENT WELLNESS IN
THE BASIC NEEDS INITIATIVE FOR
THE CSU AND I'M HERE WITH MY
COLLEAGUE FRAMERATE MARIA WHO
OVERSEES -- STUDENT DIRECTOR OF
STUDENT PROGRAMS FOR THE CSU.
OUR CAMPUSES HEALTH MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICES PROVIDE A MERRY
OUT OF SERVICES TO SUPPORT
STUDENTS FOCUSING ON THE EFFORTS
ON EDUCATION OUTREACH TRAINING
AND A Q. CRISIS CARE.
ADDITIONALLY THIS YES YOU
ACTIVELY DEVELOPS AND
STRENGTHENS RELATIONSHIPS WITH
THE REGIONAL AND LOCAL AGENCIES
AND ORGANIZATIONS TO PROVIDE
COMPREHENSIVE CARE TO STUDENTS.
IN CASES WHERE STUDENTS NEEDS GO
ABOVE AND BEYOND CAMPUS
CAPABILITIES ALL CAMPUSES
PROVIDE IT'S THAT BASELINE
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES TO
STUDENTS AS OUTLINED IN
EXECUTIVE ORDER TEN FIFTY THREE
ON A POLICY ON STUDENT MENTAL
HEALTH WHICH INCLUDES COUNSELING.
SUICIDE AND VIOLENCE PREVENTION
AND SERVICES EMERGENCY CRISIS
INTERVENTIONS OUT REACH
CONSULTATION AND REFERRAL
RESOURCES.
OUR CAMPUS IS A SOUND THAT THEY
CAN ADDRESS STUDENTS MENTAL
HEALTH AND A VARIETY OF
INNOVATIVE WAYS WHICH BREAKS
DOWN THE STIGMA OF SEEKING HELP
AND ADDRESSES PROBLEMS IN A
HOLISTIC MANNER. FOR INSTANCE
THE REAL PROGRAM BEGAN ON ONE
CAMPUS THAT HAS NOW EXPANDED TO
SEVERAL OTHER CAMPUSES.
THE REAL PROBLEM PROGRAM IS A
SERIES OF EMOTIONAL WELL BEING
WORKSHOPS WHERE STUDENTS ARE
INVITED TO ATTEND SMALL FOCUS
SESSIONS THAT ADDRESS TOPICS.
THAT MAY BE LEADING TO ANXIETY
SUCH AS MANAGING THEIR FINANCES
WITHOUT EVEN NECESSARILY SAYING
THE WORDS MENTAL HEALTH THIS
PROGRAM CONNECTS STUDENTS WHO
MAY BE STRUGGLING WITH THE
RESOURCES THEY NEED TO ADDRESS
ANXIETIES.
AND FEEL MORE CONFIDENT.
AND THE LET'S TALK PROGRAM
CURRENTLY BEING UTILIZED ON
SEVERAL OF OUR CAMPUSES COUNTERS
MEET WITH STUDENTS AND HONEST
ANONYMOUSLY FOR TWENTY MINUTE
SESSIONS IN LOCATIONS AROUND
CAMPUS.
DURING WHICH THE COUNCIL
RECESSES THE STUDENTS NEED IT
MAY BE THAT THE STUDENT NEEDS TO
TALK THROUGH AN ISSUE OR THE
COUNTER MAY RECOMMEND THAT THEY
CONTINUE TO MEET AND SCHEDULE AN
APPOINTMENT.
THE PROGRAM HAS BEEN VERY
SUCCESSFUL BECAUSE OUR STUDENTS
ARE ABLE TO MEET WITH THE
COUNSELORS AND FAMILIAR SPACES.
SUCH AS THE ENGINEERING BUILDING
OR AT THE RESIDENCE HALL.
OUR PEER TO PEER PROGRAMS HAVE
ALSO BEEN SUCCESSFUL SUCH AS
ACTIVE MINES WHICH PROVIDES
EDUCATION AND TRAINING FOR
STUDENTS TO HELP OTHER STUDENTS
WHO ARE DEALING WITH A MENTAL
pHEALTH CHALLENGE.
THESE ARE EXAMPLES OF PART OF
THIS MODEL OF POLITICALLY
TREATING STUDENTS WELL BEING
THROUGH EARLY INTERVENTION.
AND INTERVENTION SERVICES AND
NEEDS WAYS WE ARE TRYING TO MEET
STUDENTS WHERE THEY ARE BOTH
PHYSICALLY AND GETTING OUTSIDE
OF THE COUNSELING CENTER BY
ENGAGING WITH THEM AT EVERY
STAGE OF THE SPECTRUM.
BECAUSE MENTAL HEALTH ASSISTANCE
IS NOT ONLY NEEDED FOR THOSE IN
CRISIS BUT SHOULD BE PROVIDED
ENCOURAGED LONG BEFORE AN
INDIVIDUAL REACHES THAT POINT.
AND TWENTY EIGHTEEN THE CSU USE
THE NATIONAL COLLEGE HEALTH
ASSESSMENT SURVEY TO ASSESS
STUDENT WELLNESS HEY HEALTH AND
SAFETY.
THE NCHA RESULTS PROVIDED A
COMPREHENSIVE PICTURE OF THE C.
ISSUES HEALTH AND STUDENT WELL
BEING.
FROM THE MENTAL HEALTH DATA WE
COULD SEE THAT CSU STUDENT
DEMAND FOR SERVICES HAS
INCREASED AND WE'RE
STRENGTHENING PARTNERSHIPS
INCREASING SERVICES AND RESPONSE
TO THAT DEMAND.
CAMPUSES HAVE INVESTED IN
ADDITIONAL COUNSELOR POSITIONS
AT A RATES ARE PASSING THE
GROWTH OF STUDENT HEAD COUNT.
BETWEEN FALL TWENTY TEN AND THE
PRELIMINARY DATA FOR FALL TWENTY
EIGHTEEN THIS YEAR'S TO INCREASE
THE NUMBER OF FULL TIME
EQUIVALENT COUNSELOR POSITIONS
BY 37%.
IT IS IMPORTANT TO NOTE THAT
THIS DOES NOT INCLUDE MANY OTHER
CAMPUS PERSONNEL WHO PLAY AN
IMPORTANT ROLE IN ADDRESSING
STUDENTS MENTAL HEALTH.
SUCH A POST DOCTORAL INTERNS TO
PROVIDE DIRECT SERVICES DOCTORS
PSYCHIATRISTS AND LICENSE SOCIAL
WORKER TO SERVE AT CASE MANAGERS.
THE PROCESS FOR STUDENTS SEEKING
MENTAL HEALTH CARE SERVICES
VARIES FROM CAMPUS TO CAMPUS AND
MOST CASES STUDENTS MAY ARRIVE
AT THE COUNTING CENTER AS A
RESULT OF A CAMPUS OUTREACH
PROGRAM AS A WALK IN FROM A
PHONE CALL.
OR BECAUSE THEY'RE EXPERIENCING
A CRISIS.
IN MANY CASES IT IS THROUGH THE
ASSISTANCE OF A FACULTY MEMBER
WHO HAS RECOGNIZED THE SIGNS
THAT THE STUDENTS EXPERIENCING
MENTAL HEALTH TO STRESS OR
THROUGH PEER TO PEER HEALTH
EDUCATION.
WHEN A STUDENT ARRIVES IN SEVERE
CRISIS MOST CAMPUSES ARE ABLE TO
ACCOMMODATE STUDENTS IN A MATTER
OF MINUTES OR HOURS WHERE THEY
ARE ABLE TO RECEIVE AN INITIAL
CONSULTATION APPOINTMENT WITH A
LICENSED PROFESSIONAL?
STUDENTS ARE THEN SCHEDULE FOR
THEIR FIRST VISIT WHEN THE
TREATMENT PLAN IS DETERMINED.
IF A STUDENT IN CRISIS THE
TREATMENT PLAN IS TYPICALLY
DETERMINED IMMEDIATELY.
THE TREATMENT PLAN IS
PERSONALIZED FOR EACH STUDENT
INCLUDES SOME COMBINATION OF
COUNSELING OR A COMMUNITY
REFERRAL IF THE STUDENTS NEEDS
ARE BEYOND CAMPUS CAPABILITIES.
AFTER THE TREATMENT PLANT HAS
BEEN UNDER WAY THE STUDENTS THE
MEETS BACK WITH THE LIGHTS AND
PROFESSIONAL ON CAMPUS TO REVIEW
AND RE WRITE THE TREATMENT PLAN
AS NEEDED.
THIS CYCLE CONTINUES UNTIL BOTH
THE STUDENT AND PROFESSIONAL
FEEL THE STUDENTS READY TO IN
THE PROCESS.
WE ARE CONTINUALLY WORKING TO AS
A SYSTEM TO STRENGTHEN THESE
PARTNERSHIPS WITH LOCAL AND
REGIONAL AGENCIES AND COMMUNITY
ORGANIZATIONS.
ARE FIFTEEN MILLION ONE TIME
BUDGET REQUEST FOR BASIC NEEDS
WOULD BE UTILIZED TO BUILDING
STRENGTH IN THESE RELATIONSHIPS
IN ORDER TO CREATE COMPREHENSIVE
CARE PATHWAYS FOR STUDENTS
EXPERIENCING BASIC NEEDS
CHALLENGES.
INCLUDING THOSE -- TO THEIR BASE
TO THEIR MENTAL HEALTH.
WE ARE GRATEFUL FOR ASSEMBLY
MEMBER MCCARTHY'S BILL THE CARD
IS BILL I'M AB SIXTEEN EIGHTY
NINE WHICH ALLOCATES FIVE
MILLION PROP SIXTY THREE DOLLARS
TO THE CSU PER YEAR TO WORK WITH
OUR COUNTY PARTNERS TO IMPROVE
STUDENTS ACCESS TO MIDDLE HEALTH
SERVICES.
AND EARLY IDENTIFICATION AND
INTERVENTION PROGRAM.
IN ADDITION TO CAMPUS EFFORTS TO
PROVIDE EDUCATION OUTREACH
TRAINING IN A QUEUE CRISIS CARE
THERE ARE NUMBER OF SYSTEM WIDE
INITIATIVES UNDER WAY.
THE CHANCES OFFICE HOST ANNUAL I
CAN HELP SUICIDE PREVENTION AND
WELL BEING IN BATH OR TRAINING.
BOTH BRING TOGETHER FACULTY AND
STAFF SYSTEM WIDE TO PROVIDE
RESOURCES TOOLS AND INFORMATION
TO SUPPORT SUICIDE PREVENTION
EFFORTS.
AND IMPROVING ACCESS TO MENTAL
HEALTH ACCESS THROUGH
APPROPRIATE REFERRALS.
WE ARE CURRENTLY WORKING TO
EXPAND THIS TRAINING TO REACH
ADDITIONAL FACULTY AND STAFF.
AS A RESULT OF A SYSTEM WIDE
GRANT FROM THE CALIFORNIA MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICES AT THE ALREADY
ALL CAMPUSES HAVE AT LEAST ONE
STAFF MEMBER THAT'S BEEN TRAINED
IN MENTAL HEALTH FOR STATE.
Q. P. R. OR THE ASSIST TRAIN THE
TRAINER PROGRAM WHICH TEACHES
PARTICIPANTS TO RECOGNIZE AND
HELP WHEN SOMEONE MAY HAVE
THOUGHTS OF SUICIDE.
AND JUST WEEKS AGO APRIL TENTH
THE SEATS YOU ACTED AS THE
CONVENER TO SUPPORT CAMPUS
EFFORTS TO DEVELOP COMMUNITY
PARTNERSHIPS BY HOSTING THE
FIRST EVER STATEWIDE CONVENING
ON COLLEGE STUDENT MENTAL HEALTH.
ALL TWENTY THREE CAMPUSES AND
FIFTEEN COUNTIES.
OUT OF THE EIGHTEEN THAT OVERLAP
WITH OUR CAMPUSES ATTENDED.
AS WELL AS HEADS OF STATE
PROGRAMS SUCH AS CAL MESA THE
PURPOSE OF THIS MEETING WHAT TO
CONNECT LOCAL COUNTY DEPARTMENT
OF MENTAL HEALTH WITH CAMPUS
MENTAL HEALTH DIRECTORS. TO
STAFF AND STAFF TO BEGIN TO
ADDRESS GAPS TO RESOURCES FOR
STUDENTS DEALING WITH BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH CHALLENGES.
WE ANTICIPATE THE PROCESS OF
DEVELOPING THESE RELATIONSHIPS
WILL IDENTIFY WAYS THAT CAMPUSES
AND COUNTIES CAN WORK ON
PRIORITIZING PARTNERSHIPS WITH
COLLEGE MENTAL HEALTH PROGRAMS.
AND SERVICES TO ALIGN WITH THE
PASSAGE OF SB.
ONE THOUSAND FOUR WE CAME AWAY
FROM THIS MEETING WITH THREE
MAIN GOALS ONE TO CREATE A
CONTACT LIST STATEWIDE OF CAMPUS
AND COUNTY.
DIRECTORS AND STAFF SO THAT THEY
CAN BEGIN TO HAVE THOSE
CONVERSATIONS ON AN ONGOING
BASIS.
THE SECOND IS TO HAVE A IN
PERSON MEETING BETWEEN CAMPUS
AND COUNTY OFFICIALS TO TALK
ABOUT GAPS IN AREAS AND WE'RE
RESOURCES ARE NEEDED.
AND THE THIRD IS TO CREATE AN
ONGOING REGIONAL MEETING SO THAT
CAMPUS ISN'T COUNTIES IN CLOSE
PROXIMITY CAN SHARE BEST
PRACTICES CHALLENGES.
AND WAYS TO OVERCOME BARRIERS IN
RELATIONSHIP TO THE CONTEXT OF
THESE SPECIFIC REGIONS.
AS WE CONTINUE TO PURSUE OUR
GRADUATION INITIATIVE TWENTY
TWENTY FIVE GOALS INVESTMENTS IN
OUR STUDENTS MENTAL HEALTH AND
THEIR OVER WHILE WELL BEING.
I INVESTMENTS IN STUDENT SUCCESS
AND TIMELY GRADUATION WE THANK
YOU FOR YOUR TIME AND WELCOME
YOUR QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU.
AND NEXT OUR COMMUNITY COLLEGE
REPRESENTATIVE.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHARLIE MCCARTY
AND MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
SPEAK WITH YOU TODAY ABOUT THE
MENTAL HEALTH NEEDS OF
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGE
STUDENTS.
HI MY NAME IS COLLEEN GANLEY AND
I'M A PROGRAM SPECIALIST WITH
THE STATE CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE
AND I'VE HAD THE GOOD FORTUNE OF
WORKING WITH OUR HUNDREDS OF
HEALTH AND MENTAL HEALTH
PROFESSIONALS WITHIN THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGE SYSTEM FOR
CLOSE TO A DECADE -- WE'VE
WORKED VERY VERY CLOSELY ON
MULTIPLE ACTIVITIES INCLUDING
PREVIOUS FUND FUNDING PROVIDED
THROUGH PROP SIXTY THREE OR THE
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES ACARIDAE
GRANT MAKING TO THIRTY OF THE
COLLEGES AND DID.
MANY STATEWIDE INITIATIVES TO
SUPPORT THE PREVENTION AND EARLY
INTERVENTION SERVICES AVAILABLE
TO COMMUNITY COLLEGE STUDENTS.
I'M A LITTLE BIT OF BACKGROUND
OUR INFRASTRUCTURE FOR HEALTH
AND MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES IN
THE COMMUNITY COLLEGE SYSTEM IS
VERY VERY DIFFERENT THAN THAT OF
THE UC AND THE CSU SYSTEMS -- WE
ARE A DECENTRALIZED SYSTEM OF
OUR HUNDRED FOURTEEN SCHOOLS WE
HAVE SEVENTY BRICK AND MORTAR
HEALTH CENTERS ACROSS OUR
CAMPUSES MANY OF WHOM PROVIDE
HEALTH AND MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES -- WE HAVE DONE SOME
RESEARCH ACROSS OUR SYSTEM AND
HAVE IDENTIFIED NINETY OF THE
SCHOOLS COMMUNITY COLLEGES THAT
ARE PROVIDING MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES TO THEIR STUDENTS
HOWEVER.
THOSE THE SCALE AND THE SCOPE OF
SERVICES AVAILABLE ARE VERY
LIMITED -- MOST MOST OFTEN ONE
TO THREE MENTAL HEALTH SESSIONS
PER SEMESTER IS ABOUT THE
MAXIMUM THAT STUDENTS CAN ACCESS --
GENERALLY SPEAKING WE HAVE ONE
TWO FOUR PROVIDERS AT A GIVEN
COLLEGE MANY OF WHOM ARE PART
TIME REGARDLESS OF THE SIZE OF
THE STUDENT BODY SO THAT COULD
BE ONE TO FOUR PART TIME MENTAL
HEALTH PROVIDERS. FOR A STUDENT
BODY OF THE SIZE OF ABOUT TWENTY
FIVE THOUSAND THAT SOME OF OUR
CAMPUSES SO YOU CAN SEE THAT
WERE NOT VERY CLOSE TO MEETING --
STATE RECOGNIZED RATIOS OF
STUDENT TO COUNSELOR -- WHAT
THERE ARE ABLE TO OFFER IS QUITE
LIMITED ALL THE COLLEGES HAVE
PROTOCOL REGARDING CRISIS
INTERVENTION FOR STUDENTS
PRESENTING IMMEDIATE MENTAL
HEALTH CRISIS?
AND THE MAJORITY OF THE COLLEGES
HAVE MENTAL HEALTH CRISIS TEAMS
THAT HELP ADDRESS STUDENTS THAT
ARE IN DISTRESS -- WE COLLECT
VERY LIMITED CENTRALIZED DATA
AROUND MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES TO
COMMUNITY COLLEGE STUDENTS.
THOUGH BASED ON AN INFORMAL
SURVEY ACROSS OUR HEALTH AND
MENTAL HEALTH PROFESSION
PROFESSIONALS EXCUSE ME -- WE
ESTIMATE THAT THE MAJORITY OF
STUDENTS HAVE AT LEAST A ONE TO
THREE WEEK WAIT FOR AN
APPOINTMENT THOUGH THESE WAIT
TIMES DUE VERY ACROSS THE SYSTEM.
MOST OF THE CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY
COLLEGES CHARGE A HEALTH SERVICE
FEE WHICH FUNDS MUCH OF THIS
WORK IT'S TWENTY ONE DOLLARS PER
SEMESTER PER STUDENT.
SO YOU CAN GET A PRETTY GOOD
IDEA OF THE LEVEL OF SERVICE
THAT MIGHT BE AVAILABLE TO THE
STUDENTS AT TWENTY ONE DOLLARS A
SEMESTER PER STUDENT -- THE
LARGER CAMPUSES HAVE LARGER
HEALTH CENTER BUDGETS BUT
THEY'RE STILL LIMITED BECAUSE
THIS IS SUPPOSED TO COVER THE
FULL SCOPE OF HEALTH AND MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICES AVAILABLE TO THE
STUDENTS.
WE WERE FORTUNATE IN THE
SEVENTEEN EIGHTEEN BUDGET WE GOT --
PROP NINETY EIGHT FUNDS OF FOR A
HALF MILLION DOLLARS TO PROVIDE
TO THE COLLEGES WE DID GRANT OF
COMPETITIVE GRANT MAKING PROCESS
AND SELECTED FIFTEEN DISTRICTS
WHICH ENCOMPASS TWENTY SEVEN
COMMUNITY COLLEGES.
THEY RECEIVED GRANTS BETWEEN TWO
HUNDRED AND FIFTY THOUSAND AND
THREE HUNDRED FIFTY THOUSAND
DEPENDING ON THE SCOPE OF WHAT
WAS IN THEIR APPLICATION.
I'M WE DID HAVE SOME
ADMINISTRATIVE DELAYS HOWEVER
THOSE GRANT DOLLARS ARE OUT TO
THE COLLEGE AND BEING
OPERATIONALIZED THERE TO BE
PROVIDING DIRECT SERVICES TO
STUDENTS TO PROVIDE FACULTY AND
STAFF AND STUDENTS TRAINING
AROUND PREVENTION AND EARLY
INTERVENTION AND SUICIDE
PREVENTION.
AND TO INCREASE RELATIONSHIPS
WITH COUNTY BEHAVIORAL HEALTH --
WE DO HAVE A FULL DIRECTORY THAT
WE PROVIDE TO THE COLLEGES THAT
TELLS THEM WHO IS THERE AN HSA
COUNTERPART IN THEIR COUNTY --
WE HAVE STARTED CONVERSATIONS
WITH THEM TO BRIDGE THOSE
RELATIONSHIPS I THINK SOMETIMES
HOWEVER -- THE COUNTY BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH DEPARTMENTS AREN'T ALWAYS
AS STUDENT ORIENTED -- AS ONE
MIGHT HOPE -- A LOT OF TIMES THE
STUDENTS THAT ARE -- HAVE LESS A
LESSER DEGREE OF MENTAL ILLNESS
OR UNLESS YOU KNOW THEY HAVE
DEPRESSION OR ANXIETY THEY DON'T
NECESSARILY MEET THE CRITERIA.
OF WHAT COUNTY BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
REQUIRES IN TERMS OF GETTING
SERVICE SO THEY DON'T HAVE A
SERIOUS AND SIGNIFICANT --
MENTAL HEALTH DIAGNOSIS -- SO
THEY DON'T MEET THE ELIGIBILITY
FOR COUNTY SERVICES IN EVERY
INSTANCE INSIDE I THINK IT'S
WORTH NOTING -- IT IS MY
UNDERSTANDING THAT THE MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICE ACT THE PROP
SIXTY THREE THAT A PRETTY
FUNDS IS SUPPOSED TO BE DIRECTED
TO FOR PERSONS UNDER THE AGE OF
TWENTY FIVE IT WOULD BE.
HELPFUL TO KNOW IF THAT IS IN
FACT THE CASE -- AS I MENTIONED
EARLIER WE WERE VERY VERY
SUCCESSFUL AT OUR PARTICIPATION
IN THE MENTAL HEALTH SERVICE ACT
FUNDING THAT CAME TO ALL THREE
SYSTEMS IN.
TWO THOUSAND ELEVEN WE SAW AN
INCREDIBLE -- GROUND SWELL OF
WORK AND STIGMA REDUCTION AND
AWARENESS ABOUT THE NEEDS OF OUR
STUDENTS ON CAMPUS SO WE ARE
VERY MUCH IN SUPPORT OF ASSEMBLY
BILL.
SIXTEEN EIGHTY NINE AND LOOK
FORWARD TO THE OPPORTUNITY TO
PARTICIPATE IN THAT -- WE IN
EIGHTEEN NINETEEN WE ALSO DID
GET A TEN MILLION DOLLAR ONE
TIME ALLOCATION FOR MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICES ACROSS OUR
SYSTEM WE APPROPRIATED THAT TO
ALL HUNDRED AND FOURTEEN
COLLEGES BASED ON F. T. E. S. --
WE HAVE A REPORT THAT WILL BE
PROVIDING TO YOU ON THE OUTCOMES
OF THOSE DOLLARS ON JULY.
ONE WE DO HAVE A LITTLE BIT OF
DATA THAT WE WOULD LIKE TO SHARE
WE HAD A CONSORTIUM OF TEN
COMMUNITY COLLEGES THAT
PARTICIPATED IN.
THE NATIONAL COLLEGE HEALTH
ASSESSMENT -- BACK IN TWO
THOUSAND SIXTEEN WE COLLECTED
SURVEYS FROM US SEVENTY FOUR
HUNDRED STUDENTS AND OF THOSE
STUDENTS TO THIS NATIONAL
COLLEGE HEALTH ASSESSMENT --
TWENTY FOUR POINT 8% OF STUDENTS
REPORTED ANXIETY LEVELS THAT WAS
IMPACTING AND IMPEDING THEM
ACADEMICALLY -- SEVENTEEN POINT
3% OF THOSE STUDENTS REPORTED TO
PUT LEVELS OF DEPRESSION THAT
WERE IMPACTING THEM ACADEMICALLY --
FIFTY EIGHT POINT 9% WERE
FEELING HOPELESS.
A 55% FILLED OVERWHELMING
ANXIETY THIRTY EIGHT POINT 8%
FELT SO DEPRESSED IT WAS
DIFFICULT TO FUNCTION. 11%
CONSIDERED SERIOUSLY CONSIDERED
SUICIDE AND 2% ATTEMPTED SUICIDE --
AND WHEN YOU CONSIDER THAT WE
HAVE TWO POINT TWO MILLION
STUDENTS IF YOU EXTRAPOLATED
THOSE FIGURES ACROSS OUR ENTIRE
STUDENT BODY -- THERE WOULD BE A
VERY SIGNIFICANT NEED REFLECTED
AND SO -- I'M OPEN TO ANY
QUESTIONS YOU HAVE WE LOOK
FORWARD.
TO THE ON GOING DISCUSSION ABOUT
SIXTEEN EIGHTY NINE AND THE
OPPORTUNITY TO PARTICIPATE IN
AND PROP SIXTY THREE FUNDING.
OKAY THANK YOU LET ME ASK A
QUESTION FOR ALL OF THE SEGMENTS
SO.
OF COURSE WE KNOW THERE'S
THERE'S A BIG.
I NEED HERE WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
IT GOT RIGHT NOW AND ONGOING
MONEY WOULD BE BETTER THAN ONE
TIME MONEY OF COURSE SPECIALLY
WITH PERSONNEL AND STAFFING.
SO WE DID GIVE THE COMMITTEE
CALLS AS ONE ONE TIME MONEY LAST
YEAR THAN YOU SEE YOU MENTION
YOUR YOUR ONE TIME.
IF YOU DIDN'T HAVE IT OF COURSE
WE'RE GONNA TEND TO TO LOOK AT
ONGOING AND WE'RE OF AS YOU
MENTIONED LOOKING AT THE PROP
SIXTY THREE STATE ADMIN -- A POT
OF MONEY WHICH GOES FOR STATE
WHY PRIORITIES AND YOU KNOW
THERE'S A DESIRE TO HELP YOUNGER
PEOPLE AND WE THINK DECIDED BE
AT STATEWIDE PRIORITY -- SO BUT
BUT IF IF THERE IS ONLY A CHANCE
TO GET ONE TIME MONEY.
HOW DO YOU HOW DO YOU TAKE CARE
THAT THE CAMPUS?
TO HIRED LIMITED TERM POSITIONS
IS IT.
IS IT YOU DO LIKE A CONTRACT TO
WEAR WITH WITH YOUR
PROFESSIONALS THESE MENTAL
HEALTH PROFESSIONALS AT HOW
LOGISTICALLY DE DO THAT I'M NOT
SURE THIS IS THE QUESTION FOR
YOU OR YOUR FOR YOUR BUDGET
PEOPLE BUT WELL NO I THINK I CAN
ANSWER THAT -- THESE FOR US --
SO I'M WE'VE TALKED ABOUT THAT
AND UNFORTUNATELY WHEN YOU KNOW
WHEN YOU YOU RECRUIT TO TRY TO
RETAIN OR HIRE SOMEBODY -- FOR A
LIMITED CONTRACT POSITION THAT
HAS AN EXPIRATION YOU GET A
COMPLETELY DIFFERENT POOL OF
CANDIDATES YOU YOU'RE NOT
DEALING NECESSARILY WITH THE
SAME KINDS OF OF PROVIDERS OR OR
QUALITY.
AND IF IF WE WERE UNABLE TO GET
AS I MENTIONED BEFORE IF WE WERE
ABLE TO GET ONE TIME MONEY THAN
THAT COULD SUSTAIN SOME OF OUR
CURRENT PROVIDERS WHO ARE
CURRENTLY AT RISK.
IF THE AMOUNT OF MONEY WAS
SUFFICIENT TO ALSO DO SOME
TARGETED PREVENTION WORK THAT
PROBABLY BE OUR NEXT PRIORITY IF
NO MONEY COMES IN AS I MENTIONED
EARLIER -- WE WOULD HAVE TO LET
GO PROVIDERS THAT WE THAT WE
PART AND HOW ABOUT FOR THE OTHER.
OTHERS I WOULD SAY IT'S A
SIMILAR SITUATION THE THE
INVESTMENTS THAT HAVE BEEN MADE
OVER THE LAST TWO FISCAL YEARS
HAVE REALLY ALLOW THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGES TO RAMP UP.
THE NUMBER OF PROFESSIONALS THAT
THEY HAVE AVAILABLE TO THE
STUDENTS IT THESE DOLLARS HAVE
ALSO ALLOWED FOR THE DEVELOPMENT
OF INTERNSHIP PROGRAMS WHERE OUR
COUNTERPART TO THE FOUR YEAR
COLLEGES BRING THEIR MSW
STUDENTS -- ONTO OUR CAMPUSES TO
PROVIDE SERVICES SO A LOT OF THE
SCHOOLS HAVE CREATED SOME
INFRASTRUCTURE AROUND LEVERAGING
THE FOUR YEAR COLLEGES AND THEIR
GRADUATE STUDENTS --IF THE
MONEY.
I'M GONNA SAY THAT ONE TIME
MONEY IS IS GOOD BETTER THAN NO
TIME MONEY YEAH -- I LIKE THAT
NO TIME.
I DON'T MEAN TO BE SO CASUAL --
ONGOING MONEY WOULD BE GREAT BUT
I THINK WHAT WILL HAPPEN IS
PEOPLE WILL BE LAID OFF YEAH
WHAT ABOUT HIRING PEOPLE WHO ARE
IN THE PROFESSION.
WE DON'T TO LAY THEM OFF IN
OTHER WORDS YOU WANT MENTAL
HEALTH PROFESSIONALS ON CAMPUS.
AND THERE'S MENTAL HEALTH
PROFESSIONALS WHO HAVE MAYBE A
PRACTICE.
AND YOU COULD CONSULT WITH THEM
TO COME OVER AND SPEND TEN HOURS
A WEEK AT YOUR COMMITTEE COLLEGE
CAMPUS AS OPPOSED TO BEING AT
THEIR AT THEIR OFFICE WHEREVER
THEY'RE AT AND SO YOU'RE NOT.
NECESSARILY -- HIRING PEOPLE
LAYING PEOPLE OFF BUT YOU KNOW
WHAT IF YOUR STUDENT.
YOU DON'T CARE IF THE PERSON TO
HELP YOU THAT DAY OR THE NEXT
WEEK.
AS AN EMPLOYEE LEADERS
CALIFORNIA OR IS -- YOU KNOW
JAMES MENTAL HEALTH PROGRAM AND
WHAT I WOULD SAY IS I THINK MANY
OF THE COMMUNITY COLLEGES DO
HAVE SUCH ARRANGEMENTS THAT THEY
DON'T NECESSARILY AREN'T
CARRYING THE FULL OVERHEAD.
OF A 100% OF THE COST OF A
MENTAL HEALTH PROFESSIONAL AT
EACH OF THE CAMPUS IS SPECIALLY
FOR SMALLER CAMPUSES SO I THINK
THAT IS ACTUALLY THE PRACTICE
THAT HAPPENS.
IN MANY OF THE SMALLER COLLEGES
WHERE THEY CONTRACT FOR CERTAIN
NUMBER OF HOURS WITH
PROFESSIONAL OKAY DID THAT CSU
FOLKS WHEN THE SAME THING HERE.
WELL I THINK FOR US WE'RE WE'RE
LOOKING AT PARTNERSHIP AS BEING
KIND OF THE CRUX OF ARM MIDDLE
HOLE SUPPORT -- BECAUSE OUR
CAMPUSES AS WELL OR NOT
NECESSARILY COMFORTABLE WITH
HIRING -- MORE PEOPLE WITHOUT IT
BEING ON GOING SO WHAT WE'RE
TRYING TO DO AND ACTUALLY ONE OF
OUR MODELS -- AT CSU SAN
BERNARDINO AS THEY WORK WITH THE
COUNTY AND THE COUNTY PROVIDES
AND A PERSON A COUNSELOR CASE
MANAGER TO THAT ACTUALLY SEES
STUDENTS ON CAMPUS.
AND SO THIS IS ONE OF THE MODELS
WE WOULD LIKE TO SEE EXPANDED
WITH THE POTENTIAL OF SIXTEEN
EIGHTY NINE AND THEN ALSO -- THE
SB ONE THOUSAND FOUR DOLLARS SO
WE'RE THINKING ABOUT
PARTNERSHIPS UNDERSTANDING THAT --
ALLY THE NEED TO DO GO BEYOND
THE CAMPUS SCOPE AND HOW WE'RE
ABLE TO LEVERAGE -- LEVERAGE
THAT WITH OUR COUNTY
PARTNERSHIPS.
SO I ACTUALLY DO AN AD REMEDIAL
FROM THE CSU OFFICE OF THE
CHANCELLOR AS WELL ON THE IDEA
OF THE CONTRACTED A WORKERS WE
ACTUALLY DO THAT WITH PSYCHIATRY.
PSYCHIATRY'S ONE OF THE BIGGEST
HIGHEST NEED THAT WE'RE FINDING
IN OUR SYSTEM BUT IT STILL COMES
WITH CHALLENGES BECAUSE IT'S A
CHI TREES IN HIGH DEMAND ON
CAMPUS AS WELL AS OFF CAMPUS OF
THEIR TIME IS LIMITED.
AS WELL AS THE COST IS VERY VERY
HIGH YEAH -- SO THE MENTAL
HEALTH CERTAINLY WE HAVE SOME
COMMUNITIES THAT DO HAVE SOME
PROVIDERS THAT COULD IN FACT BE
AVAILABLE ON A RETAINER TO HELP
OUT PERIODICALLY ON OUR CAMPUSES.
THERE ARE OTHER COMMUNITIES LIKE
HUMBOLDT THAT THEY'RE JUST DON'T
EXIST SO THEY'RE GONNA BE
STRAPPED JUST BECAUSE IT
AVAILABILITY OF PROVIDERS BUT
ALSO IT WOULD ANTICIPATE AND
HAVING CONTRACTED WORK.
WE WOULD MOST LIKELY PROBABLY
RUN INTO SOME COLLECTIVE
BARGAINING ISSUES ON THAT
[inaudible]
OKAY [inaudible]
OKAY.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH LET'S NEXT --
BRING OUT FOR SEASON QUESTIONS
FOR THE FOLKS.
SACRAMENTO BEE AT OF FRONT PAGE
STORY I BELIEVE YESTERDAY ON THE
BERKELEY STUDY ON A MENTAL
HEALTH.
IN -- IN IN HIGHER EDUCATION NOT
ONLY IN CALIFORNIA BUT ACROSS
THE UNITED STATES.
AND I I I I THINK THE THE
BERKELEY STUDY -- WAS VERY --
VERY MUCH -- SHOWING THE SAME
KIND OF DATA THAT I'M LOOKING AT
HERE ON THE ESCALATING DEMAND.
OF FROM FROM UC -- WHEN WE WERE
ON AT ON THE UCLA CAMPUS WE
HEARD A LOT FROM STUDENTS ABOUT
THE NEED FOR OF PRACTITIONERS
WHO REFLECTED THEIR THEIR THEIR
THEIR CULTURES THEIR LANGUAGES --
SO WONDERED IF YOU MIGHT WANT TO
COMMENT ON EITHER OF THOSE TWO
THINGS SURE I'LL JUST MENTION IN
OUR IN OUR FIVE YEAR INITIATIVE
THAT WE HAD -- UNDERTAKEN IN --
TWENTY FIFTEEN MORE THAN 50% OF
THOSE PROVIDERS WERE -- WE
ATTEMPTED TO FILL THOSE
POSITIONS WITH -- A PROVIDERS
WITH BACKGROUNDS ETHNICITIES
WILL -- THE KINDS OF COUNSELORS --
THAT REFLECTED OUR STATE BETTER
REFLECTED OUR STUDENT POPULATION --
AND SO THAT'S AS I MENTIONED
EARLIER ONE OF THE THINGS THAT
WERE WORRIED ABOUT THOSE
PROVIDERS ARE ALWAYS HARDER TO
FIND HARDER TO RECRUIT AND
HARDER TO RETAIN.
AND SO WE HAVE BEEN ABLE TO TO
HIRE -- I THINK OUT OF THE
SEVENTY THAT I MENTIONED US.
IT'S CLOSE TO FIFTY OF THOSE
PROVIDERS WERE WERE TARGETED BY
THEIR CAMPUSES BASED ON THE
CAMPUS THE CIVIC POPULATIONS.
STRATEGY THANK YOU I APOLOGIZE
FOR COMING IN LATE AND SO -- THE
PLEASE SOMEONE TELL ME IF IF YOU
COVER THIS BUT TO WE WE WE'VE
BEEN HAVING TO SEVERAL.
HEARINGS -- IN THE AT ADDRESSING
GO -- IN ONE WAY OR ANOTHER --
THE STUDENT MENTAL HEALTH --
NEEDS WHAT IS DRIVING THIS.
THIS ESCALATING DEMAND AND
INCREASING SEVERITY OF ILLNESS
BUT YOU KNOW I I I THINK IT'S
MULTI FACTORIAL AND EVERYBODY
HERE COULD PROBABLY COMMENT I I
THINK THAT -- A NUMBER OF THINGS
LOWERING THE STIGMA SO A LOT OF
THE WORK THAT WE'VE DONE
ACTUALLY MAKES IT MORE LIKELY
THAT STUDENTS WILL COME IN WHO
HAVE LOWER LEVEL SYMPTOMATOLOGY
THEY'RE MORE WILLING TO COME IN
IT'S NOT A SCARY IF THEY START.
TO THINK THEY MIGHT HAVE -- AN
ISSUE WITH THAT MIGHT BE YOU
KNOW WORKED OUT THROUGH THROUGH
COUNSELING SO SO THAT'S THAT'S A
VERY BIG FACTOR I THINK.
YOU KNOW THIS THIS --
GENERATIONAL COHORT AND AND THAT
KIND OF ENVIRONMENT THEY'VE
GROWN UP IN I THINK AGAIN WE
HAVE MANY MORE UNDOCUMENTED
STUDENTS THE POLITICAL SITUATION
CERTAINLY IS PUTTING A LOT OF
STRESS ON ON MANY MANY STUDENTS --
FINANCIAL PRESSURES -- CONCERNED --
ABOUT THEIR WELL BEING ON CAMPUS
OR IF THEY ENGAGE WITH STUDENT
HEALTH AND COUNSELLING OR WHAT
HOW WITH THOSE RECORDS
POTENTIALLY BE USED AGAINST THEM --
WE HAVE MORE TRANSFER STUDENTS
AND THEY I THINK HAVE A UNIQUE
CHALLENGES COMPARED TO SOMEONE --
WHO WHO WHO COMES ON SO I THINK
YOU KNOW GREAT COMPETITION --
THEY'RE USED TO BEING OF THE
BRIGHTEST -- OF THEIR CLASSES IN
HIGH SCHOOL AND THEY ARRIVE AT
UNIVERSITIES AND NOW EVERYBODY'S
AT THAT LEVEL OF THOUGHT HIGHER
AND SUDDENLY SOMEBODY WHO'S BEEN
A STRAIGHT A STUDENT IS GETTING
A LOT OF BEES IN THE FIRST.
QUARTER OR SEMESTER AND AND AND
IT'S A YOU KNOW IT'S AN ADAPTION
THEY HAVE TO MAKE SO I I DON'T
KNOW IF MY OTHER COLLEAGUES HAVE
OTHER.
THOUGHTS ABOUT THE STRONGEST
FACTORS BUT IT'S REALLY A LOT OF
THINGS HAPPENING.
SIMULTANEOUSLY YOU KNOW ONE
THING I THINK THAT THAT YOU
ALLUDED TO AND YOU KNOW WHEN WE
DID THE SIGNIFICANT WORK BACK
STARTING IN TWO THOUSAND ELEVEN
AT WITH AN HSA PROP SIXTY THREE
DOLLARS.
I THINK ACROSS ALL THREE SYSTEMS --
THERE WAS A LOT OF WORK AND WORK
CONTINUES AROUND REDUCING STIGMA.
AND AROUND TO CULTURAL
COMPETENCE AND ADDRESSING THE
UNIQUE NEEDS OF DIFFERENT
STUDENT POPULATIONS INCLUDING
THAT INCLUDING LATINO STUDENTS
INCLUDING.
STUDENTS OF COLOR WHO WHERE FROM
THEIR CULTURES THERE MAY BE TOO
MUCH STIGMA ASSOCIATED WITH THEM
ACCESSING CARE AND THEN THEY
FIND SOME INDEPENDENCE WHEN THEY
COME TO COLLEGE IN WHEN YOU'RE
WORKING ON REDUCING STIGMA.
AND YOU'RE MAKING IT OKAY TO GET
HELP -- I THINK IT'S NOT A BAD
THING FOR PEOPLE TO GET HELP I
THINK -- THAT SOME OF THE
INCREASE IN ACCESSING SERVICES
HAS TO DO WITH THAT REDUCTION
AND STIGMA.
AND REALLY HELPS -- TO REDUCE
MORE CATASTROPHIC MENTAL ILLNESS
IF IF LEFT UNADDRESSED AND SO
IT'S YOU KNOW THIS CATCH TWENTY
TWO TO REDUCE STIGMA.
AND TO BRING GREATER AWARENESS
AND TO MAKE IT OKAY TO ACCESS
HELP.
ON THAT INCREASES SERVICES THAT
PUTS MORE PRESSURE ON THE
INSTITUTIONS TO TRY TO PROVIDE
THAT HELP -- BUT I THINK IN THE
BIGGER PICTURE IT HELPS TO
REDUCE.
ONGOING LIFETIME CATASTROPHIC
MENTAL ILLNESS AND PREVENTION
AND EARLY INTERVENTION SERVICES
HAVE PROVEN.
THAT THAT HELPS CURTAIL THAT
LIFETIME OF MENTAL ILLNESS IF
LEFT UNTREATED.
OKAY THANK YOU LET'S THAT BRING
UP THE NEXT PANEL ON THE SAME
TOPIC.
IF YOU HAVE A REPRESENTATIVE
FROM THAT STEINBERG INSTITUTE
WORK ON MENTAL HEALTH ISSUES
ADRIN SHELTON.
AS WELL AS A STUDENT
REPRESENTATIVE.
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS I'M ADRIAN SHELTON AND
I'M FROM THE STEINBERG INSTITUTE.
THE STEINBERG INSTITUTE WAS
FOUNDED BY SACRAMENTO'S MAYOR
AND FORMER PRO TEM OF THE SENATE
DARRELL STEINBERG.
AND OUR MISSION IS TO ADVANCE
PUBLIC POLICY INSPIRED
LEADERSHIP ON THE ISSUES OF
MENTAL HEALTH.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR HAVING
US TODAY -- ENJOYING THIS REALLY
WONDERFUL PANEL DISCUSSION TO
ELEVATE THE IMPORTANCE OF
STUDENT MENTAL HEALTH IN OUR
STATE.
IT'S SO CLEAR TO US THAT WE HAVE
DEDICATED PARTNERS FROM THE
COLLEGES WHO BELIEVE LIKE US THE
MORE NEEDS TO BE DONE TO ADDRESS
STUDENT MENTAL HEALTH.
WE HAVE THE STEINBERG AS A TO
BELIEVE THAT WE ARE AT A TIPPING
POINT.
WITH REGARD TO MENTAL HEALTH
CARE IN OUR STATE.
AND WE'RE GRATEFUL TO THIS
COMMITTEE AND STAFF IN YOUR
LEADERSHIP. TO REALLY BRING
ATTENTION TO WHAT WHAT WE THINK
IS THE CIVIL RIGHTS ISSUE OF OUR
TIME.
STUDENT ACCESS TO MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES GOES HAND IN HAND WITH
SUCCESS.
IN COLLEGE.
BUT WE KNOW THAT OFTEN STUDENTS
DO NOT HAVE ACCESS TO NEEDED AND
LIFESAVING.
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES AND
SUPPORTS WHEN THEY NEED THEM THE
MOST.
AND THAT'S WHY WE ARE SPONSORING
ASSEMBLY BILL SIXTEEN EIGHTY
NINE WHICH IS AUTHORED BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MCCARTY.
WHICH WOULD SET UP A COMPETITIVE
GRANT PROGRAM FOR THE PUBLIC
COLLEGES AND UNIVERSITIES IN OUR
STATE.
FUNDED BY MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES
ACT STATE ADMINISTRATIVE DOLLARS.
TO INVEST SPECIFICALLY AND
STUDENT MENTAL HEALTH.
WE SET A FRAMEWORK IN THE BILL
SO IT DOES NOT DICTATE THE LOCAL
SOLUTION.
PRIORITIES AROUND PARTNERSHIPS
WITH THE COMMUNITY EITHER THE
COUNTIES ARE COMMUNITY BASED
AGENCIES.
AND ALSO PROGRAMS THAT TARGET
UNDERSERVED COMMUNITIES SUCH AS
LGBT OR VETERANS OR VICTIMS OF
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE OR COMMUNITIES
THAT HAVE EXPERIENCE RACIAL --
INEQUITIES.
WE KNOW THAT PUBLIC COLLEGES IN
MANY CASES DO NOT MEET THE
NATIONAL STOPPING STANDARDS FOR
PSYCHIATRIC SERVICES OR OTHER
MENTAL HEALTH PROFESSIONALS.
AND THAT ACCESS TO MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES ON PUBLIC COLLEGE
CAMPUSES VERY IS AS AS WE HAVE
HEARD TODAY AND THIS IS THE
REASON WHY WE'RE SPONSORING AB.
SIXTEEN EIGHTY NINE AND WHY WE
WORK ON YEAR AFTER YEAR ON
STUDENT MENTAL HEALTH
INVESTMENTS.
BECAUSE WE REALLY OUR VISION IS
THAT EVERY CALL EVERY PUBLIC
COLLEGE CAMPUS IN CALIFORNIA HAS.
A COMPREHENSIVE PLAN. TO RAISE
AWARENESS OF THE SYMPTOMS OF
MENTAL ILLNESS.
IDENTIFY STUDENTS AT RISK AND
PROVIDE THOSE NEEDED SUPPORTS
AND PROVIDE THOSE LINKAGES TO
OUR PARTNERS IN THE COMMUNITY.
WE ALSO KNOW THAT THE COLLEGES
UNDERSTAND THIS NEED AND WE HAVE
SEEN THIS PLAY OUT ACROSS THE
STATE WE'VE ALSO HEARD TODAY
UPDATES FROM THE SEGMENTS ON THE
CSU MENTIONED THAT.
WE LOVE THIS THAT THEY HAD --
RECENTLY CONVENED -- HEALTH
CAMPUS DIRECTORS WITH THE
COUNTIES TO TALK ABOUT BEST
PRACTICES WHEN IT COMES TO
STUDENT MENTAL HEALTH -- IN
TWENTY FIFTEEN AND SIXTEEN THE
UC REGENTS EARMARKED FUNDING TO
HIRE ADDITIONAL EIGHTY FIVE
CLINICIANS ACROSS THEIR SYSTEM.
AND WE KNOW THAT MANY OF THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGES DESPITE THEIR
FUNDING CONSTRAINTS ARE STEPPING
UP TO ADDRESS THIS ISSUE -- BUT
THE BOTTOM LINE IS IS THIS FROM
OUR PERSPECTIVE THE STEINBERG
INSTITUTE IS THAT.
THE AVAILABILITY OF STUDENT
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES -- MUST
BE A STATEWIDE PRIORITY BECAUSE
MENTAL HEALTH PROFESSIONALS CAN
MAKE SUCH A DIFFERENCE IN THE
LIVES.
OF STUDENTS.
AND IT'S IMPORTANT THAT
CALIFORNIA INTERVIEWS WITH YOUNG
PEOPLE AS THE MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES ACT WAS DESIGNED TO
DEAL.
SO WE BELIEVE THAT AB SIXTEEN
EIGHTY NINE FURTHERS THIS INTENT.
ADDRESSES THE MENTAL HEALTH
NEEDS OF OUR YOUTH.
AND CALLS OUT MEANT STUDENT
MENTAL HEALTH IS A STATE WIDE
PRIORITY THAT IT MUST BE.
AND SO I'M VERY PLEASED TO BE
HERE TODAY WITH MARY ELIZABETH
ALEXANDER WHO IS A STUDENT AT
SACRAMENTO CITY COLLEGE TO SHARE.
SOME OF HER EXPERIENCE.
HEY -- MY NAME IS MARY ELIZABETH
ALEXANDER AND LIKE SHE SAID I'M
A STUDENT AT SAC CITY COLLEGE
AND I'D LIKE TO TALK ABOUT MY
OWN MENTAL HEALTH EXPERIENCES
WHILE I'VE BEEN IN COLLEGE.
AND I'VE STRUGGLED WITH BOTH
DEPRESSION AND ANXIETY SINCE
CHILDHOOD AND HAVE BEEN
DIAGNOSED WITH SOCIAL ANXIETY IN
PTSD.
IN COLLEGE I FELT THE CRUSHING
DREAD OF THE FUTURE AND OF
POTENTIAL FAILURE AND THE HIGH
PRESSURE OF MY CLASSES.
THEN THERE IS THE FEAR AND
UNCERTAINTY OF MY CLASSMATES
FEEDING INTO MY OWN AN EASE.
I WOULD SET EVERY DAY IN CLASSES
ON ALLOWED.
BUSTLING CAMPUS AS MY SOCIAL
ANXIETY MADE ME WANT TO HIDE.
I STARTED MISSING CLASSES
BECAUSE I WAS TOO SCARED TO BE
AROUND PEOPLE.
THE TIPPING POINT FOR ME WAS AND
A SOCIOLOGY CLASS. ONE OF THE
LAST TWO CLASSES OF THAT
SEMESTER THAT I HADN'T DROPPED
DUE TO MY INCREASING ANXIETY.
AND THE THE BIGGEST MOMENT OF
THE SEMESTER WAS A SOCIAL NORM
REACH EXPERIMENT -- THAT WE'RE
SUPPOSED TO GO BEHAVE STRANGELY
IN PUBLIC TO GET REACTIONS OUT
OF PEOPE.
AND I COULDN'T.
I COULDN'T EVEN GO OUTSIDE.
I TRIED TO WORK UP THE COURAGE
BUT I STRUGGLED WITH THAT AIM OF
CALLING ATTENTION TO MYSELF AND
PUBLIC.
THE ASSIGNMENT WAS ESSENTIAL FOR
THE CLASS AND TO MESSAGE MEANT
FAILURE.
COULD ADDED TO MY LIST OF THAT
FAILED AND DROPPED CLASS.
I WAS SO PARALYZED WITH FEAR I
ENDED UP JUST HIDING AT HOME FOR
MONTHS BARELY ABLE TO LEAVE --
EVERYTHING IN COLLEGE AND MY
PERSONAL LIFE CULMINATED AND
ENDED WITH ME FEELING BROKEN.
I DON'T KNOW HOW TO FIND HELP.
AND I DIDN'T KNOW IF I COULD
EVEN GET HELP -- I DROPPED OUT
IN THE MIDDLE OF MY FOURTH
SEMESTER OF COLLEGE BECAUSE I
DIDN'T KNOW WHAT ELSE TO DO.
I KNOW I'M NOT THE ONLY ONE WITH
THE STORY BUT MENTAL HEALTH IS
RARELY DISCUSSED IF THIS WERE.
PART OF THE PUBLIC CONVERSATION
IF THERE WERE RESOURCES TO HELP
ME OR EVEN INFORMATION ABOUT
RESOURCES.
THEN I MAY HAVE BEEN ABLE TO
STAY ON TRACK.
MENTAL HEALTH ISSUES ARE COMMON.
BUT SUPPORT WITHIN THE SYSTEM IS
NOT [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR HAVING
THE COURAGE TO COME HERE TODAY
TO TESTIFY IT TO US TODAY'S MAY
FIRST JUST BY COINCIDENCE.
THIS IS -- THE FIRST DAY
MAINTENANCE MAY IS MENTAL HEALTH
AWARENESS MONTH AND SO -- WE
WANT TO MAKE SURE WE TALK ABOUT
THIS ISSUE -- REDUCE THE STIGMA.
AS WE HEARD THE OUR DAY AT SAC
STATE.
IF YOU'RE HAVING.
A BRIEF PROBLEM BREATHING.
GOT FOR BIDS FALLEN.
DINO SPRAIN YOUR ANKLE ON CAMPUS
HAVING SOME OTHER ISSUE YOU CAN
GO TO THE HEALTH CENTER AND IT'S
LIKE OKAY COME ON AND SAY TO
HELP THEM AND BUT WHEN IT'S A
MENTAL HEALTH AILMENT -- TOO
OFTEN PEOPLE THINK OF THAT AS
SOMETHING THAT WE SHOULD PUT TO
THE SIDE BUT IT'S STILL PART OF
OUR HEALTH ITSELF -- THANKS FOR
FOR TESTIFYING AND AND YEAH IT
IS SOMETHING THAT WE'RE GOING TO
TRY TO ADDRESS IT JUST FOR OUR
OUR COMMITTEE MEMBERS TO NOW WE
DO HAVE VERY LIMITED.
GENERAL FUND WE HAVE OTHER
PRIORITIES AND ROMANCE FUNDING
PROPERLY FUNDING THE UC AND CSU.
OPS ONE THING THAT WE'RE LOOKING
AT FOR THIS IS THAT PROP SIXTY
THREE FUN THERE IS A AS OF
COURSE MAJORITY MONIES GO OUT TO
THE COUNTIES FOR THEIR
PRIORITIES BUT THERE'S SOME.
MONEY HELD BACK IN THIS SO
CALLED STATE ADMIN ACCOUNTS --
TO FOCUS ON STATE PRIORITIES AND
SO WE THINK THIS AUDIT B..
ESTATE PRIORITY SO THAT'S ARE
LOOKING AT DOING IS IS FURTHER
HELPING THE UCC ISSUED KAMALA
COMMUNICABLE SYSTEM -- BUT WITH.
ANOTHER -- POT OF MONEY SO WE
CAN USE OUR SCARCE RESOURCES TO
FRANKLY AND ROLL MORE CALIFORNIA
STUDENTS SO.
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS MR
MARTUCCI THANK YOU VERY MUCH I I
WANTED THANK YOU FOR SHARING
YOUR YOUR PERSONAL EXPERIENCE
AND YOU KNOW.
I IS SPOKE RECENTLY AT A SIT IN
MENTAL HEALTH -- EVENT WHERE
THEY THEY TALKED ABOUT THE
IMPORTANCE OF A OF A ROLE MODEL
SPEAKING ABOUT YOU KNOW.
ABOUT THEIR OWN STRUGGLED IN
ORDER TO HELP REMOVE THE STIGMA
AND I I CAN SAY THAT I STRUGGLE
DURING MY COLLEGE YEARS AND YOU
KNOW AND I AND I SAW SOME --
SOME COUNSELINGAND AND AND SO I
<c.red> I COMPLETELY UNDERSTAND -- YOU</c>
KNOW THE THE THE THE NEED FOR
THE SUCH SERVICES -- YEAH I I
HAD A QUESTION FOR THE THAT THAT
THE STEINBERG INSTITUTE IN MAINE --
IT WAS.
LOOKING AT MISTER MCCARTY IS A
BILL HERE AND AND AND AND IT'S
THE TARGET IN THE UC CSU AND
COMMITTEE COLLEGES BUT I WAS
WONDERING IF THERE WAS ANY
EVIDENCE THAT THATYOU KNOW.
EARLIER INTERVENTION LIKE YOU
KNOW HAVING THE STATE ADMIN
FUNDS ACCESS YOU KNOW K. R. K.
THROUGH TWELVE SCHOOL DISTRICTS --
BEING ABLE TO ACCESS THAT WE IF
IF IF THERE IS ANY -- YOU KNOW
THE EVIDENCE THAT THERE MIGHT BE
EVEN MORE EFFECTIVE TO INTERVENE
EARLIER ABSOLUTELY AND WHAT WE
KNOW ABOUT MENTAL ILLNESS IS
THAT 50% MANIFEST BY THE AGE OF
1475%.
BY THE AGE OF TWENTY FOUR SO
ABSOLUTELY WE NEED TO BE DOING
MUCH MORE EARLIER -- ONE OF THE
ITEMS WAS BROUGHT UP EARLIER WAS
SB -- TEN FOR A BILL THAT WE HAD
SPONSORED AND WAS SIGNED LAST
YEAR INTO LAW AND ONE OF THE
THINGS WE DID AT THE STEINBERG
INSTITUTE WAS MANDATE A
DIFFERENT KIND OF STRATEGIC PLAN
FOR THE PREVENTION DOLLARS THE
COUNTY SCAT -- TO FOCUS MORE
STRATEGICALLY ON YOUNG PEOPLE
AND SO ONE OF THOSE AREAS IS ON
CHILDHOOD TRAUMA ENCOURAGING
PARTNERSHIPS WITH SCHOOLS -- SO
THIS IS PART OF SORT OF A
COMPREHENSIVE PACKAGE THAT WERE
WORKING ON NOT TO SAY THAT THIS
SHOULD -- YOU'LL BE MORE
IMPORTANT THAN THOSE THOSE OTHER
PROGRAMS THAT ARE FUNDED HERE
BUT IT'S IN A WEEK WE ALSO THINK
THAT MORNING TO BE DONE WITH IT
WITH THE COLLEGE STUDENTS AND
AND WORK ON A MYRIAD OF ISSUES
BUT WHAT WE KNOW ABOUT MENTAL
ILLNESS IS THAT WE HAVE.
WE HAVE TO BE DOING MUCH MORE
EARLIER -- FOR FOR KIDS AND
ENCOURAGING THESE PARTNERSHIPS
WITH WHAT K. TWELVE AS WELL
[inaudible]
MR MEDINA.
HI I WANNA THANK -- THE STUDENT --
FOR SCHERING -- STORY -- YOU
KNOW TOO MANY TIMES COLLEGE
STUDENTS -- OUR AFRAID OR OR OR
CAN'T WE'RE NOT ABLE TO ASK FOR
HELP.
AND I HEAR THE STORIES -- TIME
AND TIME AGAIN.
OF US STUDENTS SOMETIMES EVEN
FOREIGN STUDENTS OR STUDENTS WHO
COME FROM FAR AWAY.
AND JUST PARALYZED OF WITH
WHAT'S GOING N WITH THEM IN
THEIR OWN LIVES AND MAY BE FAR
AWAY.
FROM HOME AND ARE ARE KIND OF
STUCK ON CAMPUS.
AND DON'T KNOW.
YOU KNOW WHERE TO REACH OUT AND
AND HAVE A REALLY HARD TIME --
REACHING OUT SO I APPRECIATE
THANK THE STUDENT FOR BRINGING
THIS UP AND I VERY MUCH HOPE
THAT THE CAMPUSES.
YOU KNOW CAN CAN START -- DOING
MORE AND MORE TO MAKING SURE
THAT STUDENTS CAN BE AWARE TO
THOSE KIND OF THINGS THAT DON'T
HAPPEN YOU KNOW THE STORY OF A
STUDENT WHO WILL STAY.
A MAYBE A WHOLE SEMESTER WITHOUT
GETTING HELP.
IN IN IN A IN A DORM ROOM.
BUT THOSE THINGS HAPPEN AND AND
I HOPE THEY WILL HAPPEN LESS AND
LESS [inaudible]
OKAY [inaudible]
THIS LIMóN.
THANK YOU AND I WANT TO ECHO --
MY COLLEAGUES THINGS TO BOTH OF
YOU BUT PARTICULARLY YOU FOR
SHARING YOUR STORY I THINK IT'S
A STORY THAT.
REGRETTABLY.
IS ALL TOO COMMON AS SOMEONE WHO
SPENT SOME TIME WORKING IN
HIGHER ED -- I MYSELF HAD TO
WALK OF THE STUDENTS TO OUR
EQUIVALENT OF LIKE CAPS AT UC
SANTA BARBARA -- MULTIPLE TIMES
AND I KNOW THAT AT THE TIME --
THERE WAS.
THE ABILITY TO SEE SOMEONE ON
THE SPOT UNDER VERY DIRE.
SITUATION WHICH IS NOT WHERE YOU
WANT TO SEE STUDENTS EVER GET --
BUT THE WAIT LIST WAS I MEAN THE
WAIT WAS AT LEAST TWO THREE
WEEKS I HEAR THAT THAT'S GONE UP
SINCE I LEFT THE CAMPUS IN --
TWO THOUSAND SIX AT THE WEIGHTS
ARE LONGER -- BUT I ALSO HEAR
FROM FOLKS IN K. TWELVE SO I I'M
TRYING TO THINK OF YOU KNOW IN
OUR EDUCATION COMMUNITY.
WHAT IS THE BEST APPROACH
BECAUSE -- THIS IS BIGGER I'VE
NEVER HEARD AS MUCH FROM THE K.
TO TWELVE COMMUNITY -- THAT
TALKS ABOUT THE NEED FOR MENTAL
HEALTH I KNOW THAT WHEN SCHOOL
BOARD MEMBERS CAME UP HERE THAT
WAS ONE OF THEIR TOP ISSUES I
THINK ABOUT THE CONNECTION IT
HAS TO THE STUDENTS IN HIGHER ED --
THESE ARE NOT MUTUALLY EXCLUSIVE
THESE ARE CONNECTED AND SO I
JUST WONDER IF THERE IS A WAY
FOR US TO THINK ABOUT HOW WE
IMPACT THE SYSTEM -- MAKE WE
CLEARLY NEED TO DO SOMETHING
ABOUT IT I JUST DON'T.
NO WHERE OR HOW -- AND IT'S NO
DOUBT THATINVESTMENT OF FUNDS
IS ONE APPROACH BUT I THINK.
MORE BROADLY -- THINKING ABOUT%
THE FACT THAT K. TWELVE IS
ASKING US FOR THIS HIGHER AT IS
ASKING US FOR THIS -- AND THE
NEED IN THE GAP IS -- BECOMING
MUCH GREATER [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
YEAH.
THANK YOU AND AND I KNOW THAT
THE OTHER GUARD SISTER
SUBCOMMITTEE RIGHT NEXT DOOR
HERE SOMEONE.
IS IS TALKING ABOUT THIS ISSUE.
AND THEY HAVE A LIST OF
PROPOSALS AND SO WE'RE GOING TO
HAVE TO COMPETE BUT I THINK WE
OUGHT TO BE.
FOCUSING ON ON BOTH POPULATIONS
AND I THINK THE ISSUE HERE IS.
THAT THAT PROP SIXTY THREE THE
SO CALLED MILLIONAIRE'S TAX WHEN
IT WAS APPROVED.
WAS GONNA BE ABOUT A BILLION
DOLLARS A YEAR NOW IT'S THREE
TWO POINT FOUR BILLION FOR YEAH.
SO THAT'S A LOT OF MONEY IN IT
AND A LOT IS GOING OUT TO THE
COUNTIES IN WE KNOW SOME
COUNTIES ARMS SPENDING IT.
AND TAKE IT YOU KNOW COULD SEE
WITH THE SHOULD BE THEY COULD BE
FOCUSING ON AS YOU SAID MISS
SIMONE STUDENT ISSUES IN COLLEGE
ISSUES AND WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO
FOCUS ON HERE IS THERE SOME
MONEY THAT COMES TO THE STATE.
WE NEED TO FOCUS HOW WE THINK
OUR STATE PRIORITY SEND.
THIS -- CERTAINLY -- IN MY VIEW
SHOULD BE ONE BUT YOU KNOW AGAIN
WILL WILL ALSO LOOK AT THE OTHER
PROPOSALS.
AGAIN THANK YOU FOR YOUR TEST
WHEN THERE'S NO ACTION ON THIS
ITEM -- WILL HOLD THIS ISSUE --
OPEN AND TALK ABOUT IT AFTER THE
MAY REVISE LESTAT FOLK REAL
QUICK SORRY I KNOW WE HAVE SOME
STUDENTS HERE WHO WANT TO TALK
SPECIFICALLY ABOUT.
ABOUT THIS SO THIS IS THE PUBLIC
COMMENT SECTION -- FOR MENTAL
HEALTH ISSUES SO -- INCOME ON UP
LINE UP OVER HERE.
WESLEY SEXTET STUDENT IN SUPPORT
OF AB.
SIXTEEN EIGHTY NINE HI THERE MY
NAME IS LONG BEEN SEALED I'M A
STUDENT SACRAMENTO STATE
UNIVERSITY AND I SUPPORT THIS
BILL -- TO REMEMBER HOW THE
HISPANIC ASSOCIATION OF COLLEGES
AND UNIVERSITIES WE SUPPORT YOUR
BILL TERM MCCARTY IT'S
INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT FOR LAND
ASK STUDENTS.
WHO FACE CERTAIN CHALLENGES JUST
REMINDER ANYONE IS A STATE
CORPORATIONS COMMITTEE BUT WE
SUPPORT IDEA?
AND CONCEPTS SO YOU CAN TALK
ABOUT THE ISSUE THAT'S IMPORTANT
TO YOU BUT AGAIN -- THE BILL IS
NOT RELEVANT IN TODAY'S
DISCUSSION.
I CHAIR MCCARTY AND MEMBERS OF
MANY I'M DOCTOR IN WALTHAM
COUNSELING PSYCHOLOGIST A
CALIFORNIA STATE UNIVERSITY
MARITIME ACADEMY AND I'M HERE TO
SAY THAT BETTER MENTAL SERVICES
ARE NEEDED.
AND APPROPRIATIONS IN BILL --
SIX SIXTY WILL HELP CAL MERIT
TIME I AM THE ONLY FULL TIME
MENTAL HEALTH COUNSELOR IN MY
PART TIME CALLING AND I SERVER
THOUSAND CADETS IN OUR SCHEDULES
ARE FULL.
IRIVER LEAN STAYING LATE MOST
DAYS YET THE MAJORITY OF MY CSU
COLLEAGUES ARE EX CENTERS WITH
AN AVERAGE OF ONE COUNSEL PER
TWO THOUSAND STUDENTS SOME MORE.
AND IT THIS TURNS COUNSELING
CENTERS INTO CRISIS CENTERS.
ME SAID AGAIN COUNSELING CENTERS
ARE BECOMING CRISIS CENTERS.
AND HIGH RISK STUDENTS ARE
PRIORITIZE IT LEAVES OTHERS
HANGING ON WAIT LISTS OUR
COMMUNITY HEALTH SYSTEMS THAT
OFTEN INACCESSIBLE HAS BEEN
DOCUMENTED TODAY -- AND I CAN
SPEAK ALSO FROM DIFFERENT
SPIRITS AS HAVING WORKED IN THE
UC SYSTEM UC BERKELEY AS A
COUNSELOR THERE AND IT FRESNO
CITY IN THE COMMUNITY COLLEGE
DISTRICT -- I HAVE THOSE
EXPERIENCES LASTLY LET ME SAY
THAT BASED ON DANIEL EISENBERG'S
WORK AT THE UNIVERSITY OF PURSUE
MICHIGAN PROVIDING MENTAL
SERVICES PAYS FOR ITSELF AND
RETENTION INTUITION YOU CAN GO
TO HIS WEBSITE AND USE THE
CALCULATOR.
EACH INDIVIDUAL INSTITUTION CAN
INPUT THEIR DATA AND FIND OUT
HOW MUCH MONEY SPECIFICALLY THEY
CAN SAVE WITH MORE COUNSELORS
AND THAT'S WHAT -- IN THE CSU WE
NEED AND THAT TWENTY MILLION AND
MORE CAN GIVE CSU STUDENTS THE
EQUITABLE HEALTH CARE THAT THEY
DESERVE.
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
THANK YOU CHAIR MCCARTY AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS FOR ALLOWING
ME TO SPEAK TODAY A MICHAEL
RITTER AND I'VE RETIRED TWO
YEARS AGO FROM SAM'S CISCO STATE
UNIVERSITY AFTER THIRTY YEARS
AND COUNTING THE PSYCHOLOGICAL
SERVICES.
SO DURING THAT TIME I SAW.
THE THE MOUNTING PRESSURE THAT
THE CENTER WAS UNDER IN AS HE
SAID MY COLLEAGUE SAID.
BECOMING MORE OF A CRISIS CENTER
TRYING TO PUT OUT FIRES BUT THE
NUMBER OF MENTAL HEALTH
PROFESSIONALS DID NOT INCREASE
DURING THAT TIME.
IS SAN FRANCISCO STATE CURRENTLY.
OF THE COUNSELING CENTER HAS
LESS THAN HALF OF THE
RECOMMENDED.
NUMBER OF CANCER SO THERE'S
BASICALLY TEN COUNSELORS FOR
TWENTY NINE THOUSAND STUDENTS
THE UNIVERSITY OF THE TIME.
WAIT TIMES CAN BE TWO TO THREE
WEEKS -- THE MOST VULNERABLE OF
OUR STUDENTS FEEL LIKE THEY'VE
BEEN TURNED AWAY WHEN WHEN
SOMEONE SAYS.
OUR NEXT AVAILABLE APPOINTMENT
IS TWENTY DAYS OUT. FOR STUDENTS
OF COLOR THE CHALLENGES.
ARE EVEN MORE ACUTE AS A FACE
ALL THE DISTAL STRESSORS SUCH AS
DISCRIMINATION.
IMMIGRATION STATUS FINANCIAL
HARDSHIPS.
STUDENTS OF COLOR ARE LESS
LIKELY TO ATTEND THE NEEDED
SERVICES AND THAT'S WHY IT IS
ESSENTIAL THAT FULL TIME MENTAL
HEALTH COUNSELORS BE HIRED.
THE REFLECT THE DIVERSITY OF THE
STUDENTS THEY SERVE I ALSO LIKE
TO ADD TO IT -- COLLEGE
COUNSELING IS A UNIQUE SET OF
SKILLS IS NOT NECESSARILY AN
INTERCHANGEABLE -- SET OF SKILLS
THAT DID THE PEOPLE WHO GO INTO
THAT.
VESTER FOCUS.
THIS TREMENDOUS AMOUNT OF STRESS
FOR THE DEDICATED MENTAL HEALTH
PROFESSIONALS.
WHO KNOW THE COUNSELING CAN MAKE
THE DIFFERENCE BETWEEN A STUDENT
DROPPING OUT OFSCHOOL?
GRADUATING.
THESE DEDICATED PROFESSIONAL
SKIP LUNCH SO THAT THEY CAN SEE
A STUDENT BECAUSE THEY KNOW THAT
THERE'S A WAITING LIST THEY THEY
PUT OFF PAPERWORK INTO IT AFTER
HOURS SO THEY CAN SEE A STUDENT --
DURING THAT TIME KNOWING THAT
THE COMMUNITY RESOURCES ARE
EQUALLY PRESSURED THANK YOU.
OKAY.
SO JUST WANT TO SAY I WANT TO
SUPPORT ON BEHALF OF CALIFORNIA
FACT ASSOCIATIONS.
HIGHER DUE TO SUPPORT SENATE
BILL SIX SIXTY AUTHORED BY --
DOCTOR PAN AND TO SUPPORT SEE A
FACE REQUEST FOR TWENTY MILLION
DOLLARS TO HIRE -- ADDITIONAL
HEALTH PROFESSIONALS THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR MCCARTY
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE -- I
WON'TREADER REITERATE I'M HERE
ON BEHALF THE CALIFORNIA FACULTY
ASSOCIATION MARIO GUERRERO I
WON'T REITERATE -- SEE A FACE
PROPOSALS WHICH YOU'VE HEARD ON
BUT I DO WANT TO THANK YOU FOR
YOUR EFFORTS TO BRING ADDITIONAL
FUNDS -- TO HIRE ADD
SPECIFICALLY FOR MENTAL HEALTH
JUST WANT TO POINT OUT THAT THE
TWENTY MILLION DOLLAR ASK --
THAT WE MADE OF THIS COMMITTEE
AND THE BUDGET THE BILL THAT WAS
MENTIONED SB.
SIX SIXTY THEY REALLY ARE
TOGETHER AND WE'RE NOT ASKING
FOR ADDITIONAL FUNDS ABOVE WHAT
THE GOVERNOR HAS REQUESTED WE'RE
ASKING THAT OF THE THREE HUNDRED
MILLION THAT THE GOVERNOR HAS
PROPOSED.
THAT TWENTY MILLION BE SET ASIDE
TO PRIORITIZE MENTAL HEALTH JUST
LIKE OTHER SYSTEMS IN THE
GOVERNOR PRIORITIZE FUNDING --
FOR THE UC'S WE BELIEVE THAT
SOME OF THIS MONEY SHOULD BE
PRIORITIZED HERE -- TWO ISSUES
ONE ABOUT THE DIVERSITY OF
CANCERS ARE PROPOSAL UNDER SB
SUCCESS SIX SIXTY TALKS ABOUT
THE NEED FOR DIVERSE CANCERS TO
BE I'M HIRED -- TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE ARE ADDRESSING THE NEEDS
OF THE DIVERSE -- STUDENT
POPULATION LASTLY -- WITH
REGARDS -- TO YOU KNOW THE NEEDS
OF STUDENTS AND APART TIMES THE
A PART TIME FACT OF PART TIME
CANCERS THAT'S GREAT BUT IF YOU
HAVE STUDENTS THAT -- HAVE.
ON GOING ISSUES THAT NEED TO SEE
CONSERVE TIME MORE THAN ONCE YOU
REALLY NEED CONSISTENT FULL TIME
FACULTY THAT THEY CAN SEE THOSE
STUDENTS OVER A PERIOD OF TIME
THANK YOU.
QUICK QUESTION SO THE CSU
BUDGETS NOT TODAY MAJORITY MONEY
IS -- FOR THE OF COURSE CAN PLAY
COMPENSATIONS A PIECE OF IT. TO
TO TACKLE WHICH WE THINK IS THE
RIGHT THING TO DO THAT THE
CONTRACT THE CFA.
STUDENT ENROLLMENT OPERATIONAL
COSTS THE GRADUATION INITIATIVES
SO WHERE WOULD CFA PROPOSED
TAKING THE TWENTY MILLION FROM
TO FIND SURE WELL THE AS A
YSTEM LAST YEAR IF YOU RECALL
OF THIS OF THIS BODY AND AND THE
SENATE AGREED TO FUND -- THE CSU
BY INVESTING TWO HUNDRED MILLION
NEW ON GOING DOLLARS THIS YEAR
THIS IS A A GOVERNOR'S PROPOSING
THREE HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS SO
WE THINK THAT.
THE FUND TWENTY MILLION DOLLARS
CAN COME OUT OF THAT.
THREE HUNDRED MILLION FUNDS YOU
CERTAINLY HAVE -- THE GRADUATE
STUDENT IN THE GRADUATION
INITIATIVE SOME OF THAT FUNDING
CAN BE CAN GO TOWARDS THIS AS
YOU HEARD EARLIER -- WITH
STUDENTS HAVE ISSUE YOU'VE HEARD
FROM THE OTHER PANELISTS WHEN
STUDENTS HAVE ISSUES -- MENTAL
HEALTH ISSUES THEY DROP OUT
RIGHT SO THIS CERTAINLY HELPS
THEM GRADUATE I GET THAT BUT IN
THE BUDGET IT IT IS NOT JUST A
BLANK CHECK THEY SAY.
WHERE?
MONIES GOV CELL I UNDERSTAND AND
YOU KNOW OUR JOB IS TO YOUR JOB
IS TO ASK ME TO DO THAT.
OUR JOB IS TO ASK WHERE DO WE
TAKE MONEY FROM TO PUT MONEY
OVER HERE CELL SURE THANK YOU.
DID ANSWER QUESTIONS NOT REALLY
THAT'S OKAY.
YOU'RE DOING YOUR JOB.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE -- MY NAME IS
MAHMOUD SAM I'LL FAR ON THE
DIRECTOR SUSTAINABILITY AND
INCOMING DIRECTOR OF EXTERNAL
AFFAIRS ASSAULT A COMMUNITY
COLLEGE FOR THE STUDENT
GOVERNMENT -- AND I CAN JUST SAY
THAT.
A BIG NON ACADEMIC BARRIER THAT
STUDENTS DO FACE IS THE ISSUE OF
MENTAL HEALTH A LOT OF STUDENTS
ESPECIALLY I SAW ABOUT COMMUNITY
COLLEGE ARE DROPPING OUT.
DUE TO THE CONSTRAINTS THAT THEY
HAVE MENTALLY WITHIN THEMSELVES.
THAT'S WHY WE SUPPORT I KNOW
THIS IS SENATE BILL SB SIX SIXTY
WHICH WOULD BRING IN ONE MENTAL
HEALTH COUNCIL FOR EVERY.
FIFTEEN HUNDRED FIFTEEN HUNDRED
STUDENTS IN COLLEGES I THINK
THIS IS A STEP FORWARD TO
IMPLEMENTING MENTAL HEALTH --
THESE TOWARDS OUR STUDENT BODY.
ESPECIALLY WHEN THAT IS
EXTREMELY IMPORTANT IN TIMES
SUCH AS THIS -- SO THANK YOU
GUYS FOR RECOGNIZING THE ISSUE
OF MENTAL HEALTH AND I THOUGHT
ABOUT COLLEGE I SELECT COMMITTEE
CALLS FULLY ENDORSES IT AND WE
APPRECIATE YOUR GUYS HELP AND
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
SURE MCCARTY -- COMMITTEE MY
NAME IS JEFF NOR I AM -- ENGLISH
PROFESSOR AT SACRAMENTO CITY
COLLEGE.
I JUST WANT YOU OF VOICE MY
SUPPORT.
FOR NECESSARY RESOURCES --
MENTAL HEALTH RESOURCES FOR
STUDENTS IN MY TWENTY SIX YEARS
AT CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGES.
I HAVE SPOKEN WITH MANY MANY
STUDENTS -- WHO NEED MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICES I'VE WALKED MANY
STUDENTS TO OUR COUNSELING
CENTER -- TO THE DOOR WHERE
UNFORTUNATELY NO ONE IS THERE TO
RECEIVE THEM EXCEPT POSSIBLY OF
AN ACADEMIC COUNSELOR WHO HAS
SOME.
MODERATE TRAINING IN DEALING
WITH A CRISIS -- THAT'S NOT THE
WAY YOU WANT TO LEAVE A STUDENT
AT THE DOOR OF A COUNSELING
CENTER.
WHO IN CRISIS WITH SOMEONE WHO'S
MODERATELY TRAINED IN CRISIS
COUNSELING IT'S A VERY VERY REAL
NEED -- SO I HOPE WE CAN SEE
THAT -- MANIFEST IN THE IN THE
COLLEGES.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS NEIL
I'M A STUDENT AT UC BERKELEY I
JUST WANT TO STAND ON WITH THE
NEED TO REALLY INVEST AS MUCH AS
WE CAN AND MENTAL HEALTH.
SO I'M ASKING THAT WE MAKE THE
FOUR POINT EIGHT MILLION IN
STATE GENERAL FUNDS AT THE WRIST
YOU SEE RECEIVED.
IN LIEU OF A STUDENT SERVICES
FEE INCREASE PER MINUTE AND TO
ALSO APPROVE A FIVE POINT THREE
MILLION IN ONGOING STATE GENERAL
FUND THAT'S PROPOSED BY THE
GOVERNOR SPECIFICALLY FOR MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICES EXPANSION.
AT THE UC FOR CONTACTS IN --
TWENTY FIFTEEN THROUGH THE
ADVOCACY OF STUDENTS AND THE
HIGHLIGHTING OF SIGNIFICAN
INSTITUTIONAL LIKE OF MENTAL
HEALTH RESOURCES THE UC BEGAN A
MULTI YEAR PLAN TO FUNDS FOR
FUNDS TO HIRE AN ADDITIONAL
EIGHTY FIVE CLINICIANS.
ACROSS THE SYSTEM TO EXPAND ITS
COUNSELING SERVICES AND REDUCE
THE STUDENT A COUNSELOR RATIO.
AND TWENTY EIGHTEEN IN THE MIDST
OF THIS EXPANSION THE UC
RECEIVED A ONE TIME FUNDING FROM
THE STATE TO THE STATE TO
SUPPORT THESE EFFORTS.
HOWEVER THE ONE TIME FUNDING
FELL TO ACCOUNT FOR THE ONGOING
COST OF ADDITIONAL COUNSELORS
NOR DID ACCOUNT FOR THE FUNDING
NECESSARY TO CONTINUE AND FINISH
THE EXPANSION.
IN ORDER TO MAINTAIN THE NEWLY
HIRED COUNSELORS AND AVOID
RAISING TUITION FOR AT THE STATE
MUST MAKE A PERMANENT MUST MAKE
PERMANENT THE FOUR POINT EIGHT
MILLION AND ALSO INCLUDE A FIVE
POINT THREE MILLION ONGOING
FUNDING.
WITH OVER ONE IN FOUR STUDENTS
DEALING WITH SOME FORM OF MENTAL
ILLNESS ANXIETY RECENTLY BEING
CLAIMED AS AN EPIDEMIC ACROSS
COLLEGE CAMPUSES.
IT'S CRITICAL THAT WE IN A
TRIPLING OF ANXIETY IN THE LEVEL
AMONG YOU SEE STUDENTS OVER THE
PAST DECADE IT'S CRITICAL THAT
WE TAKE INTO ACCOUNT THE IMPACT.
ON THAT THIS HAS HONOR STUDENTS
IN THEIR LIVELIHOOD THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME'S LOCAL NOW NEWMAN
ALSO STUDENT AT UC BERKELEY OF A
SECOND HERE -- AND PURSUING
PUBLIC HEALTH AND BIO EASY AND I
FEEL AS IF LIKE I WANT TO
CONTEXTUALIZE WIPING MENTAL
HEALTH IS VERY IMPORTANT WHY WE
SHOULD SUSTAIN IT HERE AT THE
UC'S.
AND OTHER SCHOOLS AT THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA -- I'M OUT OF
STATE STUDENT AND I GOT THE
OPPORTUNITY TO COME TO CAL ON
OTHER REGIONS AND CHANCE OR
SCHOLARSHIP.
SO LIKE I WAS PROMISED THAT I
WOULD COME HERE AND I'D BE
UPLIFTED AS LIKE A TOP RECRUITED
STUDENT.
BY FALL AS IF LIKE JUST FOR THE
RESOURCES LIKE I HAVEN'T BEEN
SUPPORTED NECESSARILY LIKE.
IN MY FIRST YEAR HERE UNDER WHAT
LIKE TO MATIC EXPERIENCES AND I
FELT LIKE IT TOOK A LONG TIME
FOR ME TO GET THAT CARE.
AND ANOTHER THING THAT I WOULD
LIKE TO ALSO LIKE BRING TO THE
FOREFRONT IS THE FACT THAT LIKE
A LOT OF UC BERKELEY STUDENTS IF
THEY WANT TO RECEIVE CARE IT
TAKES UP TO LIKE. TWO TO TWO
WEEKS TO A MONTH TO GET LAKE
SCENE AND THEN ALSO WE'RE
STRUGGLING ON CAMPUS WITH.
ACCESS TO A DIVERSE BY
COUNSELORS AND THAT INCLUDES
LIKE ETHNICALLY DIVERSE -- SOCIO
ECONOMICALLY INTERFAITH -- AND
ALSO BY SEXUAL ORIENTATION HAVE
YOU SEEN THIS MANIFEST IN A LOT
OF STUDENTS FEELING AS IF THEY
CANNOT.
PROCEED WITH THE SCHOOLING AT
THE SCHOOL AND ALSO DROPPING OUT --
I BELIEVE LIKE IT'S ALSO
INTERESTING BECAUSELIKE A KEY
WORD THAT A LOT OF PEOPLE BRING
UP NOW IT'S LIKE THIS IDEA OF
LIKE INCLUSIVE EXCELLENCE BUT
THE WAY IN WHICH WE DO THAT IS
TO LIKE ACADEMIC EQUITY RIGHT.
BUT A LOT OF THE ISSUES THAT
STUDENTS BASED ON OUR CAMPUS OR
LIKE NOT LIKE -- EXCLUSIVE LIKE
WE HAVE WHAT TO STUDENTS WHO ARE
HOMELESS WE HAVE LOTS OF
STUDENTS WHO LACK BASIC ACCESS
TO LIKE FOOD AND NUTRITION.
AND THOSE THINGS ALL CULMINATE
IN THE FACT THAT LIKE THEIR
MENTAL HEALTH IS BEING IMPACTED
AND IT'S SORT OF LIKE THIS
BIGGER QUESTION OF LIKE.
HOW CAN STUDENTS GO ABOUT LIKE
GETTING ACCESS TO LIKE THIS TOP
NOTCH EDUCATION IF THEY'RE
WORRYING ABOUT LIKE SMALLER
ISSUES -- I ALSO WANT TO COMMENT
ON THE FACT THAT LIKE AT UC
BERKELEY THE BLACK POPULATION IS
ONE POINT 9%.
AND WE'RE SEEING A LOT OF
STUDENTS DROP OUT BECAUSE THEY
CANNOT GO AND BE SEEN FOR LIKE
OTHER SOCIAL ISSUES THAT THEY
MAY HAVE OUTSIDE OF SCHOOL.
WE ALSO HAVE TO REALIZE THAT MY
TWO EYES IDENTITIES TO CALM WITH
LIKE A LOT OF DIFFERENT TRAUMAS
IN LIKE THEY NEED TO BE A
DRASTIC LIKE IF THEY'RE NOT
HELPED THEN OBVIOUSLY THEY'RE
GOING TO DROP OUT OUR RETENTION
RATES ARE VERY LOW.
AND A LOT OF OUR STUDENTS THE
NECESSARY STOP BECAUSE IF IT'S
NOT TAKEN A WE SEE OUR OUR RATES
GOING DOWN TO LIKE. ZERO NUMBERS --
ANOTHER THING THAT'S REALLY.
I'M ASSET WRAP IT UP WE'RE
SUPPOSED TO GIVE ONE MINUTES OUR
STUDENTS ON BEING A LITTLE BIT
MORE GENEROUS BUT OF COURSE
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS ANGIE
CHEN ON THE SENIOR AT UC
BERKELEY -- WE REALLY NEED TO
INVEST MORE MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES ONE IN EVERY EIGHT YOU
SEE STUDENTS USE AND COUNSELING
SERVICES BUT YOU KNOW AT THE
TING CENTER ON CAMPUS AT UC
BERKELEY WAIT TIMES GETTING
LONGER LONGER THIS IS TRUE
ACROSS THE UC SYSTEM -- AND I
WORK A LOT ON BASIC NEEDS
PARTICULARLY HOUSING AND
SECURITY I WORK WITH LIKE -- THE
LOCAL GOVERNMENT YEAH YOU SEE
BURKE AT THE CITY OF BERKELEY TO
ADDRESS YOU DON'T RISING HOUSING
COSTS AND YOU KNOW STUDENTS ARE
SUFFERING BECAUSE OF RISING
HOUSING COSTS BECAUSE OF HIGH
TUITION WAS A COMPETITIVE
ACADEMICS.
AND THESE ARE ALL FACTORS THAT
WILL IMPACT OUR MENTAL HEALTH BY
INCREASING OUR STRESS AND
ANXIETY AND SO WE NEED TO
ADDRESS THIS BY YOU KNOW FUNDING
SERVICES THAT HELP STUDENTS
NAVIGATE.
THIS AND ACHIEVE THE SUCCESS IN
THEIR COLLEGE CAREERS SO WE NEED
TO MAKE PERMANENT THE FOUR POINT
EIGHT MILLION DOLLARS IN FUNDING
THAT WAS USED TO HIRE CANCERS
AND NOW WE NEED TO USE THAT TO
MAINTAIN THE COUNTERS THERE.
AND WE NEED TO APPROVE THE
GOVERNOR'S REQUEST OF FOUR FIVE
POINT THREE ADDITIONAL DOLLARS
IN -- MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES
FUNDING BECAUSE THIS IS REALLY
AN IMPORTANT ISSUE THAT IMPACTS
EVERY SINGLE STUDENT ON EVERY
SINGLE YOU SEE CAMPUS THANK
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME SAID IN A
TELEPHONE THEN I GO TO UC
BERKELEY'S WHILE I'M A SOPHOMORE --
AND AGAIN I JUST WANT TO
EMPHASIZE THE IMPORTANCE OF
PRIORITIZING MENTALHEALTH --
ESPECIALLY AT UC BERKELEY THE
CLIMB IT AND LIKE LEVELS OF
STRESS AND ANXIETY REALLY DO.
A PLAY A TOLL ON A LOT OF PEOPLE
THAT I KNOW PERSONALLY AND
MYSELF SO THAT'S WHY IT'S
IMPORTANT THAT WE CAN -- GET A
SMALLER RATIO OF COUNSELORS TO
STUDENTS BECAUSE IT'S RIDICULOUS
TO HAVE TO WAIT MORE THAN YOU
SHOULD BE ABLE TO WALK IN AND
pYOU HAVE WHEN YOU'RE DEALING
WITH ISSUES -- I ALSO WANT TO
SEE MENTION HOW ONE IN FOR OVER
ONE IN FOUR STUDENTS ARE DEALING
WITH SOME FORM OF MENTAL ILLNESS
AND ESPECIALLY IN COMMUNITIES OF
COLOR IS SPECIFICALLY I CAN
SPEAK ON LIKE BEING A LOT THE
KNOCK.
IN HIGHER ED LIKE FROM BACK HOME
LIKE WE DON'T TALK ABOUT MENTAL
ILLNESSES AND IT'S SO
STIGMATIZED AND IF I'M GOING TO
UNIVERSITY LIKE I WANT TO HAVE
ACCESS.
TO DIVERSE -- COUNSELORS I WANT
TO BE ABLE TO HAVE THOSE
SERVICES PROVIDED TO ME
ESPECIALLY WHEN A LOT OF TIMES
WE DON'T EVEN KNOW WE'RE DEALING
WITH THESE ISSUES BECAUSE WE'VE
NEVER EVEN TALKED ABOUT MENTAL
ILLNESS BEFORE -- SO THAT'S WHY
I MERGING THE UC TO MAKE THE ONE
TIME FOUR POINT EIGHT MILLION
DOLLARS IN STATE GENERAL FUNDS
THAT THE UC RECEIVED IN LIEU OF
A STUDENT SERVICES FEE INCREASE
IN.
TWENTY EIGHTEEN NINETEEN
PERMANENT AND APPROVE THE FIVE
POINT THREE MILLION AN ONGOING
STATE GENERAL FUNDS PROPOSED BY
THE GOVERNOR FOR MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES EXPANSION OF THE UC.
THANK YOU.
HI I'M IT DOES THE CAN I AM ALSO
FROM UC BERKELEY ANIMAL AND A
FRESHMAN AND I WANTED TO SHARE
WITH YOU SOME THOUGHTS ABOUT A
STUDENT MENTAL HEALTH AFTER.
A DUSTER THAT ALSO STRIKE ME
AFTER I STOP IT ON CAMPUS.
I WANTED TO STATE THAT THE UC'S
IS COUNSELING CENTERS HAVE SEEN
A 78% INCREASE IN STUDENT
UTILIZATION OF MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES SINCE.
TWO THOUSAND SEVEN FURTHERMORE
WAIT TIMES AND THE U. S. COUNCIL
YOU AT THE UC COUNSELING CENTERS
HAVE BEEN UNDER EYES AND THE
ABILITY OF COUNSELING CENTERS TO
SEE STUDENTS WITHIN FOURTEEN
DAYS AFTER FIRST SESSION
REQUESTED CREST.
DICK DECREASED BY NEARLY 8% OVER
THE PAST TWO YEARS.
AND AND AFTER SHARING THESE
SEVEN THESE SOME LIKE BASIC --
STATEMENTS WITH THE I WANTED TO
REITERATE MY FRIENDS REQUEST OF
MAKING THAT FOUR POINT EIGHT
MILLION AND GENERAL FUND SPUR
MINUTE UNAPPROVED THAT
ADDITIONAL FOUGHT FIVE POINT
EIGHT MILLION.
I ONGOING STATES GIVEN -- FUND --
APPROVED THANK YOU.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TESTIMONY.
HI MY NAME IS JACKIE MY THANK
YOU SO MUCH FOR LETTING ME SPEAK --
I AM ALSO A STUDENT AT UC
BERKELEY I'M A SECOND YEAR AND I
STUDY PUBLIC HEALTH AND PUT ON
PUBLIC POLICY -- MOST
IMPORTANTLY I'VE BEEN WORKING SO
HARD SINCE THE START OF MY
COLLEGE CAREER WORKING ON TO
WORKING ON IMPROVING STUDENT
MENTAL HEALTH AS A STATE
REPRESENTATIVE IN THAT SO SHE
GETS INTO THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA WHICH IS OUR SENIOR
GOVERNMENT.
BUT ALSO I'M A RESIDENT
ASSISTANT IN IF YOU HAVE BEEN TO
COLLEGE AND YOU REMEMBER LIKE.
LIVING IN THE RESIDENCE HALLS
YOU REMEMBER YOUR ARE A BEING
ABOUT ONE PERSON THAT WOULD HELP
STUDENTS -- HELP GIVE STUDENTS
ADVICE BUT MORE IMPORTANTLY I
REALIZE THAT MY ROLE AS AN ARE A
THIS YEAR WAS REALLY TRYING TO
MEDIATE A LOT OF THESE DIFFERENT
TYPES OF MENTAL HEALTH CRISIS
THE THAT OUR UNIVERSITY HAS
SINCE BE OUTPACING THIS YEAR.
AND IT'S JUST COINCIDENTAL THAT
I'M SPEAKING TODAY BECAUSE JUST
LAST WEEK I HOW TO DEAL WITH THE
CASE -- REGARDING SUICIDE
IDEATION AND I'M STILL TRYING TO
TAKE CARE OF MYSELF AFTER
DEALING WITH THAT AND JUST THIS
PAST MONTH FIVE OF MY RESIDENTS
ON MY FLOOR SIXTY SIX STUDENTS
HAVE ALL ASKED ME HOW TO ACCESS.
COUNTING RESOURCES OUT OUR LOCAL
UNIVERSITY HEALTH SERVICES TAKE
CENTER AND CONSISTENTLY ONE
AFTER THE OTHER FIVE OF THE FIVE
STUDENTS HAVE ALL MENTIONED THAT
IT TOOK THEM TWO TO THREE WEEKS
TO REACH A COUNSELOR.
THERE'S CLEARLY AN
OVERSATURATION OF STUDENTS
TRYING TO ACCESS THESE
COUNSELING RESOURCES AND WE CAN
WE NEED FUNDING -- TO TO
CONTINUE THE SERVICE SAYS -- I'D
REALLY LIKE TO ADD THAT -- I
COULD HAVE A KINGS IDEAS THE X.
AS IT'S AN INCREASING EPIDEMIC
ON OUR CAMPUS ESPECIALLY BECAUSE
OUR COLLEGES SO RIGOROUS AND FOR
THAT.
THOSE WHO NEED THOUGHT -- ARE --
YEAH IT'S REALLY POINT THAT WE
DO INCREASE FUNDING BECAUSE
THESE RESOURCES ARE REALLY
NECESSARY THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON -- GENRE THE UC
TION ASSOCIATION -- WE HAVE OUR
EYES AND I SEE A LOT OF THE
FORCE OF SHARES -- THE SAME ASKS
THAT WE NEED -- THE CONTINUED
FUNDING TO FIVE POINT THREE
MILLION HOW TO EXPAND THE
SERVICES AND ALSO THE FOUR POINT
EIGHT MILLION ONE TIME TO TURN
INTO ONGOING IN ORDER TO
MAINTAIN THEIR THE TRAJECTORY
THAT WE HAVE -- BUT I DO WANT TO
KIND OF SHARE FOR A MOMENT I
THINK WE QUITE OFTEN THINK ABOUT
THESE AS NUMBERS AND AS YOU KNOW
STILL LIKE LITERAL.
BUT NOT NOT REALLY AS HUMAN
BEINGS AND AND HE WAS SEVEN
YEARS AGO AT A DAY LIKE THIS ONE
AS A FIRST YEAR STUDENT I WAS
WALKING AND I SAW.
THE BREAK HIS NUMBER AROUND --
ONE OF OUR BUILDINGS WHEN THEY
SHOULDN'T HAVE COMMITTED SUICIDE
AT UC IRVINE.
AND AND I REMEMBER THAT WAS THE
FIRST TIME.
THAT THAT AFFECTS SO MANY THAT I
SAW HAPPEN IN MY TIME AND EVERY
TIME TO DAYTHAT I YOU KNOW I
THINK ABOUT THIS AND I I START
TO SHAKE BECAUSE I THINK -- FOR
EVERY STUDENT THAT THAT --
SOMETHING HAPPENS TO THEM WHEN
THEY COMMIT SUICIDE OR GOD
FORBID -- YOU KNOW WHAT THIS IS
ON US YOU KNOW IF WE DON'T FIND
THESE FALSE IF WE CAN HAVE THOSE
DISCUSSIONS OFTENTIMES WE THINK
ABOUT EFFICIENCY WE THINK ABOUT.
WHAT MAKES SENSE WITHIN LIMITED
RESOURCES THESE ARE LIVES AND WE
CAN'T THINK OF THEM AS?
WHAT MAKES SENSE WE ONLY CAN DO
WHAT KEEPS THEM ALIVE SITE I
HIGHLY ENCOURAGE YOU TO TO GIVE
US THIS FUNDING BECAUSE IT'S
NECESSARY?
AND SORRY FOR THE SAKE THAT IT
SHOULD WAS TRIGGERING TO FOLKS
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
OKAY THANK YOU FOR THE PUBLIC
TESTIMONY ON THIS ISSUE AGAIN
WE'RE GONNA TRY TO MAKE THIS A
PRIORITY.
WITH OUR FINAL BUDGET ACTION
LET'S GO NOW TO THE UNIVERSE
CALIFORNIA AGENDA ITEMS THESE
ARE THE ISSUES THAT WE CAN
ADDRESS A FEW WEEKS AGO READ --
TIME.
SO ISSUE NUMBER.
TWO PERATIONAL COSTS.
UNDER NINETEEN MILLION ONGOING
FUNDING TO ADDRESS YOU SEE
OPERATIONAL COSTS DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE.
GOOD AFTERNOON JACK'S WALTER AND
FINANCE -- AS WE DISCUSSED IN A
PREVIOUS HEARING.
FULL YOU SEE PACKAGE FOR IN THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET THIS WINTER
NINETY THREE MILLION DOLLARS
GENERAL FUND. TO ORDER MILLION
TWO HUNDRED FORTY MILLION -- THE
WHICH IS ON GOING.
OF THIS TWO HUNDRED FORTY
MILLION ONGOING GENERAL FUND ONE
HUNDRED NINETEEN POINT EIGHT
MILLION IS FOR CONTRACTUALLY
CONTRACTUALLY OBLIGATED
COMPENSATION.
NON SELLER PRICE INCREASES
ANOTHER OPERATIONAL COSTS --
THIS FUNDING IS GOING TO BE
CRITICAL OPERATIONAL DEMANDS AT
THE UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA AND
WILL ALLOW THE UNIVERSITY TO
MAKE DECISIONS WITH OTHER
RESOURCES TO MEET STATE GOALS --
AND YEAH A LOT OF THIS
INVESTMENT THE ADMINISTRATION
SIGNALED ITS INTENTION THAT YOU
SEE KEEP ITS TUITIONFLAT IN --
TWENTY NINETEEN TWENTY WE ARE --
GLAD TO HEAR FROM PRESIDENT PAUL
TANA THAT THAT WILL BE THE CASE
AND WE LOOK FORWARD TO A
CONVERSATION ON HOW WE CAN
COLLABORATE ON SHORT AND LONG
TERM INITIATIVES TO PROVIDE
FISCAL STIR CERTAIN.
STUDENTS AND THEIR FAMILIES
INCREASED ACCESS IMPROVE STUDENT
SUCCESS GREAT MORE COST
EFFICIENT SYSTEM OF HIGHER
EDUCATION IMPROVE THE LINK
BETWEEN HIGHER EDUCATION AND THE
SKILLS IF THE ECONOMY BOTH NOW
AND IN THE FUTURE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU LA -- DECENT
CONCENTRATE SOLELY -- REGARDING
THIS SPECIFIC ITEM IF YOU TURN
TO PAGE SIX OF YOUR AGENDA IT
HAS A TABLE THAT BREAKS OUT HOW
YOU SEE WOULD SPEND THE PROPOSED
A HUNDRD TWENTY MILLION DOLLARS
ON GOING.
AND YOU'RE LOOKING AT THAT LIST
YOU CAN THINK OF IT AS ROUGHLY
INTO DIFFERENT CATEGORIES THE
FIRST YOU CAN THINK OF IS.
WHAT YOU MIGHT CONSIDER BASIC
COST INCREASES THAT THE
UNIVERSITY ENCOURAGE EACH YEAR?
THINGS LIKE PENSION COST
INCREASES BENEFIT COST INCREASES
EQUIPMENT COST INCREASES.
WE DON'T TAKE ISSUE WITH THESE.
ANY OF THESE ESTIMATES HERE.
THE SECOND AREA -- IN THIS LIST
IS WHAT YOU COULD CALL
COMPENSATION AND THIS IS --
SOMETHING THAT THE LEGISLATURE
FACES EVERY YEAR.
HOW MUCH IN SALARIES INCREASE
FOR EMPLOYEES FACULTY AND STAFF
EACH YEAR?
AND USUALLY LEGISLATURE WOULD
CONSIDER THINGS LIKE RICK --
RECRUITMENT AND RETENTION ISSUES
HOW WELL THE UNIVERSITY IS.
WORKING IN EACH OF THE FOR EACH
OF ITS EMPLOYEES GROUPS.
WELL ONE THING WE WOULD NOTE
HERE THAT'S SOMEWHAT DIFFERENT
THAN SAY THE WAY THE GOVERNOR'S
TREATING CSU.
IS THE GOVERNOR'S EXPLICITLY
FUNDING.
SALARY INCREASES.
FOR REPRESENTED EMPLOYEES AND
THAT'S ABOUT A THIRD OF COURSE
FUNDED EMPLOYEES THAT YOU SEE
THERE MEANING TWO THIRDS OF A OF
YOU SEE EMPLOYERS ARE NOT ARE
NOT.
A NON REPRESENTED.
AND A FOR SOME CONTACTS THAT
INCLUDES ALL TEN YEAR TENURE
TRACK FACULTY.
AND ALSO INCLUDES A MOST
ADMINISTRATIVE COURT FUNDED
MINISTRY TO STAFF THAT YOU SEE
YOU.
NOW THE ADMINISTRATION NOTES
THAT THE UNIVERSITY HAS
IDENTIFIED -- VARIOUS NON STATE
RESOURCES IT'S ABOUT A HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS ON GOING THAT IT
ALSO INCLUDED IN ITS -- BUDGET%
PLANS AND COULD BE AVAILABLE TO
COVER ONGOING COSTS IT'S
REASONABLE THAT YOU WOULD.
FACTOR THOSE INTO YOUR BUDGET
DECISIONS.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU TERM MCCARTY A MEMBERS
OF THE SUBCOMMITTEE FOR HAVING
ME HERE TODAY I'M SAY EVER
TENANT AND I'LL BE SPEAKING ON
BEHALF OF THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA.
ON SLIDE TWO OF MY PRESENTATION
THAT THE SERGEANT JUST HANDED
OUT.
YOU'LL SEE THAT THE UNIVERSITY
OF CALIFORNIA'S BUDGET REQUEST
IS CENTERED AROUND THE REGION'S
MULTI YEAR PLAN WHICH AIMS TO
INCREASE THE NUMBER OF YOU SEE
DEGREES AWARDED BY TWO HUNDRED
THOUSAND BY.
TWENTY THIRTY THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA'S MULTI YEAR PLAN
FUNDING MODEL HAS THREE AREAS OF
FOCUS SUSTAINING OUR CURRENT
OPERATIONS FUNDING GROWTH AND
FACULTY STUDENTS AND PROGRAMS.
AND ADDRESSING CAPITAL NEEDS AND
THIS NEXT ITEM WILL BE TALKING
ABOUT THE SUSTAINING OF CURRENT
OPERATIONS.
AS A BRIEF REMINDER ON SLIDE
THREE YOU'LL SHEET YOU'LL SEE
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET PROPOSAL
FOR YOU SEE WHICH WE ARE
REQUESTING THAT YOU SUPPORT FOR
US -- THAT INCLUDES THE FIVE
POINT THREE MILLION FOR STUDENT
MENTAL HEALTH THAT YOU JUST
HEARD EXTENSIVELY UP REGARDING --
ON SLIDE FOR IS THE ONE TIME
FUNDS PROPOSED FOR THE
UNIVERSITY BY THE GOVERNOR AND
WE'RE VERY GRATEFUL THAT HE
RECOGNIZES THE DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE.
AND THE UNIVERSITY'S ROLE IN IT
A NEW DEGREE COMPLETION EFFORTS
AND WILL DISCUSS BOTH OF THOSE
LATER IN THIS HEARING -- THE
UNIVERSITY IS REQUESTED THIS
COMMITTEE IN ADDITION TO WHAT
THE GOVERNOR HAS PROVIDED TO US
AS HUNDRED AND EIGHTY TWO POINT
SIX MILLION DOLLARS.
OF THIS I'D LIKE TO FOCUS ON
THREE NINETY FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS -- THAT IS STEVE FIRST
ITEM ON THAT SLIDE -- IN THE
CURRENT YEAR IN EIGHTEEN
NINETEEN THE UNIVERSITY RECEIVED
ONE TIME FUNDS FOR TUITION AND
STUDENT SERVICES BE BUYOUT.
AS WELL AS TO SUPPORT TWO
THOUSAND FIVE HUNDRED CALIFORNIA
UNDERGRADUATES THAT WE OVER AND
ROLLED BY AND TWENTY SIXTEEN AND
TWENTY SEVENTEEN AND YOU MAY
RECALL LAST YEAR WHEN WE WERE
DISCUSSING THIS FUNDING IN THE
SUBCOMMITTEE -- THIS
SUBCOMMITTEE PROVIDED THESE DOES
NINETY FIVE MILLION TO US AS
PERMITTED FUNDING BECAUSE YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED THE ROLE OF A
TUITION BY OUT.
AS AN ON GOING SUPPORT FOR THE
UNIVERSITY -- ALSO THIS NINETY
FIVE MILLION -- INCLUDED THE
STUDENT SERVICES BE BY OUT OF
THE FOUR POINT EIGHT MILLION FOR
STUDENT MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES.
THAT WE ALSO DISCUSSED IN THIS
HEARING EARLIER -- UNFORTUNATELY
IN THE LATE STAGES OF THE BUDGET
NEGOTIATIONS THE NINETY FIVE
MILLION WAS MADE ONE TIME
FUNDING.
AND WE'RE HERE NOW REQUESTING
THAT IT BE MADE PERMANENT -- SO
THAT WE CAN CONTINUE ALL THE
SERVICES THAT HOW START BEEN
STARTED FORTY STUDENTS WITH THE
SPENDING.
ON SLIDE SIX YOU'LL SEE SOME OF
THOSE -- SERVICES THAT WE HAVE
BEEN -- HAD THAT HAVE BEEN
UNDERTAKEN WITH THIS NINETY FIVE
MILLION THIS INCLUDES HIRING
FOURTEEN LETTERING FACULTY.
AT UC RIVERSIDE AND SEVENTEEN
NEW LOT AROUND FACULTY AT UCLA
WE SPENT OVER THIRTY TWO MILLION
ON NEW LECTURES A NEW GRADUATE
STUDENTS INSTRUCTORS.
EXPANDING THE CAPACITY OF
COURSES ON CAMPUSES SO THAT
STUDENTS CAN.
STUDENTS CAN GET THE COURSES
THAT THEY NEED TO GRADUATE IN A
TIMELY MATTER.
SOME OF THE FUNDS WERE SPENT ON
LIBRARY SERVICES -- ON STUDENT
ADVISORS -- TITLE NINE SEXUAL
ASSAULT SEXUAL VIOLENCE
COORDINATORS -- ON MENTAL HEALTH
COUNSELORS AND OTHER ASPECTS OF
THE UNIVERSITY'S OPERATIONS AND
WE'RE HOPING THAT YOU CONTINUE
THIS FUNDING FOR THE UNIVERSITY
SO WE CAN SUSTAIN THOSE
OPERATIONS.
THEN SLIDE SEVEN CONTINUES THE
DISCUSSION OF COSTS FOR OUR
CURRENT COME CAMPUS OPERATIONS
THESE WERE TOUCHED ON ALREADY BY
THE LA -- AND DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE THAT FIRST HUNDRED
NINETEEN POINT EIGHT MILLION IS
INCLUDED IN THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET AND WE'RE VERY GRATEFUL
THAT HE RECOGNIZES.
THAT THE UNIVERSITY HAS
MANDATORY COST INCREASES IN
LABOR RETIREMENT AND HEALTH THAT
MUST BE MET -- THESE MANDATORY
COST MAY SEEM LIKE A VERY LARGE
INCREASE -- WHEN COMPARED TO THE
SIZE OF OTHER STATE AGENCIES BUT
I'D LIKE YOU TO REMEMBER THAT
THIS IS IN REGARDS TO
UNIVERSITIES THREE POINT SEVEN
BILLION DOLLAR BUDGET?
THIS ACTUALLY REPRESENTS A 3%
INCREASE IN COSTS WHICH IS
APPROXIMATELY IN LINE WITH
INFLATION.
AND I'M HAPPY TO ANSWER MORE
QUESTIONS ABOUT THOSE ITEMS -- I
ALSO WANT TO EMPHASIZE THAT NOT
RECEIVING THE TWO HUNDRED UP TO
NINETY FIVE MILLION FROM THE
CURRENT YEAR WILL.
IF WE DON'T RECEIVE THAT
PERMANENTLY IT WILL EAT INTO THE
UNIVERSITY'S ABILITY TO COVER
THESE COSTS. TO THE POINT THAT
ALTHOUGH WE'RE RECEIVING TWO
HUNDRED AND FORTY MILLION ONCE
THE MANDATORY COST SHOWN HERE
AND THE PROP FIFTY SIX
OBLIGATIONS ARE SUBTRACTED.
THE NINETY FIVE MILLION THE
UNIVERSITY WOULD HAVE TO
IMPLEMENT SOME OPERATIONAL
REDUCTIONS IN ORDER -- TO UP
AHEAD INTO NINETEEN TWENTY IF WE
DON'T RECEIVE THAT NINETY FIVE
PERMANENTLY.
OTHER HIGH PRIORITY COST YOU SEE
INCLUDED ON THIS PAGE INCLUDE
FACULTY COMPENSATION STAFF
COMPENSATION AND CAPITAL OF LATE
DEBT SERVICE AND ALL DISCUSS THE
CAPITAL OUTLAY LATER.
IN THIS HEARING ISSUES.
SIX THE STAFF COMPENSATION
PROPOSAL IS FOR FORTY TWO POINT
SIX MILLION DOLLARS -- AND
REPRESENTS A 3% SALARY INCREASE
FOR UC'S NON REPRESENTED STAFF.
I IN FOUR OF THE PAST TEN YEARS
YOU SEE WAS UNABLE TO PROVIDE
STAFF SALARY INCREASE PROGRAM
FOR THE ON REPRESENTS STAFF.
AND OVER THE PAST TEN YEARS THE
AVERAGE ANNUAL BUDGET INCREASE
FOR STAFF SALARIES WITH ABOUT
ONE POINT 8%.
ANNUALLY FOR THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA SYSTEM -- OTHER STATE
AGENCIES DURING THIS TIME HAVE
BEEN ABLE TO PROVIDE A 225%
SALARY INCREASES ANNUALLY -- AND
NEXT SLIDE I WILL DISCUSS THE
COMPONENTS OF THE FACULTY SALARY
INCREASE OF WE'RE PROPOSING ON
SLIDE EIGHT YOU'LL SEE SOME
FACTS.
ABOUT WHY WE WANT TO INCREASE
OUR FACULTY SALARIES.
THE FACULTY SALARY COMPENSATION
TO NINETY FOUR POINT FOUR
MILLION INCLUDES THREE PARTS.
THERE'S THIRTY THREE MILLION
DOLLARS FOR FACULTY MERIT
INCREASES.
THAT REFERS OF FACULTY
PERFORMANCE REVIEW WHERE FACULTY
ARE PROMOTED EITHER FROM AN
ASSISTANT PROFESSOR TO AN
ASSOCIATE PROFESSOR OR FROM AN
ASSOCIATE PROFESSOR TO A FULL
PROFESSOR OR THEY MOVE UP IN --
SALARY STEPS WITH IN THOSE RANKS
AND THERE ARE RANKED BASED ON
PERFORMANCE OF HOW MUCH THEY
PUBLISH HOW MANY COURSES THEY
TEACH AND SO FORTH THAT THEY IF
THEY MEET THOSE CRITERIA THEY
CAN MOVE UP IN THEIR STEPS OF
PAY.
AND WE ESTIMATE THAT THAT WILL
COST APPROXIMATELY THIRTY THREE
MILLION DOLLARS FOR THIS COMING
YEAR.
WE HAVE TO PROVIDE THE FACULTY
MERITS ANNUALLY BECAUSE IN
NINETEEN NINETY THREE WE LOST
THE CASE IN SAN FRANCISCO
SUPERIOR COURT -- DUE TO TRYING --
TO IT AND THE FACULTY MERIT
PROGRAM ONE YEAR DUE TO BUDGET
CONCERNS AND THE COURT FOUND
THAT WE WOULD NOT BE ABLE.
TO DENY FACULTY THEIR REVIEWS
DUE TO BUDGETARY CONCERNS.
OF THE SECOND COMPONENT OF THE
FACULTY COMPENSATION PIECES OF
FORTY SEVEN POINT FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS TO FUND AN AVERAGE
FACULTY SALARY INCREASE OF 3%
FOR ALL.
A LOT OF RANK FACULTY IN THE
UNIVERSITY.
AND THEN WE'RE ALSO PROPOSING
ANOTHER THIRTEEN POINT NINE
MILLION FOUR SEPARATE SALARY
PROGRAM IS PART OF A MULTI YEAR
EFFORT TO CLOSE TO UNIVERSITIES
LOT OF RANK FACULTY SALARY GAP.
WITH OUR COMPETITOR INSTITUTIONS
OVER TIME AND ON SLIDE EIGHT
YOU'LL SEE THAT -- WHERE THE
UNIVERSITY SALARIES ARE ARE
BELOW -- WHERE ARE COMPARISON
INSTITUTES CURRENTLY ARE WHERE
ABOUT SIX POINT 7% BELOW ON
SLIDE?
EIGHT YOU WILL SEE A CHART THAT
SHOWS THAT -- WHERE SIX POINT
SEVEN BELOW ARE COMPARISON
INSTITUTES -- WHEN FACULTY LEAVE
THE UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA
FIFTEEN OUT OF TWENTY LEE FOR
PRIVATE UNIVERSITIES WHICH IS
WHY WE DO THINK THAT COMPARING
OURSELVES TO PRIVATE
INSTITUTIONS CONTINUES TO BE A
RELEVANT METRIC -- UC'S
COMPARISON INSTITUTIONS WERE
SELECTED AFTER AN EXTENSIVE
DISCUSSION WITH THE LA -- AND
THE NOW DEFUNCT C. PACK THE
TECHNOLOGY EXISTS THERE MAY BE --
SOME -- REASON MAYBE TO GO BACK
AND RE EXAMINE THOSE AT SOME
POINT BUT THERE CURRENTLY ARE
THE BEST THAT -- METRIC THAT WE
DO HAVE.
THERE WAS A NINETY TWENTY
SIXTEEN STUDY THAT SHOWED THAT
AMONG OUR FACULTY MEMBERS WHO
LEFT YOU SEE FOR ANOTHER
INSTITUTION.
SALARY WAS THE MOST OFTEN CITED
REASON.
SALARY WAS ALL THIS IS ALSO THE
SECOND MOST CITED REASON AMONG
THOSE WHO DECIDED TO REMAIN AT
UC. 91% OF WHOM RECEIVED AN
ADDITIONAL SALARY IN THE
RETENTION OFFER.
SO WE DO FIND THAT OUT TO SALARY
OFFERS MAKE A SIGNIFICANT
DIFFERENCE IN THE FACULTY I THE
REMAINING WITH US OR LEAVING US
FOR ANOTHER INSTITUTION.
AND THAT CONCLUDE MY
OPERATIONAL COMPONENT OPERATIONS
COST -- PRESENTATION -- A ANY
QUESTIONS -- THANK YOU.
I'D LIKE.
TO KNOW FIRST GAS THE LA -- AND
THEN -- THE UNIVERSITY
CALIFORNIA.
TO TO RESPOND BUT I I SEE IN THE
COMMITTEE ANALYSIS ON THE ISSUE
OF OF FACULTY.
SALARIES AND COMPETITIVENESS THE
COMMITTEE ANALYSIS INDICATES
THAT THE LA -- DOES KNOW THAT
SOME DATA SUGGESTS.
YOU SEE IS COMPETITIVE IN
RECRUITING FACULTY AND THAT
SEEMS TO BE.
CONTRADICTED BY THE UC'S
REPRESENTED COULD YOU ELABORATE
ON THAT.
SURE SO I'M.
YOU SEE USED TO COMPREHENSIVELY
GATHER DATA ON RECRUITMENT AND
RETENTION OF FACULTY -- THEY
INDICATE THA THAT SYSTEM Y.
DATA OR IS NO LONGER AVAILABLE
BUT SEVERAL YEARS AGO WE DID AN
ANALYSIS OF THE DATA THAT WAS
AVAILABLE.
AND WE FOUND THAT THE UNIVERSITY
WAS SUCCESSFULLY -- RECRUITING
AND RETAINING FACULTY WE LOOKED
AT A NUMBER OF DIFFERENT
MEASURES BECAUSE THAT DOES THE
SEVERAL YEARS OLD -- YOU KNOW
THINGS CAN CHANGE OVER THE
COURSE OF SEVERAL YEARS AND SO
WE DON'T HAVE.
ANY UPDATED DATA TO REALLY
PROVIDE THE LEGISLATURE'S TECH
TO GUIDE YOU ON THE ON THOSE
DATA.
THE ONE EVIDENCE WE DO HAVE HIS.
SALARY COMPARISONS.
NUMBER COMES A SALARY
COMPARISONS THE THE KEY QUESTION
FOR THE LEGISLATURE IS -- WHO
DOES THE LEGISLATURE WANT YOU
SEE TO COMPETE AGAINST?
THE ORIGINAL COMPARISON EAT
INSTITUTIONS THAT YOU SEE --
COMPARES ITSELF TO ON PAGE AIDS
AND YOU CAN SEE IT'S A SELECT
GROUP OF PRIVATE AND PUBLIC
RESEARCH UNIVERSITIES.
THAT INCLUDES -- A FEW OF KEY
PUBLIC INSTITUTIONS THAT EACH
STATE -- AND ALSO INCLUDES A FEW
VERY SELECTIVE -- AN EXPENSIVE
PRIVATE INSTITUTIONS.
ALTERNATIVELY IN THE IN THE PAST
WE'VE COMPARED UC FACULTY
SALARIES TO A BROADER GROUP OF
PUBLIC HI RESEARCH UNIVERSITIES.
ABOUT SEVENTY OF THOSE ACROSS
THE NATION.
WE FIND THAT YOU SEE FACULTY ARE
ARE PAID A ABOVE THE AVERAGE OF
THOSE OTHER INSTITUTIONS OTHERS
ARE MOSTLY PUBLIC INSTITUTIONS
AND PART OF WHAT DRIVES UP THE
COMPARISON EIGHT COMPARISON OR
THESE PRIVATE INSTITUTIONS LIKE
HARVARD MIT.
AND SO THAT'S SORT OF THE KEY
QUESTION FOR THE LEGISLATURE'S I
DOESN'T WANT YOU SEE TO COMPETE
AS A AS AN ENTIRE SYSTEM AGAINST --
THESE SELECT NUMBER OF
INSTITUTIONS AS A WANT TO LOOK
AT A BROADER NUMBER OF
INSTITUTIONS BUT TO KEEP.
ISSUE THAT THE LEGISLATURE FACES
EACH YEAR -- I DON'T HAVE THE
MOST RECENT DATA ON OUR
RECRUITMENT OF FACULTY -- I
WOULD POINT TO SOME OF THE
RETENTION DATA IN THIS WE
RECRUIT A LOT OF VERY YOUNG
TALENTED FACULTY AND WE OFFER IN
ADDITION TO THEIR SALARY WELL
FOR THEM WHAT'S CALLED START UP.
WHICH IS -- SOMETIMES LABORATORY
RENOVATIONS SOMETIMES ITS
INITIAL RESEARCH FUNDING AND SO
FORTH -- THOSE CAN BE VERY
ENTICING TO A YOUNG FACULTY
HARKENING STARTED IN THEIR
CAREERS -- BUT WHAT WE'RE
FINDING IS WERE STRUGGLING TO
KEEP THEM ONCE THEY'RE PAST THAT
INITIAL ASSISTANT PROFESSOR
LEVEL -- THAT WE HAVE YOUNG
EXPRESSION WE FACULTY FROM
UNDERREPRESENTED MINORITY
BACKGROUNDS.
TEND TO GET OFF ONCE THEY SHOW
HOW GREAT THEY ARE AND THEY'RE
DOING ALL THEIR PUBLISHING --
OTHER UNIVERSITIES BEGIN TO
RECRUIT THEM QUITE AGGRESSIVELY
AND WE ARE FINDING THAT WHEN WE
OFFERED THEM HIGHER PAY.
THAT GETS MANY OF THEM TO STAY
WITH US THEY WANT TO BE AT YOU
SEE BECAUSE OF OUR PUBLIC
MISSION.
BECAUSE OF OUR HIGHLY TALENTED
WE OFFERED THEM HIGHLY TALENTED
COLLEAGUES -- AND ALSO
CALIFORNIA IS A WONDERFUL PLACE
TO BE SO -- THEY WANT TO BE HERE
BUT WE ARE FINDING THAT --
RETENTION IS AN ISSUE I DON BUT
I DON'T HAVE THE DATA ON HOW
MANY OFFERS WE INITIALLY MAKE
THEM ARE REJECTED -- WE DO FIND
THAT -- A LOT OF OUR FACULTY
LEAVE FOR OTHER HIGH PAYING
INSTITUTIONS WE DON'T THINK THAT
WE SHOULD BE COMPARED --TO JUST
ANY RESEARCH INSTITUTION OR JUST
ANY PUBLIC INSTITUTION BECAUSE
OF OUR FOCUS ON RESEARCH AND
CONTRIBUTING TO THE PUBLIC --
PUBLIC KNOWLEDGE IN PUBLIC
SERVICE REQUIREMENTS THAT ARE
FACULTY HAVE.
ME -- TOO PAYMENT MISTER
CHAIRMAN I I I WANTED TO MAKE
THE POINT THAT -- YOU KNOW IT --
THE COMMISSION ALSO SEND AND TO
CREATE A INDICATES A LEE SAID.
THAT THE THAT THERE'S SOME
AGREEMENT THAT WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION'S ASSESSMENT THAT
NON REPRESENTED FACULTY
INCREASES CAN CAN BE CONSIDER
OPTIONAL BUT BUT BUT AND AND
THAT THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL
SEEMS TO BE.
FOCUSING ON THE REPRESENTED.
EMPLOYEES BUT IT SEEMS TO ME AND
I I WOULD LOVE TO HEAR WHAT.
YOU KNOW THE REST OF THE
COMMITTEE THANKS BUT YOU KNOW
WHAT I WANT TO CAL.
THE THE THE THE REPUTATION OF
THE UNIVERSITY WAS NOT.
BASED ON THE UNDERGRADUATE WAS
BASED ON THE FACULTY AND AND AND
THE ABILITY -- TO TO RECRUIT
INTO INTO -- KEEP I AM MEMBER
THERE WAS ALWAYS THERE.
THE YOU KNOW THE THE WHEN THE
MOST -- THE PROUDEST THINGS THAT
THAT THE UNIVERSITY WOULD ALWAYS
TELL WAS A NUMBER OF NOBEL PRIZE --
WINNERS IT WAS AT THE UNIVERSITY
AND I I WOULD THINK THAT IN
ORDER.
TO MAKE SURE THAT WE KEEP.
AND AND AND PROTECT THE
UNIVERSITY CALIFORNIA BRAND THAT
THAT WE NEED.
TO YOU KNOW PRIORITIZE --
SPECIALLY FACULTY SALARIES --
NOW HAVING SAID THAT YOU KNOW I
I I JUST DON'T SEE HOW THE
UNIVERSITY CALIFORNIA CAN
COMPETE WITH INSTITUTIONS LIKE
HARVARD STANFORD AND YELL AND IN
TERMS OF THEIR YOU KNOW THEIR
THEIR MASSIVE AND TALENTS I MEAN
A YOU KNOW LIKE -- IT SEEMS LIKE
THAT'S AN EASY WAY -- TO TO SKEW --
GOD -- COMPENSATION -- GUY
COMPARISON -- BUT YEAH HI I JUST
WANTED.
TO HIGHLIGHT OR OUR FOCUS ON THE
ISSUE OF OF COMPETITIVE FACULTY
SALARIES BECAUSE I THINK THAT'S
VERY IMPORTANT -- IT TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE CONTINUE TO HAVE.
IN A WHAT I CONSIDER TO BE THE
THE COUNTRY'S BEST PUBLIC
UNIVERSITY SYSTEM.
YEAH I THINK THERE'S TWO THINGS
ONE IT'S I THINK WITH THE
UNIVERSITY IT'S A LARGE
INSTITUTION SO IT'S YOU KNOW
EQUITY SISTER FACULTY BUT ALSO.
THE RANK AND FILE INDIVIDUALS.
TO HELP KEEP THE UNIVERSITY --
RUNNING I THINK THAT'S IMPORTANT
AS WELL WE TAKE CARE OF THEIR
SALARY NEEDS BECAUSE YEAH COST
TO RENT BECAUSE THE FOOD IS THE
SAME PER FOR IT FOR THOSE
INDIVIDUALS AND THEIR WAY LOWER
ON THE ON THE PAY SCALE THAT
BEING SAID YEAH WE WE WANT TO
MAKE SURE.
WE DON'T.
LOSE -- FACULTY TO OTHER PUBLIC
UNIVERSITIES AND AND PIRATES OF
COURSE IT'S ALL YOU KNOW
BALANCING ACTS SO WE'RE TRYING.
TO BALANCE OUR PRIORITIES --
THANK YOU [inaudible]
MISTER GALLAGHER.
YES SO I THOUGHT I JUST KIND OF
GO THROUGH A FEW THINGS HERE --
YOU KNOW WE START WITH YOU KNOW
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET RIGHT
PROVIDES -- TWO OR FORTY MILLION
OF ONGOING STATE GENERAL FUND --
MAN ON TOP OF THAT A HUNDRED
FIFTY THREE MILLION ONE TIME --
PLEASE FIFTEEN MILLION OF THAT
IS FOR DEGREE COMPLETION EFFORTS
IT AND WE'VE TALKED ABOUT THIS
THAT.
YOU KNOW I'M NOT SURE THAT USING
THE UC EXTENSION IS IS.
REALLY THE BEST WAY TO GET OUT
THERE AND I THINK THERE'S A WAY
TO GET TO THAT TWO MORE ISSUES
RIGHT AND AND SO YOU KNOW I KNOW
WE'LL GET TO THAT BUT YOU KNOW
SO WITH THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET I
THINK WE CAN DO.
SOME RE WORKING THERE I THINK
THERE WAS ALSO WAS IT FIFTY
MILLION.
FOR COMPLETING A FOUR YEARS
WHERE WE'RE SEEING SOME OF THE
BIGGEST ISSUES WITH THAT IS
REALLY IN THE CSU AND I WONDER
IF MONEY IS ACTUALLY.
BETTER SPENT THERE BUT GETTING
TO SO YOU SEE REQUEST.
ON TOP OF WHAT WE'VE ALREADY
PROPOSED WHICH IS A SIGNIFICANT
SUM.
A HUNDRED EIGHTY TWO MILLION
ADDITIONAL DOLLARS -- YOU KNOW.
SOME OF WHICH AS I SEE THE NEED --
FOR YEAH BUT I BUT AGAIN I THINK
YOU KNOW PORT A PORTION OF THIS
FORTY POINT THREE TWO AND ROLLED
TWENTY FIVE HUNDRED MORE
UNDERGRADUATES IN A THOUSAND
MORE GRADUATE STUDENTS.
AGAIN ONE OF THE PROBLEMS WE'VE
HAD AS WE DON'T YOU GUYS DON'T
TELL US HOW MANY PEOPLE YOU'RE
IN ROLLING.
WE GET THOSE NUMBERS AFTER THE
FACT SO I DON'T KNOW HOW HOW
MUCH THAT NUMBER'S GOING TO
CHANGE.
AND THEN AGAIN I I I SEE THAT
THE CSU ACTUALLY PROVIDES.
HAS THE GREATEST POTENTIAL
PROVIDE MORE MOMENT FOR
UNDERGRADUATES -- AND WITHOUT
HAVING REALLY DEFINED NUMBERS --
FROM YOU GUYS AND NOT GET IN
AFTER THE FACT I'M NOT REALLY
COMFORTABLE ADDING ANOTHER FORTY
MILLION DOLLARS. TO THEIR BUDGET
JUST BECAUSE YOU KNOW THEY SAY
RIGHT -- YOU KNOW FUNDS TO
SUPPORT FACULTY NOW LOOK -- I
UNDERSTAND THE NEED TO KEEP A
RETAIN -- FACULTY -- I THINK
UNFORTUNATELY AS MY COLLEAGUE --
FROM THE FROM THE SOUTH BAY HAS --
HAS MENTIONED YOU KNOW THERE WAS
A TIME WHEN WE HAD I THINK A
REALLY HIGH LEVEL.
FACULTY -- QUITE FRANKLY I THINK
THE STANDARDS HAVE CHANGED --
AND RIGHT NOW I KNOW YOU EMPLOY
PROFESSOR UC BERKELEY THE CALLS
FOR THE UC DAVIS SORRY I DON'T
WANT TO BE SMART BERKELEY -- BUT
UC DAVIS WHO CALLS FOR THE
KILLING OF COPS.
AND WHOSE SPECIALTY IS IN CRISIS
THEORY AND THE END OF CAPITALISM --
HIS LATEST BOOK IS RYAN STRIKE
RYAN.
I WOULD VENTURE TO SAY THAT OUR
STANDARDS OF FACULTY HAS.
GROSSLY DEPLETED AT THE UC
SYSTEM -- AND I DON'T KNOW YOU
KNOW I'M SURE THERE'S MANY GREAT
FACULTY.
AT THE UNIVERSITY SYSTEM BUT
THEY'RE OBVIOUSLY NOT VERY --
DISCERNING IN WHO THEY HIRE AND
AND THE KIND OF EDUCATION THAT I
THINK WE NEED TO PROVIDE. FOR
THE FUTURE OF CALIFORNIANS IN
THIS STATE SO NO I DON'T REALLY
FEEL LIKE SIGN A BLANK CHECK OR
WILL IN THIS CASE NINETY FOUR
MILLION DOLLARS. FOR FACULTY
INCREASES UNTIL I SEE.
A MUCH DIFFERENT SITUATION AT UC.
YOU KNOW AND AGAIN IT IT JUST
GOES ON ON AS MORE HEY.
MOST OF THESE CONTRACTS MOST OF
THESE COSTS YOU GUYS ARE THE
ONES ARE IN THE PLACE TO
NEGOTIATE.
NOT THE PEOPLE UP HERE YOU
NEGOTIATE WITH WITH YOUR FACULTY
AND STAFF OVER PENSION BENEFITS
OVER HEALTH BENEFITS OF ALL
THOSE PREMIUMS.
SO YOU NEGOTIATED AND THEN YOU
COME TO US AND SAY PAY THE BILL.
I MEAN TO ME THAT'S TOTALLY
BACKWARDS YEAH -- AND YOU KNOW
LOOK.
WHEN YOU MAKE THESE PLANS IN
ADVANCE I MEAN IT JUST SEEMS TO
ME THAT THEY ALWAYS KNOW THAT
THE MONEY WILL BE HERE BECAUSE
WE KEEP GIVING THEM THE MONEY?
AND LET ME GET TO MY FINAL POINT
WHICH IS THEY STILL ARE NOT
MEETING THE OBJECTIVES FOR FOR
ENROLLING IN STATE STUDENTS
WHICH THIS IS A UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA.
AND AT THE HIGHEST LEVELS THAT
BERKELEY AT UCLA THERE'S STILL
NOT MEETING.
THEIR STANDARDS AND THEY'RE
BRINGING IN OUT OF STATE
STUDENTS WHY BECAUSETHERE'S
ANOTHER BANKROLL OF MONEY THAT
THEY CAN RELY ON YOU KNOW. FOR
WHATEVER THEY CAN'T GET FROM US
THEY'RE GETTING FROM OUT OF
STATE STUDENT MOMENTS AND THEY
CONTINUE TO DO THIS SO.
SO NO I'M NOT REALLY INCLINED TO
DISCO OKAY HERE'S ANOTHER
HUNDRED EIGHTY TWO MILLION
DOLLARS.
OVER THE THREE HUNDRED AND FIFTY
THREE THERE WE'VE ALREADY
PROPOSED IN THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET -- DEFINITELY WANT TO
LOOK AT HEY HOW DO WE SHOULD
SOME OF THESE MONIES AROUND SO
WE GET THE BEST BANG FOR OUR
BUCK.
AND BY THE WAY WE JUST HEARD
FROM ALL THE STUDENTS.
WHO ARE SAYING YOU'RE NOT
PROVIDING THE SERVICES THAT THEY
NEED?
AND NOW YOU WANT US TO PROVIDE
YOU MORE MONEY TO TO INCREASE
THE AMOUNT OF STUDENTS THAT YOU
HAVE THERE AND YOU'RE ALREADY
NOT PROVIDING. FOR THE NEEDS
THAT THEY HAVE IN IN MANY
DIFFERENT INSTANCES HEALTH
MENTAL HEALTH.
EXCEPT FOR A YOU KNOW AND YOU
KEEP AND YOU ALSO.
BY THE WAY THE THIRD PART OF
MONEY THAT YOU LIKE TO GO -- TO
TUITION RIGHT WHICH CONTINUES A
SPIKE AND THAT WE BOARDED OFF
ONLY BY GIVING YOU BY THE THREAT
OF YOU GUYS SAYING IF WE DON'T
GET MORE MONEY.
WE'RE GONNA RAISE TUITION ON
THESE POOR STUDENTS WHO ALREADY
PAYING THE HIGHEST.
TUITION COSTS AROUND -- NOT TO
MENTION THEN WE COMPARED OTHER
UNIVERSITIES RAY AND THANK YOU
FOR BRINGING THAT UP BECAUSE
ACTUALLY WERE REALLY IN LINE
WITH FACULTY SALARIES -- BUT YOU
LIKE TO COMPARE YOU LIKE.
TO USE THE COMPARISON THAT YOU
WANT TO USE. FOR YOUR PURPOSES
SO THAT YOU CAN GET MORE MONEY --
SO THAT YOU CAN TELL ME ABOUT
THESE REAL HIGH LEVEL FACULTY
THAT WE NEED TO RETAIN.
WELL I'VE SENIOR FACULTY OKAY.
AYE AYE WE'VE WE'VE ALL SEEN IT
VERY PUBLICLY HERE RECENTLY --
AND WE'VE ALSO SEEN THE RESPONSE
WHICH IS ONCE AGAIN IT'S THE
SAME RESPONSE FROM THE UC YOU
RAISE AN ISSUE THEY DO NOTHING.
THEY DO NOTHING TO ADDRESS THE
ISSUE BUT THEY KEEP COMING BACK
TO US FOR MONEY.
KEEP PAN FOR OPERATIONAL COSTS
KEEP PAYING FOR MORE THE SAME I
I I I QUITE FRANKLY AM TIRED OF
IT.
AND I'M NOT GOING TO I'M NOT
GOING TO ENABLE THAT KIND OF
ACTIVITY -- I DIDN'T EVEN
MENTION THE MONEY THAT WAS
SQUIRRELED AWAY IN THE OFFICE OF
THE PRESIDENT.
READ THAT WE HAD TO FIND OUT
ABOUT YOU KNOW.
AND I THINK WE TOOK CARE OF THAT
PROBLEM HOPEFULLY I MEAN I HOPE
WE DON'T FIND SOMETHING ELSE.
ISSUE NUMBER SO PLEASE STICK
AROUND BUT I THINK YOU I MEAN I
I KNOW I AGREE COMPLETION SO
WE'RE GONNA GET TO TO BOTH HIS
EYES.
BUT LOOK I I KNOW YOU YOU INSURE
MY FRUSTRATION I KNOW YEAH I
KNOW YOU HAD YOUR CONCERNS ON
THAT.
FACULTY MEMBER IN QUESTION AND
THAT'S ONLY ONE OF MY AYE BUT I
I WOULDN'T MENTION THAT TOO
BECAUSE IT IS NOT REALLY A ON
OUR AGENDA THIS IS THE BUDGET
OVERSIGHT TODAY BUT I WITH YOU
WE DON'T HAVE THE THEIR LEGAL
COUNSEL HERE BUT OUR
UNDERSTANDING IS THAT.
THE PEOPLE I'M ON THE DAY EXAM I
KNOW PEOPLE SAY ON THEIR OWN
TIME.
IS THAT PROTECTED SPEECH AND IT
WOULD CREATE -- MUCH MORE
HEADACHE ILLEGAL A DILEMMA FOR
THE UNIVERSITY IF IF WE IF WE
MADE A DECISION BUT YOU'RE OVER
OUR ARCHING ISSUES I THINK ARE
RIGHT IN LINE AND WE'RE LOOKING --
TO HEAVILY SCRUTINIZED -- THAN
THE THAN ISSUES COMING UP TO
DEGREE COMPLETION BECAUSE RIGHT
I DO THINK YOU'RE RIGHT THE
MAJORITY ISSUES IN THE CSU.
HANDS THIS YEAR'S BUDGET DOES
NOT HAVE ONE PENNY TO ENROLL NEW
STUDENTS FROM EAST NICHOLAS.
FROM TORRANCE HIGH SCHOOL FROM
MCCLATCHY HIGH SCHOOL FROM
RIVERSIDE HIGH SCHOOL.
AND FOR MUST BE A SANTA BARBARA
HIGH SCHOOL.
OXNARD HIGH SCHOOL SO THAT IS A
DISGRACE AND WE NEED TO BE
FOCUSING ON ON CALIFORNIA'S
FUTURE SO WE'LL GET TO THAT SO --
WITH THAT -- MISTER MEDINA OF
WITH ALL DUE RESPECT TO MY
COLLEAGUE FROM CHICO I DO WANNA
RESPOND TO A COUPLE OF THINGS --
AND ALSO MY COLLEAGUE FROM A THE
JOB.
UNIT RIGHT CLOSE THE RIGHT SOUTH
THERE -- FAR AS FACULTY.
ANNA AND I WANT TO DISAGREE I
WANT TO DISAGREE WITH MY
COLLEAGUE FROM CHICO -- WHO WHO
WHO?
WHO WITH MAY HAVE HAD?
SOME CONVERSATION.
ON THE ISSUE THAT HE RAISES --
UC RIVERSIDEHEADS TO NEW.
NOBEL PRIZE -- LAUREATES
PROFESSORS COMING TO UC
RIVERSIDE I BELIEVE ONE IN
PHYSICS AND ONE CHEMISTRY.
WHO I GOT TO MEET AT UCLA?
RECENTLY AND WHO ARE GONNA HAVE
A RECEPTION FOR AT UC ARE AND IN
THIS MONTH.
SO I I VERY MUCH DISAGREE WITH
MY COLLEAGUE FROM CHICO ON THE
COMPETENCY.
OF THE UC PROFESSORS AND AND AND
I AND I REALLY THINK THAT.
TO CAST A SHADOW.
ON THE PROFESSOR'S.
OF USE OF YOU SEE BECAUSE OF ONE
PROFESSOR -- ISN'T RIGHT.
WE WOULDN'T ALLOW OR WOULDN'T
WANT TO BE THAT DONE TO US.
AS LEGISLATORS AND I DON'T THINK
IT'S RIGHT TO DO IT -- ON UC
PROFESSORS EITHER.
AND AND AND AS WE SIT AROUND
THIS TABLE ALL OF US MANY OF US
HAVE HAD THE EXPERIENCE OF AND
THE BENEFIT OF THE EDUCATION
FROM I BELIEVE.
OUTSTANDING.
UC AND CSU PROFESSORS AND I
STILL HOLD THE PROFESSORS OF UC
AND CSU IN THAT SAME PLACE THAT
I HAD RESPECT FOR THEM.
AS AN UNDERGRADUATE WAY BACK IS
A STUDENT AT UC ARE AND I DO NOT
BELIEVE.
AND I DON'T WANT TO ALLOW TO GO
BY TO TO SAY THAT THE STATUS OR
EVEN A BAD WORD STATUE.
OF OF THE PROFESSORS OR THE
ABILITY OF THOSE PROFESSORS I DO
NOT THINK HAS DECLINED AT ALL.
AND SO I I DON'T WANNA LET THAT
GO BY -- WITHOUT COMMENT -- AND
I WANT TO VERY STRONGLY OF ARGUE
FOR THE REQUEST OF YOU SEE FOR
THE ON GOING NINETY FIVE MILLION.
OF WHICH WHICH UC'S ASKING FOR
AS ONGOING MANY I THINK THAT
NINETY FIVE MILLION IS ESSENTIAL
TO THE SUCCESS.
OF UC AND THE THE THE THE NINETY
FIVE MILLION ON GOING TO REPLACE
ONE TIME FUNDS.
I I I THINK IS A ASCENTIAL AND
VERY MUCH WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT
THAT NINETY FIVE MILLION IS
INCLUDED.
IN THE IN THE BUDGET THIS YEAR.
MISTER CHAIRMAN SURE WE'LL COME
BACK OUT I I ACTUALLY.
HADN'T QUITE FINISHED YOU KNOW
WHEN AND I AND I AND I DID THE
FOR BECAUSE I'VE IKNOW YOU
WANTED TO WRAP THAT UP.
BUT LOOK AGAIN.
MY POINT HERE WAS TO USE AN
EXAMPLE BECAUSE WHAT WE ARE
BEING ASKED TO APPROVE.
IS A FACULTY ACROSS THE BOARD
FACULTY INCREASES IN SALARIES
RIGHT -- AND I'M IT YOU KNOW
SENT IN THE STATEMENT IS BEING
MADE THE L. WE HAVE THIS WORLD
CLASS.
FACULTY ACROSS THE BOARD AND SO
THEREFORE WE MUST.
GIVE THIS NINETY FOUR MILLION
MORE DOLLARS AND I'M JUST USING
THIS AS ONE EXAMPLE -- ONE IS
VERY HIGH PROFILE BEEN OUT THERE
IN THE NEWS AND JUST AS TWO
NOBEL LAUREATES AT RIVERSIDE.
DOESN'T MEAN THAT EVERYBODY
ACROSS THE BOARD.
IS A NOBEL LAUREATE.
RIGHT. ONE PERSON AT UC DAVIS
DOESN'T MEAN THAT ALL OF THEM
ARE NOT.
BUT IT PASSED THE VERY BIG
QUESTION.
OF DO WE TRULY HAVE.
THIS STELLAR FACULTY IN THE UC
SYSTEM BECAUSE I I DON'T THINK
YOU CAN PAINT A BROAD BRUNCH
BRUSH LIKE THAT BUT THAT'S WHAT
I'M BEING ASKED TO DO.
BYE BYE BYE APPROVING NINETY
FOUR MILLION DOLLARS IN
INCREASES.
IN SALARIES BECAUSE IT'S IT'S
OUT IT'S OBVIOUSLY THE BEST.
WELL I JUST GAVE YOU A VERY HIGH
PROFILE EXAMPLE OF WHY I HAD I
QUESTION VERY HIGHLY THAT THAT'S
THE CASE.
AND I DO THINK IT'S A MAJOR
ORDEAL.
WHEN WE HAVE A PROFESSOR CALLING
FOR THE DEATHS OF ANY GROUP
PEOPLE GROUP -- I DON'T THINK WE
WOULD TOLERATE THAT IN MANY
INSTANCES AND IT SHOULD BE ANY
DIFFERENT WHEN IT COMES TO COPS.
WHO PROTECT US EACH AND EVERY
DAY -- AND YEAH I THINK THAT IS
BUT THAT WAS ONE OF MANY OTHER
ISSUES THAT I HAVE.
YOU KNOW WHAT WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT THE SALARIES BUT I'M
TALKING ABOUT MANY OTHER ISSUES
WHICH I THINK MANY OF US WOULD
AGREE THERE'S MAJOR PROBLEMS
HERE AND SO.
WE DON'T NEED TO I THINK WE CAN
AGREE.
JUST RUBBER STAMP WHAT THIS YOU
SEE ADMINISTRATION IS ASKING US
TO DO WHEN THEY'VE GOT A LOT OF
PROBLEMS -- SOME AREAS WE MAY
AGREE.
BUT SOME AREAS WE MAY DISAGREE
THAT THERE'S A PROBLEM.
THEN WE ALWAYS HAVE A RESPECTFUL
DISAGREEMENT -- MY COLLEAGUE
FROM RIVERSIDE -- BUT I THINK
THERE'S MANY AREAS WHERE WE ARE
AT BERRY MUCH IN AGREEMENT THAT
WE NEED TO SEE IMPROVEMENT AND
WE'RE NOT JUST GOING TO CONTINUE%
TO ENABLE.
THAT KIND OFATTITUDE FROM THE
ADMINISTRATION APPROVED THEIR
COSTS THAT'S ALL I'M TRYING TO
SAY.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER LIMA.
THANK YOU.
AND I THINK THAT IT'S YEAH I
REFLECT TO THE MANY EXAMPLES
THAT I HAVE -- OVER THE ELEVEN
YEARS THAT I WORKED ON THE CAN'T
AT UC SANTA BARBARA CAMPUS --
AND ALSO THINK ABOUT HOW THE
ROLE OF A PROFESSOR AND EVERY
OTHER EMPLOYEE AT THE UNIVERSITY
OF CALIFORNIA HAS CHANGED -- NOT
ONLY HAVE WE SEEN AN INCREASE IN
THE NUMBER OF STUDENTS -- THAT
WE HAVE AT THE UC -- WE JUST HAD
A PANEL THAT TALKED ABOUT -- THE
NEED FOR MORE MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES -- AND AN INCREASE IN
THE NUMBER OF STUDENTS WHO
REQUIRE -- A DIFFERENT KIND OF
ASSISTANCE -- YOU KNOW.
I A THINK OF ALL THE FACULTY THE
GRADUATE STUDENTS -- THAT OUR
LECTURERS OR THAT ARE YEAH.
D. A.'S AND HOW MUCH EVERY
SINGLE PERSON WHO WORKS AT THE
UNIVERSITY HAS HAD TO STEP UP TO
SERVE MORE STUDENTS -- TO DO
DIFFERENT TYPE OF WORK BY -- FOR
THE NINE YEARS THAT I WORKED ON
THE CAMPUS I WORKED WITH FACULTY
WHO WERE NOT PAID TO MENTOR
STUDENTS WHO MENTORED STUDENTS --
BY ADVISING THEM WELL ABOVE AND
BEYOND TO BECOME SOME DAY PHD
STUDENTS -- I A THINK THAT FOR
ME.
I I REALLY REFLECT ON REALLY
THOUSANDS OF EXAMPLES -- OVER
ELEVEN YEARS OF WATCHING PEOPLE
AT THE UC WORKERS AT THE UC GO
ABOVE AND BEYOND -- I MEAN WE
THINK OF THE UNIVERSITY CAMPUSES
AS PLACES WHERE STUDENTS GO THEY
HAVE STUDENT ACTIVITIES BAY DO
EXTRA CURRICULAR SO ALL OF THAT
TAKES STAFF. TO BE INVOLVED ALL
OF THAT TAKES -- FACULTY TO TRY
TO SUPPORT US STUDENTS IN
THINKING ABOUT WHAT'S HAPPENING
IN THE WORLD AND ALSO IN THE
CLASSROOM.
I DON'T THINK ANY INSTITUTION
ANY INDUSTRY ANY PROFESSIONAL
PLACE -- IS ABSENT OF BOTH
AMAZING EXAMPLES AND ALSO SOME
THAT FALL SHORT SO.
AT A THINK FOR ME I SEE THAT.
IF WE HAVE CONCERNS WITH THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA THAT.
THE METHOD TO ADDRESS THOSE
CONCERNS IS NOT TO DISINVEST
IT'S TO INVEST IN A STRATEGIC
WAY -- BECAUSE I THINK
DISINVESTMENT IN OUR HIGHER ED
SYSTEM IN THE INDIVIDUALS WHO
WORK IN THE CAMPUS IS ALSO A
DISINVESTMENT IN THE STUDENTS --
IT IS TRICKLE DOWN I HAVE SAID
THIS OVER AND OVER IN THIS
COMMITTEE OVER THE LAST THREE
YEARS -- THAT WHENEVER ANY
CONVERSATION IS HAPPENING ABOUT
IMPERFECTIONS THAT YOU KNOW
OFFICE OF THE PRESIDENT IT
TRICKLES DOWN TO STUDENTS AND I
CAN TELL YOU THAT BECAUSE I KNOW
WHAT THOSE BUDGETS LOOK LIKE.
I HAD TO DEAL WITH BUDGET THAT
WOULD BE SCALED BACK OR THAT WE
WOULD HAVE TO GO BACK I WAS ONE
OF THE INDIVIDUALS THAT HAD TO
DO THE DIFFERENT TYPE OF
REPORTING -- TO EXPLAIN THE
SUCCESS OF MY WORK TO SHOW THE
NEW METRICS THAT THE STATE
LEGISLATURE WAS ASKING.
FOR IT ALL IT I MEAN IN ALSO
MEANT I WAS DOING MORE REPORTING
BECAUSE THAT'S WHAT FOLKS WANTED
US TO DO WE WE DID IT BUT IT
CERTAINLY MEANT I WAS DOING LAST
ADVISING I WAS DESK DOING LESS --
PROGRAMMATIC WORK FOR THE
STUDENTS THERE ARE REAL TRICKLE
DOWN A FAX AND I HOPE -- THAT
ARE ARE COMMITTEE CAN THINK
ABOUT IF THERE ARE IMPERFECTIONS
HOW DO WE ADDRESS THEM AND HAD
WE ALSO FOCUS ON REPLICATING THE
SUCCESS.
EVERY SINGLE SPACE THAT WE DEAL
WITH EVERY SINGLE POLICY OR
BUDGET COMMITTEE HAS FLAWS AND
IF ALL WE FOCUS ON ARE THE FLAWS.
AND NOT A WAY TO FIX THOSE A
THINK THAT WE ARE IN TROUBLE --
WE HAVE A HISTORY OF THIS
INVESTING IN HIGHER AT THE
MASTERS IT.
WE USED TO FIND THE UC.
AT A MUCH HIGHER LEVEL THAN WE
DO NOW -- AND I THINK THAT WE
ALSO CAN SEE TRENDS OF THAT'S
NOT NECESSARILY HELP TO THE
STUDENTS ARE THE PEOPLE THAT WE
SERVE OR TAXPAYERS.
SO I THINK I WANT TO OFFER THAT
PERSPECTIVE BECAUSE IT GETS.
VERY LOST IN ONLY TALKING ABOUT
OFFICE OF THE PRESIDENT -- AND
NOT SEEN HOW ALL OF OUR
DECISIONS THAT WERE MAKING ALL
OF THE CONVERSATIONS WERE HAVING
TRICKLE DOWN TO EVERY DAY
STUDENTS AND THE WORKERS THERE.
OKAY WELL THIS WAS OUR FIRST
ENGINE ITEM SO WE HAVE A FEW
OTHERS -- TO TO TO GET THROUGH
THEY TO THE UC I I THINK THE
CONCLUSION HERE.
IS -- WE ALL LOVE THE UNIVERSE
CALIFORNIA FOR PERSONAL INTEREST
OR FOR CONSTITUENTS -- OFF FOR
MY COLLEAGUES HERE -- STATE AT
THE UC DID YOU MISTER TO MEDINA.
YOU DID AS WELL.
HI -- I DID NOT -- CERTAINLY MY
FATHER DID MY WIFE DIDN'T PROUD
OF THAT.
YOU SEE -- LEGACY IN OUR FAMILY
AND I THINK IT BOILS DOWN TO ONE
A GREAT UNIVERSE CALIFORNIA
SYSTEM FOR ALL CALIFORNIANS THIS
GENERATION THE NEXT.
BUT WITH THAT BEING SAID.
WE DON'T HAVE UNLIMITED MONEY
AND WE NEED TO BE SMARTER WITH
THE SCARCE RESOURCES WE DO THAT
FOR HIGHER AT AND I THINK THAT'S
WHAT WE'RE ARE TRYING TO TO TO
FOCUS ON EVERY YEAR IN THE
BUDGET PROCESS NOW -- GOVERNOR.
BROWN WAS ABOUT THAT IS FOR THE
PARTNERSHIP AND I ASSUME
GOVERNOR SOME SO FAR HIS IS THE
SAME AND SO THIS IS COMMITTEE IS
GOING TO BE.
VERY MINDFUL THAT AS THAT AS
WELL -- PRUDENT OVERSIGHT AND
I'M NOT AWARE ABOUT THE METRICS
THAT WE MADE YOU DO THAT YOU.
THERE'S A LOT OF REPORTING.
THE MANY THAT GOES TO UNIVERSITY
CALIFORNIA DOESN'T GO TO A
CAMPUS WITHOUT SOME REPORTING
THAT'S INVOLVED -- SO WHETHER
IT'S TRACKING OF STUDENTS IN
TERMS OF MEETING LONG TERM AND
SHORT TERM OBJECTIVES WHETHER
IT'S THE PROFILE OF THE STUDENT
I MEAN I JUST. EIGHTY IT DOESN'T
YOU DON'T JUST GIVE MONEY TO THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA --
OFFICE OF THE PRESIDENT -- OUT
REACH WITHOUT SOMEONE ASKING FOR
SOMETHING IN RETURN SO THAT DATA
DOES EXIST GOSH I I WASN'T AWARE
THE NEW REQUIREMENTS THAT'S WHAT
I WAS ASKING -- WITH THAT LET'S
MOVE ON TO ISSUE NUMBER.
ISSUE NUMBER -- TO THIS IS THE
STUDENT -- SUCCESS.
IT IS YOU THREE I'M SORRY ISSUE
THROUGH.
YES STUDENT SUCCESS -- THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET INCLUDES FORTY
NINE POINT NINE ONGOING AT FORTY
EIGHT FORTY NINE POINT NINE
MILLION ONGOING GENERAL FUND FOR
DEGREE ATTAINMENT INSTANCE X.%
CERTAIN SERVICES PROGRAMS.
THIS WILL ALLOW YOU SEE THE
HIGHER NEED TO FACULTY AND OFFER
SUPPORT SERVICES THAT ENABLE
BETTER LEARNING OUTCOMES AND
IMPROVE TIME TO DEGREE.
THE CITY HAS BROAD DISCRETION TO
USE THESE FUNDS TO ACHIEVE --
THESE PURPOSES THANK YOU OKAY.
THIS COMMITTEE A DISCUSS THIS
PROPOSAL SOMEWHAT DURING THE
HIGHER IT OVERVIEW A FEW MONTHS
AGO.
AND IT'S PART OF THAT DISCUSSION
ASKED THREE QUESTIONS THAT WE
THINK ARE REALLY THE CORE ISSUES
HERE IS REVIEWING THIS PROPOSAL
I'LL GO THROUGH EACH CORE ISSUE
ONE AT A TIME.
THE FIRST QUESTION THAT THE
COMMITTEE ****.
OUT WAS.
IS THERE A CONCERN REGARDING
STUDENT SUCCESS THAT YOU SEE.
IF YOU TURN TO PAGE EIGHT OF
YOUR AGENDA.
OF THAT TABLE ON THE ON THE PAGE
THEIR DISPLAYS THAT USE THE MOST
RECENT ESTIMATES FOR ITS
GRADUATION RATES FOR ITS
FRESHMEN AND TRANSFER STUDENTS.
AND AS YOU CAN SEE.
LOOKING BACK FOR YEARS THANKS
FOR FRESHMEN IT'S OVER SIXTY SIX
OVER 60% -- LOOKING OUT SIX
YEARS THAT GRADUATION GOES IT
RATE GOES UP TO OVER 80%.
I'M LOOKING FOR YOURSELF FOR
TRANSFER STUDENTS -- IT'S ALSO --
OVER -- CLOSE 290%.
THESE RATES ARE AMONG THE HIGH
OR THE OR OR THE HIGHEST AMONG
THE STATE'S THREE PUBLIC HIGHER
EDUCATION SEGMENTS ARE THERE ARE
HIGHER THAN CSU AND HIGHER THAN
COMMUNITY COLLEGES.
AND THE STATE'S RECOGNIZE THAT
HISTORICALLY AND IN PAST YEARS
THE LEGISLATURE HAS PRIORITIZED
FUNDING FOR STUDENT SUCCESS.
AT THE CSU AND COMMUNITY COLLEGE
SYSTEMS AND FOCUSED ITS
ATTENTION THAT YOU SEE ON OTHER
CRITICAL ISSUES THAT THE
UNIVERSITY FACES THINGS LIKE
ENSURING ACCESS FOR RESIDENTS
STUDENTS AND REDUCING OVERALL
COSTS ARE YOU SEE.
THIS APPROACH IS REASONABLE.
THAT'S SAID ONE ISSUE THE
LEGISLATURE MAY WANT TO CONSIDER
AS IT'S REVIEWING THIS PROPOSAL
IS THE DIFFERENT GAPS IN
GRADUATION RATES BETWEEN
DIFFERENT GROUPS OF STUDENTS.
NOW IF YOU LOOK AT AGAIN AT THE
TABLE ON PAGE EIGHT YOU CAN SEE
THAT THERE ARE SOME DIFFERENCES
BETWEEN.
NON TELL STUDENTS THOUGH THOSE
DIFFERENCES OF LARGELY GO AWAY
WHEN SHE LOOKS SIX AND FOUR
YEARS OUT FOR FRESHMEN AND
TRANSFER STUDENTS.
BUT IF YOU TURN THE PAGE TO PAGE.
NINE YOU WILL SEE DIFFERENCES IN
GRADUATION RATES ACROSS THE
DIFFERENT CAMPUSES NOT JUST TO A
LARGE EXTENT REFLECTS THE
DIFFERENT ADMISSION.
RATES AND SELECTIVITY OF THOSE
CAMPUSES.
YOU CAN ALSO SEE.
DIFFERENT GRADUATION RATES BY
RACE AND ETHNICITY LOOKING AT
THE BOTTOM GRAPH ON PAGE.
NINE AND AS YOU CAN SEE THOSE
GAPS HAVE BEEN FAIRLY PERSISTENT
OVER TIME.
THIS IS AN ISSUE THAT'S ALSO
PRESENT AT THE OTHER TWO
SEGMENTS IT'S NOT UNIQUE TO YOU
SEE BUT THE LEGISLATURE OF THE
LEGISLATURE MAY BE CONCERNED
ABOUT -- THIS PERSISTENT
GRADUATION AT A GAP BETWEEN THE
BY BY RACE AND ETHNICITY.
THE SECOND QUESTION THE
COMMITTEE ASKED WAS WELL HOW
WERE YOU SEE SPEND THESE FUNDS
IF IT IF IT WERE APPROPRIATED TO
UNIVERSITY.
WHEN WE REVIEWS REVIEW THIS
PROPOSAL THE UNIVERSITY PROVIDE
A HIGH LEVEL PROVIDED A HIGH
LEVEL NARRATIVE HOW WOULD SPEND
THE FUNDS BUT WHAT OF MORE
DETAILED EXPENDITURE PLANS
LACKING?
NOW I HAVE TO SAY I LOOK THROUGH
THE HANDOUT THAT YOU SEE A
RELEASE AND IF YOU GO TO PAGE.
TEN I I DO SEE AN EXPENDITURE
PLAN I'M LOOKING AT THIS FOR THE
FIRST TIME SO OUR OFFICE WOULD
HAVE TO WORK WITH THE UNIVERSITY.
TO A DRILL DOWN THESE NUMBERS A
LITTLE MORE UNDERSTAND THEM AND
AND PROVIDE A FULLER ASSESSMENT
OF THEM SO I FORTUNATELY I CAN'T
COMMENT AT THIS TIME ON THE
EXPENDITURE PLAN BUT I I DO SEE
IT HERE ON ON THIS PAGE.
THE FINAL QUESTION THE
LEGISLATURE ASKED WAS WELL.
HOW WILL WHAT WHAT WHAT
ACCOUNTABILITY IS IN PLACE HOW
WE TRACK WHETHER OR NOT THE
FUNDING MEETS OUR OBJECTIVES?
THEN WE RECOMMEND THAT THE
LEGISLATURE ADOPT --
ACCOUNTABILITY MEASURES TO
ENSURE THE FUNDS ARE MEETING
OBJECTIVES.
AS YOU'RE THINKING ABOUT WELL
WHAT WITH THESE ACCOUNTABILITY
MEASURES BE WE WOULD NOTE THAT
THE UNIVERSITY HAS DEVELOPED --
A LONG TERM TERM PLAN ASSOCIATED
WITH THESE FUNDS.
THAT -- SAID SCHOOLS TO
ELIMINATE GRADUATION GAPS THAT
EACH CAMPUS AN INCREASE FOR YOUR
GRADUATION RATES -- OVER THE
NEXT SEVERAL YEARS [inaudible]
FIFTEEN YEARS.
I'M WE THINK THAT'S A REASONABLE
PLACE TO TO START IF YOU'RE
THINKING ABOUT ACCOUNTABILITY
MEASURES YOU COULD ALSO CONSIDER
OTHER OPTIONS FOR EXAMPLE YOU
SEE ALREADY REPORTS ON
GRADUATION RATES.
EACH YEAR BROKEN UP BY STATE
CERTAIN STUDENT GROUPS BUT THAT
IS THAT -- ANNUAL REPORTING
DOESN'T INCLUDE GRADUATION RATES
BROKEN OUT BY RACE ETHNICITY.
I MEAN DOESN'T -- SO THAT'S AND
THAT'S AN EXAMPLE WHERE THE
LEGISLATURE COULD -- CHANGE SOME
OF ITS EXISTING REPORTING
REQUIREMENTS TO TO MATCH
WHATEVER BUDGET -- DECISIONS ARE
MADE REGARDING THIS PROPOSAL
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
YOU SEE.
THANK YOU -- WE'RE GRATEFUL THAT
THE GOVERNOR RECOGNIZE STUDENT
SUCCESS AS AN IMPORTANT ISSUE IN
HIS BUDGET INTRODUCTION.
OF WE ARE ASKING THE
SUBCOMMITTEE TO INCREASE THE
STUDENT SUCCESS FUNDING FROM
FORTY NINE POINT NINE MILLION TO
SIXTY MILLION WELL WE'RE GOING
THE OTHER DIRECTION.
BUT CONTINUE.
WE WHAT WE WOULD LIKE YOU TO
INCREASE THAT THAT'S OUR REQUEST --
THE OVERALL GOALS OF OUR STUDENT
SUCCESS -- PROGRAM INCLUDE TO
ACHIEVING 90% OVERALL SIX YOUR
FRESHMAN AND FOR YOUR TRANSFER
GRADUATION RATES. TO CLOSE THE
GRADUATION GAPS FOR PELL GRANT
RECIPIENTS UNDER REPRESENTED
STUDENTS AND FIRST GENERATION
STUDENTS.
AND TO CLOSE THE OVERALL
GRADUATE AND DOCTORAL DEGREE
ATTAINMENT CAPS FOR PELL GRANT
RECIPIENTS UNDER REPRESENTED
STUDENTS.
FIRST GENERATION STUDENTS AND
WOMEN.
AS PART OF THESE GOALS CAMPUSES
IDENTIFIED A NETWORK OF OVER
ARCHING CAMPUS STRATEGY SOME
PROGRAMS TO HELP WITH THE
UNDERGRADUATE DEGREE ATTAINMENT
STRATEGIES.
INCLUDING PRE MATRICULATION
PROGRAMS TEACHING AND LEARNING
CENTERS STUDENT ADVISING
HOLISTIC APPROACHES TO STUDENT
SUCCESS AND INTEGRATING CORACLE
CO CURRICULAR SUPPORT IN THE
CLASSROOM.
WHAT YOU SEE HER ON SLIDE NINE
IS OUR LATEST FOR YOUR
GRADUATION RATES THIS IS FOR
THOSE STUDENTS WHO STARTED AS A
FRESHMAN IN?
TWENTY FOURTEEN ONTHE LEFT YOU
SEE A COMPARISON OF THE FOUR
YEAR GRADUATION RATES BY
STUDENTS WHO RECEIVE PELL GRANTS.
WHICH IS OFTEN VIEWED AS THE
METRIC FOR BEING LOW INCOME.
AND THOSE STUDENTS WHO DO NOT
FORESEE PELL GRANTS AND THERE IS
A GAP OF ELEVEN POINT 7% AND
THAT FOUR YEAR GRADUATION RATE
AND WE WANT TO WORK ON CLOSING
DOT.
ON THE RIGHT YOU SEE THE
FRESHMEN COHORT TWENTY THIRD AND
FALL TWENTY FOURTEEN BROKEN DOWN
BY ETHNICITY.
YOU'LL NOTICE THAT THERE'S ME
THERE REMAIN GAPS AND GRADUATION
RATES BETWEEN THE VARIOUS ETHNIC
GROUPS WITHIN THE UC.
AGENTS WANT TO ADDRESS THIS
PROBLEM AND MAKE CERTAIN THAT
ALL OUR STUDENTS HAVE THE
ASSISTANCE TO HAVE AN EXCELLENT
EDUCATIONAL EXPERIENCE AND
GRADUATED IN A TIMELY MANNER.
GRADUATING FASTER USUALLY MEANS
LESS DEBT THAN THE STUDENTS ARE
TAKING ON THE STUDENT SUCCESS
GOAL IS INTENDED TO REMOVE THE
INSTITUTIONAL BARRIERS THE
TIMELY GRADUATION.
BEEN ON SLIGHT TENNIS DELAY --
MENTIONED AND I APOLOGIZE OF THE
LA -- AND THEY'LL ANALYST AND
SEE THIS PRIOR TO THE HEARING --
YOU SEE IT OUR PLAN FOR HOW WE
INTEND TO SPEND THESE FUNDS AND
DIVIDE THEM BETWEEN THE VARIOUS
TYPES OF CATEGORIES TO THE
CAMPUSES -- AND ON SLIDE ELEVEN
MOVING ON YOU'LL AT THOSE LAST
LINE OF THE SLIDE CONTAINS OUR
STUDENTS SUCCESS POST A HIGHER
WITH THESE FUNDS -- IN NINETEEN
TWENTY WHICH ON SLIDE TEN YOU'LL
SEE THAT WAS THE SIXTEEN MILLION
DOLLAR ITEM -- THESE ADDITIONAL
LETTERING FACULTY WOULD HELP US
ACHIEVE THESE GOALS PARTICULAR
TO FIRST YEAR PROGRAMMING THE
CURRICULUM INNOVATION AND
INTEGRATING CO CURRICULAR
SUPPORT INTO THE CLASSROOM.
THE REMAINDER OF THE FUNDS WILL
BE SPENT ON CAMPUS STRATEGIES --
TO PROVIDE ADDITIONAL STUDENT
SERVICES AND ENSURE THAT
ACADEMICALLY THE STUDENTS STAY
ON TRACK.
ON SLIDE TWELVE I SHOWS SOME
SAMPLING OF PROGRAMS THAT WE
WOULD UNDERTAKE WITH THE SIXTY
MILLION -- AND YOU'LL I INCLUDED
A PROGRAM FOR MOST OF THE CAMPUS
AS YOU CAN SEE WHAT KIND OF
THINGS THE CAMPUSES ARE PLANNING
ON WORKING ON THESE PROGRAMS ARE
ALL CAMPUS SPECIFIC.
INTENDED TO FILL ALL OF THEIR
INDIVIDUAL NEEDS FOR GUIDING
THEIR STUDENTS TO A FASTER
GRADUATION.
AND THE INTENT IS TO PROVIDE
ACADEMIC ADVISORS WITH BETTER
INFORMATION ABOUT WHEN STUDENTS
ARE REST AT RISK OF DROPPING OUT.
AND NOT MAKING PROGRESS ON THEIR
MAJORS PROVIDING THE STUDENTS
WITH A NETWORK OF SUPPORT AND
THEIR ACADEMIC PROGRESS BY
FORMING SMALLER COHORTS WHO TAKE
CLASSES TOGETHER AND PROVIDE
PEER TO PEER SUPPORT AND HIRING
ADDITIONAL ADVISORS.
AND THE SPINAL PLANTS ARE STILL
UNDER DEVELOPMENT NOW.
ON PAGE -- THIRTEEN YOU SEE
INFORMATION AS TO WHY OF WE
THINK.
IT'S NECESSARY TO ADDRESS
STUDENT.
SUCCESS AND FACULTY HIRING.
OF THIS DATA COMES FROM OUR
UNDERGRADUATE EXPERIENCE SURVEY
WHICH IS CONDUCTED EVERY TWO
YEARS.
ON THE LEFT YOU SEE A BAR CHART
OF STUDENT RESPONSES ON WHETHER
OR NOT THEY WOULD STILL AND ROLE
IN THE UC AFTER THEIR EXPERIENCE
ON THE CAMPUS.
WE HAVE SEEN A DROP FROM 33% OF
STUDENTS STRONGLY AGREEING AND
220006218% OF STUDENTS STRONGLY
AGREEING A DECADE LATER IN.
TWENTY SIXTEEN AND WHAT'S BEHIND
THESE NUMBERS WE BELIEVE ARE THE
EVERYDAY EXPERIENCES THAT
STUDENTS HAVE AN OVERCROWDED
CLASSROOMS THE WAIT TIMES TO
SPEAK TO AN ADVISOR.
AND BUILDING CONDITIONS AS
MAINTENANCE FUNDS HAVE BEEN
SCALED BACK.
AND ON THE RIGHT SIDE OF THE
PAGE YOU SEE A MORE TROUBLING
TRENDS -- BACK IN TWO THOUSAND
SIX WE HAD 3% OF STUDENTS
REPORTING THAT THEY COULD NOT
GET INTO THE MAJOR OFF THEIR
FIRST CHOICE AND THAT NUMBER HAD
GROWN 213% OF STUDENTS BY.
TWENTY SIXTEEN AND WHAT'S BEHIND
THAT IS LACK OF FACULTY TO TEACH
COURSES IN THOSE MAJORS -- AND
STUDENTS CAN'T CAN'T GET INTO
THE COURSES.
OUR UNDERGRADUATE STUDENTS ARE
ALSO FEELING LESS CONNECTED TO
THEIR FACULTY WITH A PORT 14%
DROP OVER TEN YEARS AND STUDENTS
WHO FEEL THEY KNOW A FACULTY
MEMBER WELL ENOUGH TO ASK FOR A
LOT OF WRECKED RECOMMENDATION.
THOSE LETTER RECOMMENDATIONS ARE
NECESSARY TO GO INTO GRADUATE
SCHOOL AND AS WE ARE TRYING TO
INCREASE THE NUMBER OF PHD IS
WHO COME FROM UNDERREPRESENTED
MINORITY BACKGROUNDS AND WHO ARE
WOMEN.
IT'S NECESSARY FOR THOSE
STUDENTS TO DEVELOP THOSE
RELATIONSHIPS DURING THEIR
UNDERGRADUATE TIMES SO WE ARE
VERY CONCERNED ABOUT THESE
TRENDS AND WANT.
TO LEVEL THEM OFTEN -- BEGIN TO
REVERSE THEM.
AND THAT CONCLUDES MY
PRESENTATION ON STUDENT SUCCESS
THANK YOU SIR.
THANK YOU -- IN EIGHTY AS YOU
NOTED -- DAILY -- WE TALKED A
LOT ABOUT THIS AT OUR
INFORMATIONAL HEARING.
AND IT IN ESSENCE WE THIS IS AN
ISSUE AS I SAID EARLIER A BIG
ISSUE AT THE CSU SYSTEM AND IN
LARGE PART MOST STUDENTS TO GET
INTO THE UC.
ARE EXTREMELY WELL QUALIFIED.
THEY DO WELL.
THEY GRADUATE IN FOUR YEARS IF
NOT.
THE FORTY SIX UNDERSTAND THAT
SIX MAY NOT BE SIX YEARS BUT
BETWEEN FOUR AND SIX COULD BE
THEY GRADUATED FOUR AND A HALF
YEARS.
SO -- WE DO HAVE SOME ISSUES
THAT SOME OF THE CAMPUSES AND
YOU SEE HERE AT AT MERCED DIDN'T --
TO SOME EXTENT RIVERSIDE -- WHAT
THE AND THE OTHER ISSUES OF
COURSE WITH?
UNDER REPRESENT UNDERREPRESENTED
MINORITY STUDENTS BUT HOW DO YOU
TARGET THAT FOR EXAMPLE AT
BERKELEY WITH THIS FORTY
THOUSAND STUDENTS AND WE HEARD
FROM MR EARLIER.
THE BLACK POPULATION SHE'S.
IN THE BACKS ONE POINT 6% -- AND
SO HOW DO YOU YOU KNOW HAVE YOU
GO AND TARGET THAT IF THAT'S WHO
YOU'RE TRYING TO REACH.
WHEREAS IT'S EASIER AND MASS TO
DO IT FOR EXAMPLE AT MAYBE IT
CAL STATE LA.
WERE YOU YEAR STUDENT POPULATION
IS.
AB 60% UNDER REPRESENTED
MINORITY SO I THINK THOSE ARE --
SOME LOGISTICS ISSUES TOO I KNOW
WE JUST GOT THE PLAN TODAY I
THINK THESE THESE OUTREACH
EFFORTS AND HE STARTED EFFORTS
ARE IMPORTANT -- I THINK IT JUST
COMES DOWN FOR US AND ANOTHER
REQUEST WAS HIGHER.
BUT IF THERE IS NO MORE MONEY
COMES ON A REQUEST IT COMES DOWN
TO US -- BALANCING THIS
PERSISTED ENROLLMENT I MET WITH
ONE OF YOUR CHANCELLOR'S AT THE
NINE UC CAMPUSES.
I ASKED ABOUT THIS HE ASKED HIM
OR HER.
HOLD SAID KIND OF SLIPPED RIGHT
THERE -- ABOUT -- THIS PROPOSAL
THEY DID NOT KNOW TOO MUCH ABOUT
THIS PROPOSAL AND THEY SAID
THEIR GRADUATIONRATE IS GREAT.
IN SEEN ISSUES AND THEY
MENTIONED THEY'D RATHER HAVE
RESOURCES FOR ENROLLMENT.
WHICH I THOUGHT HA.
THAT'S OUR PRIORITY.
SELL -- I THINK THAT THIS.
IF WE HAD UNLIMITED RESOURCES.
WOULD BE WOULD BE GREAT BUT WE
HAVE TO BALANCE -- PRIORITY SO.
HE WILL WILL BE EVALUATING THIS
BASED UPON -- THE PLAN YOU
PRESENTED AND WHAT'S IN THE
FINAL MERRY REVISED AS FAR AS
REVENUES AND AREN'T OUTSTANDING
ISSUES LIKE STUDENT ENROLLMENT
FOR THE QUESTIONS MISTER MARTZ
WHICH YES I TOTALLY WANT -- TO
ECHO -- MISTER SHARE YOUR
COMMENTS ABOUT THE ENROLLMENT
YOU KNOW IT AND AND I WANTED TO
FOLLOW ON MR GALLAGHER'S
COMMENTS EARLIER BUT YOU KNOW WE
WE JUST GOT THROUGH THE THE
LATEST CYCLE OF A ADMISSIONS --
YOU KNOW THEY THEY THEY ARE
CONSTITUENTS THOSE WHO GOT IN
THE UC'S THOSE THAT DON'T AND I
JUST CONTINUE TO HEAR LIKE YOU
KNOW HOW ARE TOP STUDENTS ARE
NOT GETTING INTO.
IN AND TO OUR UC'S IN MAINE.
I GUY I ASKED.
I I WAS JUST CONTACTED BY THE
SUPERINTENDENT OF THE PALACE
EASY.
A SCHOOL DISTRICT AND AND YOU
KNOW HE CLAIMS THAT IT'S NOT
JUST THE BERKELEY IS IN THE U.
C. L. A.'S BUT IT'S ALSO YOU
KNOW ALSO -- YOU KNOW -- YOU SEE
MERCED AND YOU KNOW I SO I ASKED
HIM TO DO TO PROVIDE THAT DATA
BUT NOW I I KNOW THAT -- OVER
THE YEARS I'VE I'VE BEEN HEARING
MORE AND MORE PEOPLE SAYING THAT.
THAT IT'S EASIER TO GET INTO THE
ARIZONA UNIVERSITIES INTO THE
UNIVERSITY OF WASHINGTON OREGON --
IT BIT BUT YOU KNOW AND SO I I
JUST WANT.
TO CONTINUE TO HAMMER CALIFORNIA
RESIDENTS YOU KNOW.
AND MAY WE JUST.
WE JUST NEED TO GET -- THE WE WE
JUST NEED TO KEEP ON HAMMERING
FOR FOR MORE ENROLLMENT FOR
CALIFORNIA RESIDENTS.
THANK YOU MISTER MEDINA.
QUESTION ON THE SLIDE.
NINE ON THE GRADUATE FIGURE.
TWENTY SIX TWENTY SEVEN THE
GRADUATION RATES WHEN ONE OF THE
THINGS I THINK THAT THIS GRAPH
DOESN'T SHOW IS THE DIFFERENCES
ON CAMPUSES AND ON HOW THEY DO --
AND GRADUATION RATES OF FOR
STUDENTS OF COLOR RIGHT OR THE
DEGREE OF DIFFERENCE.
THE DIFFERENT CAMPUSES HAVE
SUCCESS THEY HAVE RIGHT THIS
THESE GRAPHS DON'T SHOW THAT
THESE YES THESE GRAPHS -- LEAD
GROUP ALL THE UC'S TOGETHER SO
THEY DON'T SHOW THE CAMPUS DWELL
OR OR OR THAT FIGURE TWENTY SIX
WERE CHOSE GRADUATION RATES FOR
AND SIX YEAR RATES.
IT DOESN'T HAVE AN BROKE BROKEN
DOWN -- IN OTHER WORDS YOU'RE
NOT SHOWING IN THESE GRAPHS
WHICH CAMPUSES DO BETTER.
OF WITH A GRADUATION RATES HELLO
ON A MINORITY STUDENTS STUDENTS
OF COLOR.
UP SHOWN BY CAMPUS BECAUSE I
KNOW THERE IS A DIFFERENCE FOR
SOME FROM SOME CAMPUSES TO OTHER
CAMPUSES.
ON GRADUATION RATES ON STUDENTS
OF COLOR AND THE HOW SOME
CAMPUSES DO BETTER THAN OTHERS.
IN CLOSING THAT GAP THAT I THINK
THAT YOU'RE ALSO TALKING ABOUT
WANTING TO CLOSE YES THAT'S
CORRECT SIR RIGHT WITH THESE
THESE GRAPHS DON'T SHOW THAT I
THINK THOSE.
THAT INFORMATION WOULD BE VERY
GOOD TO HAVE FOR FOR THIS
COMMITTEE TO SEE WHAT CAMPUSES.
DO A BETTER JOB.
ON THE GRADUATION RATES -- AMONG
STUDENTS OF COLOR.
AND WHAT CAMPUSES HAVE CLOSE
THAT GAP OF BETWEEN -- A
STUDENTS TO COLORS AND AND AND
OTHER STUDENTS.
ARE I THINK THAT INFORMATION
WOULD BE GOOD FOR THIS COMMITTEE
YES I WILL I WILL GET THAT TO
THE COMMITTEE CONSULTANT AND ALL
THE MEMBERS OF THIS COMMITTEE
AND I AND I SAY THAT ALSO
BECAUSE I THINK THAT IT VARIES
VERY MUCH FROM CAMPUS TO CAMPUS
[inaudible]
OKAY.
THANK YOU WELL YES THIS MESSAGE
QUESTION -- SO UGH -- THE
UNIVERSITY CALIFORNIA YOU YOU
HAVE A YOU KNOW -- CREATIVELY
WORKED INTO THE STUDENT SUCCESS
A REQUEST MORE FACULTY HERE AND
AND AND AND I PLOW YOUR YOUR
CREATIVITY HERE BUT HOW HOW ARE
YOU -- PROPOSING TO INCREASE
FACULTY AT HOW HOW WOULD YOU
PROPOSE.
INCREASE FACULTY DIVERSITY -- IT
GIVEN THAT WE OPERATE UNDER
PROPOSITION TWO ONE NINE
RESTRICTIONS -- WE HAVE LEARNED
A LOT FROM OUR THREE PILOT
PROJECTS THE LEGISLATURE VERY
GENEROUSLY GIVE US TWO MILLION
DOLLARS A YEAR FOR THREE YEARS.
TO LOOK AT HOW WE COULD RECRUIT
FROM A MORE DIVERSE POOL OF
CANDIDATES -- WE LEARNED A LOT --
INCLUDING WHERE TO ADVERTISE --
THE GRADUATE STUDENTS -- TO LET
THEM KNOW.
IS BEING ADVERTISED -- BUT ALSO
TO MAKE THE CAMPUS CLIMATE MORE
FRIENDLY WHEN CANDIDATES CAME TO
TO CAMPUS THEY MAKE WITH THE
DEAN AND SOMETIMES THE FINAL CAN
IT'S WITH WITH WITH THE
CHANCELLOR. TO LET THEM KNOW
THAT THEY WERE VALUED OF WE
FOUND THAT MADE A BIG DIFFERENCE
WE ALSO -- REQUESTED ALL THE
CANDIDATES TO INCLUDE A
DIVERSITY STATEMENT SO DIVERSITY
DOESN'T JUST MEAN THAT DIVERSITY
OF THE INDIVIDUAL CANDIDATES IT
TO HIRE GRADUATE STUDENTS FROM
ALL BACKGROUNDS INTO THEIR LAB
AND WORK WITH -- THEIR
COLLEAGUES FROM DIFFERENT
BACKGROUNDS -- ARE THEY LOOKING
TO EXPAND THEIR FIELD AND WORK --
IN OUR IN ACROSS -- IT IS IN A
WORK WITH OTHER DISCIPLINES IN
THEIR RESEARCH AS WELL -- ARE
THEY WILLING TO MENTOR STUDENTS
FROM.
AREAS DIFFERENT KINDS OF
BACKGROUNDS AND FOSTERED THEM
INTO THAT FIELD.
SO WE KNOW REQUEST OF THE
FACULTY CANDIDATES TO FILL OUT
THESE DIVERSITY STATEMENTS -- TO
MAKE CERTAIN THAT THEY REALLY --
EMBRACE AN INCLUSIVE CAMPUS
ENVIRONMENT.
SO THAT WOULD THAT WE HAVE FOUND
IS MAKING A DIFFERENCE.
THANK YOU.
OKAY THANK YOU ALL THIS ISSUE
OPEN.
NEXT ISSUE DEGREE COMPLETION.
LATE TWO YEAR YOU SEE EXTENSION
PROGRAMS.
YES THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET
PROVIDES THE UC WITH FIFTEEN
MILLION DOLLARS ONE TIME GENERAL
FUND TO EXPAND AND PILOT DEGREE
COMPLETION PROGRAMS AND EXPAND
CERTIFICATE PROGRAMS THAT
EXTENSION CENTERS.
THOUSANDS OF CALIFORNIANS HAVE
SOME COLLEGE BUT NO DEGREE IN
THE ADMINISTRATION'S GOAL.
IS TO CONNECT WITH THE STUDENTS
PROVIDE ADDITIONAL EDUCATION SO
THEY CAN RECEIVE A DEGREE
CERTIFICATE OR OTHER CREDENTIAL
TO THRIVE ACCESS ADDITIONAL
OPPORTUNITIES AND ACHIEVE
GREATER SUCCESS THANK YOU.
OKAY THANK YOU LA A ALWAYS THREE
CONCERNS THAT WE HAD WITH THIS
PROPOSAL.
THE FIRST ALL THIS PROPOSAL
LACKS A LOT OF BASIC INFORMATION
THAT WOULD ALLOW THE LEGISLATURE
TO ASSESS WHETHER THE PROPOSAL'S
MEETING ITS OBJECTIVES AND ALSO
TO ASSESS WHETHER THEY PROPOSE
LEVEL OF FUNDING IS JUSTIFIED.
SO FOR EXAMPLE THE GOVERNOR HAS
PROVIDED A FEW DIFFERENT WAYS
THAT FOR POSSIBILITIES THAT THE
FUNDS WOULD BE SPENT.
THE KEY FOCUS SEEMS TO BE DEGREE
COMPLETION PROGRAMS THOUGH THE
GOVERNOR ALSO WITH OTHER OPTIONS
SUCH AS MORE CERTIFICATE
PROGRAMS.
AND ALSO STUDENT OUTREACH AND
EACH OF THESE ACTIVITIES HAVE
SOMEWHAT DIFFERENT GOALS AND
OBJECTIVES N MIND.
AND AGAIN WITHOUT A MORE
DETAILED EXPENDITURE PLAN IT'S
DIFFICULT TO ASSESS WHETHER THE
FIFTEEN MILLION IS IS ALIGNED
WITH THE COST OF WHAT'S WHAT THE
GOVERNOR'S TRYING TO ACHIEVE
HERE.
AND I I CHECKED THROUGH THE
POWER POINT AT YOU SEE I DON'T
SEE ANY -- UNDER YOUR PLAN SO I
DID SEE.
THANK YOU -- SO ON THE SO THE
SECOND CONCERN WE HAVE IS EVEN
EVEN WHERE THE LEDGE WHERE THE
LEGISLATURE TO BE HAVE A BETTER
SENSE OF EXACTLY HOW THE FUNDS
WOULD GET SPENT -- THAT ALIGNS
IT WITH ITS OBJECTIVES.
WE DON'T THINK THE
ADMINISTRATION'S MADE A CASE YET
THAT'S STATE FUNDING IS NEEDED
TO ACCOMPLISH ITS OBJECTIVE --
YOU SEE EXTENSION CENTERS ARE
SELF SUPPORTING ENTERPRISES AND
AND PART OF THEIR MISSION.
IS [inaudible]
TO OF OF MAINTAIN RESERVES THAT
IT THAT THE USE TO FIND THE
PLANNING AND DEVELOPMENT OF NEW
PROGRAMS THAT ARE -- HAVE A
POTENTIAL OF A MARKETABILITY AND
AND CAN ATTRACT A SUFFICIENT
NUMBER OF STUDENTS TO COVER
COSTS.
THIRD AS STAFF IN YOUR GENDER
NOTED -- CSU ALREADY HAS ABOUT
YOUR DEGREE COMPLETION PROGRAMS%
AND THIS RAISES FURTHER
QUESTIONS FOR EXAMPLE WELL THE
UC A PROGRAM BE SOMEWHAT
DUPLICATIVE WITH THE CSU PROGRAM
WOULD -- COVER AN ADDITIONAL
NEED THAT CSU WASN'T COVERING.
AND WHAT WITH THE ADVANTAGE BE
OF SAY EXPANDING THE EXISTING
CSU PROGRAMS VERSES YOU SEE
VERSUS CREATING NEW PROGRAMS
THAT YOU SEE.
GIVEN THESE QUESTIONS WE
RECOMMEND YOU REJECT THIS
PROPOSAL IN THIS YEAR.
AND ALLOW THE MINISTRATIONS COME
BACK NEXT YEAR WITH A MORE
DEVELOPED PLAN.
OKAY THANK YOU YOU SEE.
THANK YOU -- WE'RE VERY PLEASED
THAT THE GOVERNOR HAS RECOGNIZED
THAT THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA'S OF ROLAND DEGREE
COMPLETION FOR STUDENTS WHO LEFT
WITHOUT DEGREES.
WE REQUEST THAT THE COMMITTEE
APPROVED THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET
FIFTEEN MILLION ONE TIME TO
ADDRESS THE UC DEGREE COMPLETION
EFFORTS.
SINCE NINETEEN NINETY NINE OVER.
SIXTY EIGHT THOUSAND STUDENTS
HAVE LEFT THE UC WITHOUT A
DEGREE.
ONLY ABOUT A FOURTH OF THE
STUDENTS GO TO ANOTHER
INSTITUTION TO COMPLETE A DEGREE
THAT MEANS THERE'S A LOT OF
STUDENTS OUT THERE WHO NEVER
COMPLETED A DEGREE.
THERE IS AN OPPORTUNITY TO HEAR
TO HELP THESE FORMER STUDENTS
COMPLETE THEIR DEGREES AND BEGIN
EARNING HIGHER SALARIES.
ON SLIDE -- FIFTEEN I DISCUSS A
LITTLE BIT ABOUT WHO ARE THE
STUDENTS WHO LEAVE WITHOUT
DEGREES -- AND IS PERHAPS
SURPRISINGLY YOU SEE THAT ARE
ABOUT A THIRD OF THEM.
LEAVE WITH HAVING COMPLETED ONE
HUNDRED UNITS OR MORE.
OF THE STUDENTS REPRESENTS A
VERY LOW HANGING FRUIT TO BRING
BACK TO A FOR DEGREE COMPLETION
BECAUSE MOST AGREES ARE ABOUT
HUNDRED AND TWENTY UNITS.
SO WE COULD BRING THEM BACK AND
THEY COULD COMPLETE THEIR
DEGREES RELATIVELY QUICKLY --
THE FUNDING WOULD BE USED FOR
OUTREACH TO FORMER UC STUDENTS
HAVE NOT WHO HAVE NOT ATTAINED A
DEGREE -- FOR HIGH TOUCH STUDENT
ACADEMIC SUPPORT AND ADVISING TO
ENSURE COMPLETION FINANCIAL AID
TO NEEDY STUDENTS TO PAY FOR YOU
SEE EXTENSION COURSES.
AND OTHER PROGRAMS SUPPORT AT
THE CAMPUS AS A MORE DETAILED OF
PLAN IS UNDER DEVELOPMENT AND
WILL BE SHARED WITH THE
COMMITTEE LATER.
THANK YOU.
I WAS THE IS THINKING ABOUT THIS --
BECAUSE OBVIOUSLY WE NEED MORE
INDIVIDUALS WITH WITH COLLEGE
DEGREES [inaudible]
AND INDIVIDUALS IN THE WORKFORCE
MAY HAVE A GREAT JOB AND LEFT
CALLS.
FOR A REASON THAT THEY NEED TO
GRAY THEY ALREADY HAD A JOB YOUR
AT SPEAKER THIS ASSEMBLY.
JOHN A PET S. MONEY REGIONS
NEVER GOT HIS DEGREE.
HE SAID YOU KNOW WHAT I GOT A
GOOD JOB LABOR ORGANIZER HE
BECAME ASSEMBLY MEMBER.
AND BECOME A SPEAKER AND I WAS I
THINK KINDA.
THE BOSS OF YOUR BUS.
AND HE DIDN'T SEE A NEED TO GO
BACK. TO GET HIS DEGREE.
SO HOW MANY PEOPLE OUT ARE OUT
THERE WHO.
HAVE THEIR I GUESS THIS BEGS THE
QUESTION IS IS IT IS IT A
SOLUTION LOOKING FOR PROBLEMER
HOW HE'S INDIVIDUALS.
IF THEY GOT THEIR DEGREE ALL OF
A SUDDEN THEY BE.
HUGE BENEFIT TO OUR ECONOMY
THERE'S A THERE'S A HUGE NEED TO
GET YOUNGER PEOPLE INTO.
THE PIPELINE TO GET A COLLEGE
DEGREE SO HOW MUCH.
ANALYSIS DO WE HAVE ON ON ON ON
THAT HYPOTHETICAL THEY GAVE YOU
I I DO NOT HAVE -- AN ANALYSIS
OF HOME WHAT THE INCOME LEVEL OF
THESE INDIVIDUALS AS WHO HAVE
LEFT IN INCOME LEVEL BUT ARE
THEY GAINFULLY EMPLOYED ARE THEY
IS NOT HAVING A DEGREE.
LIMITING THEIR CAREER OPTIONS.
FOR FOR MOST INDIVIDUALS IT
WOULD LIMIT THEIR CAREER OPTIONS
NOT EVERYBODY IS A JOHN PARIAHS
OR A STEVE JOBS -- MOST
INDIVIDUALS DO NEED -- HIGHER
EDUCATION IN ORDER TO HAVE IN A
CAREER TRACK.
THAT WOULD -- PAY THEM BETTER
THAN NOT HAVING A HIGHER DEGREE
OF SOME KIND.
SO -- BUT I DON'T HAVE THE
ANALYSIS OF HOW MANY OF THESE
INDIVIDUALS -- ARE WHAT LEVEL OF
EMPLOYMENT ARE CURRENTLY OUT
OKAY.
AND LIKE THIS REQUEST IS FOR FOR
ONE TIME. ONE TIME MENTOR AVENUE
AND THEN BY GOING.
BY GOING BACK TO THE EXTENSION
YOU DON'T NECESSARILY GET YOUR
DEGREE PER SE RIGHT.
YOU CAN TAKE THE COURSES THROUGH
THE EXTENSION THAN THE THAN
THOSE COURSES WOULD BE
TRANSFERRED TO THE CAMPUS STUFF
WOULD BANG PRINTED A GREAT
THERE'S A LITTLE BIT OF A
HANDING OFF PROCESS THAT WOULD
OCCUR.
OKAY.
STRATEGY I AND I WOULD AGREE IT
SEEMS LIKE IT'S A SOLUTION IN
SEARCH OF A PROBLEM I I KNOW SO
MANY KIDS THAT WOULD.
DIE FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
ATTEND THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA.
YOU KNOW AND I THINK WE SHOULD
FOCUS ON THEM FIRST CALIFORNIA
KIDS.
THANK YOU OR PROVIDE FIFTEEN
MILLION DOLLARS WORTH OF MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICES TO HELP THE
STUDENTS GET THEIR DEGREE.
OKAY HOLD THIS ISSUE OPEN.
MISTER CHAIR. FOR THIS NEXT ITEM
CAN I INVITE MY COLLEAGUES GROUP
IN KANETO CO DIRECTOR OF THE
BASIC NEEDS INITIAL AT THE TABLE.
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET INCLUDES
FIFTEEN MILLION DOLLARS ON
GROWING GENERAL FUND TO ADDRESS
STUDENT HUNGER AND HOMELESSNESS --
ALTHOUGH UC'S PROPOSAL CALL FOR
FINANCIAL AID THE
ADMINISTRATION'S PROPOSALS
BROADER -- THE BUDGET ALLOWS THE
USE OF THESE FUNDS TO SUPPORT
THE EXISTING INFRASTRUCTURE FOOD
PANTRIES -- CAL FRESH ENROLLMENT
SUPPORT MEAL SHARING PROGRAMS
AND OTHER SIMILAR INFRASTRUCTURE
CREATED THROUGH THE ON HUNGER
FREE CAMPUS INITIATIVE -- AS
WELL AS EFFORTS TO A HOUSE
HOMELESS STUDENTS AND HOUSING
SECURE STUDENTS.
WITH FINANCIAL AID AS AS A
POSSIBILITY BUT NOT THE THE ONLY
PIECE OF THIS OF THIS MUCH
LARGER PLAN THANK YOU
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
WE HAVE THREE ISSUES FOR THE
LEGISLATURE TO CONSIDER AS IT'S
REVIEWING THIS PROPOSAL.
THE FIRST ISSUE TO CONSIDER IS
THE LEGISLATURE HAS BEEN OUT
SOMEWHAT -- TO DECIDE WHETHER
FUNDING FIND MORE FINANCIAL AID
FOR FOOD AND HOUSING INITIATIVES --
WOULD THAT SOLVE THE ISSUE AND
IT'S SOMETHING THAT THE REGENTS
HAVE BEEN GRAPPLING WITH.
OUR CONCERN HERE IS THAT.
UNDERSTOOD THE UNDERLYING CAUSES --
BEHIND WHY STUDENTS.
DON'T APPEAR TO HAVE ENOUGH
RESOURCES -- TO PURCHASING OF
FOOD OR FACING FOOD AND SECURITY --
ARE NOT ENTIRELY WELL UNDERSTOOD
THE UNIVERSITY HAS A
COMPREHENSIVE FINANCIAL AID
PROGRAMS THAT.
CONSIDERS THE COST OF ATTENDANCE
AND MAKING FINANCIALLY DECISIONS
AND SO THERE'S SOME QUESTION
HERE ABOUT WHAT ISN'T WORKING IN
TERMS OF THAT FINANCIALLY
PROGRAM.
ARE WE MAKING ASSUMPTIONS ABOUT --
HOW MUCH STUDENTS WORK AND
BORROW AND HOW MUCH FAMILIES
CONTRIBUTE TO COSTS?
ARE WE MISS MEASURING WHAT THE
COST OF ATTENDANCE IS A REASONS
QUESTIONS LIKE THAT.
AND PRESUMABLY THE UNDERLYING
CAUSES BEHIND -- FOOD AND
SECURITY WOULD DETERMINE WHICH
APPROACH WOULD BE MOST TARGETED
AND MOST EFFECTIVE IN DEALING
WITH THE ISSUE SO FOR EXAMPLE IF
THE FUNDAMENTAL ISSUES THAT
STUDENTS JUST DON'T HAVE ENOUGH
RESOURCES THROUGHOUT THE YEAR TO
TO COVER FOOD COSTS.
LIKELY THE MOST EFFECTIVE WAY TO
ADDRESS THAT WOULD BE TO PROVIDE
THE STUDENTS MORE MONEY.
TYPICALLY WE DO THAT THROUGH
FINANCIAL AID -- SOMETIMES WE
ALSO DO THAT THE PUBLIC
ASSISTANCE IN THE CASE OF A
COLLEGE STUDENT.
ALTERNATIVELY A STUDENTS FACED A
FINANCIAL EMERGENCY IN THEM IN
THE MIDDLE OF THE YEAR SAY OFF A
FAMILY MEMBER LOSES A JOB OR
THERE'S SOME SORT OF A HEALTH
EMERGENCY THAT COMES UP THAT
INCREASES THEIR COSTS.
WILL FINANCIALLY PROGRAM MIGHT
NOT BE RESPONSIVE ENOUGH TO
ADDRESS THE STUDENTS AND THAT'S
WHERE SOMETHING MAYBE LIKE A
FOOD BANK FOR EXAMPLE COULD.
ADDRESS OUR MORE IMMEDIATE NEEDS
WHAT A FURTHER UNDERSTANDING.
WHAT'S GOING ON HERE IT IT'S
DIFFICULT TO SAY WHETHER
INCREASING FINANCIAL AID
INCREASING -- ON CAMPUS FOOD
INITIATIVES WHICH OF THOSE WOULD
BE MOST EFFECTIVE.
THE SECOND ISSUE FOR THE
LEGISLATURE CONSIDER IS THAT.
THE LEGISLATURE STILL
UNDERSTANDING OF THE VARIOUS
WAYS THE PUBLIC ASSISTANCE
PROGRAMS INTERACT WITH COLLEGE
STUDENTS -- IT APPEARS THAT
THERE ARE POTENTIALLY AS A LARGE
NUMBER OF COLLEGE STUDENTS THAT
YOU SEE WHO COULD QUALIFY FOR
FOOD BENEFITS.
YOU SEE REPORTS FOR EXAMPLE THAT
AND WITHIN THE FIRST SIX MONTHS
OF TWENTY EIGHTEEN AND ROLLED
OVER TEN THOUSAND STUDENTS ON
THE CAL FRESH THAT SUGGESTS
THERE THERE COULD HAVE BEEN A
LARGE POOL OF STUDENTS THAT WE
WERE THAT -- QUALIFIED FOR
CALIFORNIA MEAN ON AVERAGE BEEN
RECEIVING THEM FOR WE DON'T HAVE
GOOD COMPREHENSIVE DATA ON HOW
MANY STUDENTS MIGHT QUALIFY FOR
CAL FRESH BENEFITS.
THE THIRD ISSUE FOR THE
LEGISLATURE TO CONSIDER.
IS ONE OF A KIND OF AN EQUITY
ISSUE BETWEEN THE THREE SEGMENTS
AND I THIS COMMITTEE HAS
DISCUSSED THE SOMEONE IN THE
PAST -- CURRENTLY THE STATE
PROVIDES THE MOST AMOUNT OF
FUNDING FOR LIVING COSTS TO YOU
SEE STUDENTS PROVIDES LESS
FUNDING FOR LIVING COSTS TO
STUDENTS AT CSU AND COMMUNITY
COLLEGES.
AND THE GOVERNOR IS PROPOSING A
ONGOING FUNDING AT YOU SEE ONLY
SO THAT TO SOME EXTENT THIS
PROPOSAL FURTHER EXACERBATES
THAT IN EQUITY.
GIVEN THESE ISSUES WE HAVE A
NUMBER OF RECOMMENDATIONS ON OF
THE LEGISLATURE TO FURTHER STUDY
THESE ISSUES FURTHER STUDY THE
UNDERLYING CAUSES FURTHER STUDY
HOW PUBLIC ASSISTANCE PROGRAMS
WORK AND GET SOME ADDITIONAL
INFORMATION.
NOW OF THE SUBCOMMITTEE HAS TO
DECIDE HOW TO APPROPRIATE
FUNDING IN TWENTY NINETEEN
TWENTY AND FURTHER STUDYING THE
ISSUE KIND OF DELAYS OF THE SOME
ANSWERS THERE THAT ARE CRITICAL
FOR THE LEGISLATURE.
SO IN THE INTERIM ONE APPROACH
LEGISLATURE COULD TAKE IS TO
CONTINUE TO PROVIDE A ONE TIME
FUNDING TO CONTINUE TO SUSTAIN
THESE PROGRAMS -- FOR SO FOR
EXAMPLE THE STATE PROVIDED A ONE
AND A HALF MILLION DOLLARS IN
ONE TIME FUNDING FOR TWO FOR
THESE PROGRAMS AND TWENTY
EIGHTEEN NINETEEN SO THAT GIVES
YOU SOME CONTEXT FOR HOW MUCH
FUNDING HAS BEEN PROVIDED IN
PREVIOUS YEARS [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU THANK YOU SEE YOU --
WE'RE GRATEFUL THAT THE
SUBCOMMITTEE HAS RECOGNIZED THE
IMPORTANCE OF STUDENT BASIC
NEEDS ISSUES IN PRIOR YEARS SOME
PROVIDED YOU SEE WITH ONE TIME
FUNDS TO BEGIN ADDRESSING THESE
ISSUES.
AND YOU'LL SEE ON SLIDE SIXTEEN
LISTED SOME OF THE FUNDS YOU
PROVIDED TO US IN THE PAST WE'RE
ALSO VERY GRATEFUL THAT THE
GOVERNOR HAS RECOGNIZED THE
STUDENT EXPERIENCE.
GOES BEYOND THE CLASSROOM AND
STUDENTS DESERVE SAFE PLACES TO
LIVE AND FREEDOM FROM HUNGER.
WE'RE ASKS THAT YOU APPROVE THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET A FIFTEEN
MILLION DOLLARS IN ONGOING
FUNDING FOR YOU SEE TO ADDRESS
THE STUDENT BASIC NEEDS ISSUES.
OF RUBEN WILL NOW DISCUSS SOME
OF THE ACTIONS THAT THE
UNIVERSITY HAS ALREADY TAKEN AND
BOTH WERE PROPOSING TO DO WITH
THESE FUNDS THANK YOU FOR OPEN
ASSAM.
OUR GUYS SAY THANK YOU ALL IT'S
MADE DAYS MENTAL HEALTH DAY IT'S
NATIONAL NICE AND NATIONAL
COLLEGE SIGNING DAY I JUST CAME
FROM THE BIG GIVEN THAT WE
HOSTED AT BERKELEY I WAS THE MC
THERE AND THEN I JUST BOOKED IT
OVER HERE.
AND WE'RE STILL HERE WITH YOU
ALSO THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR ALL
YOUR HARD WORK BUT IT WAS UCLA
THEY GOT MACHEL ABIDES YOU KNOW
THAT'S THAT INTERNAL
CONVERSATION WE GOT GOING ON
THEY GOT MICHELLE OBAMA THEY GOT
JOHN LEGEND THEY GOT LIKE NBA
STARS IN A FELLOW STARS.
AND THEN OUR POOR BERKELEY
YOU'VE GOT ME AS THE M. C. SO.
THAT'S NEVER REALLY AND NOT AT
ALL WHEN WE TALK ABOUT IN AN
EQUITABLE EXPERIENCE THAT'S
DIFFERENT SO THAT WE NEED TO
TALK ABOUT RIGHT THERE -- BUT IT
WAS SO BEAUTIFUL TO BE THERE
WITH THEM -- STUDENTS THAT WERE
GOT THAT ARE GOING TO TECHNICAL
SCHOOL COMMUNITY COLLEGE CSU YOU
SEE ALL IN ONE SPACE AND ALL
BEING CELEBRATED BECAUSE THEY'RE
FURTHERING THEIR EDUCATION INTO
COLLEGE AND IT WAS REALLY
POWERFUL TO BE THERE WITH THEM.
SO THANK YOU ALL SO MUCH FOR
STILL BEING HERE WITH US SO I'M
GONNA GIVE YOU ALL I'M OFFERINGS.
BECAUSE I'VE BEEN IN THIS
COMMITTEE WITH YOU KNOW FOR THE
LAST THREE YEARS AND LAST YEAR
THERE WERE SOME VERY SPECIFIC
QUESTIONS THAT YOU ALL ASK THAT
YOU WANTED US TO DELIVER TODAY.
AND IN THESE CONVERSATIONS AS
YOU PREPARE TO APPROVE THE
BUDGETS I WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT
BRING THOSE TO YOU ALL.
SO YOU ASK FOR YOU SEE TO
IMPROVE ITS DATA ON STUDENT FOOD
SECURITY AND HOMELESSNESS.
AS OF TODAY THE UC HAVE THE
LARGEST DATA SAID ON COLLEGE
STUDENT FOOD SECURITY AND
HOMELESSNESS ARE UC SYSTEM MY
UNDERGRADUATE EXPERIENCE SURREY
NOW INCLUDES OUR BASIC NEEDS
INSTRUMENT AND IT'S PUBLICLY
AVAILABLE.
ARE YOU SEE COST OF ATTENDANCE
STUDY HAS AN UPDATED INSTRUMENT
TO BETTER CAPTURE THE COST OF
BASIC NEEDS TO INFORM SYSTEM
MIGHT IN CAMPUS SPECIFIC STUDENT
FINANCIAL AID PACKAGING ALSO
PUBLICLY AVAILABLE.
OUR STUDIES AND RECENT
PUBLICATION SHOW THEIR
RELATIONSHIP BETWEEN BASIC NEEDS
CHALLENGES ACADEMIC PERFORMANCE
MENTAL HEALTH AND TIME TO DEGREE
ONE OF THIS YEAR'S MAJOR
MILESTONES FOR YOU SEE BASIC
NEEDS RESEARCH AND EVALUATION
EFFORTS WAS A CONFIRMATION OF
DOCTORS TO SIGN A MARTINEZ AS
APPOINTMENT.
AT UC SAN FRANCISCO AND HER
ACCEPTANCE AS THE UC SYSTEM MY
BASIC NEEDS RESEARCH AND
EVALUATION LEAD.
SHE'S OFF TO A STRONG START WITH
TWO MAJOR PROJECTS LEADING THE
CREATION OF A VALIDATED
INSTRUMENT TO IDENTIFY HOUSING
AND SECURITY AND HOMELESSNESS
RATES.
AND THE SECOND LEADING THE
CREATION AND IMPLEMENTATION OF
AN IRB APPROVED EVALUATION
INSTRUMENT FOR A BASIC NEEDS
INTERVENTIONS.
THIS WAS THE A COMP THIS WAS ALL
ACCOMPLISHED THANKS TO THE
FUNDING THAT WE RECEIVED THAT
YOU ARE PUSH FOR IT LAST YEAR --
THE SECOND IS LAST YEAR YOU ARE
REQUESTED THAT WE GENERATE AND
ON DUPLICATED COUNT OF STUDENTS
THAT EXPERIENCED FOOD INSECURITY
AND OR HOMELESSNESS SO IN
PARTNERSHIP WITH YOU SEE A PIECE
AS ADDITIONAL RESEARCH.
AND ACADEMIC PLANNING TEAM WERE
HAPPY TO CONFIRM THAT WE HAVE
COMPLETED THIS REQUEST THE DATA
SAID FROM DECEMBER TWENTY
SEVENTEENS UC FOOD AND HOUSING
SECURITY STUDY WHICH IS AGAIN
THE STUDY REFERENCE AS THE
LARGEST TO DATE.
WE IDENTIFIED A HUNDRED AND
TWENTY THOUSAND FIVE HUNDRED AND
THIRTY NINE ON DUPLICATED
STUDENTS WHEN I KNOW HOW MANY
STUDENTS ARE EXPERIENCING BASIC
NEEDS CHALLENGES AND THE
PERCENTAGE.
OF TOTAL CAMPUS POPULATION I
KNOW THAT MAY -- SOME MEMBER
MEDINA YOU ASKED EARLIER WHAT WE
KNOW ABOUT THE INDIVIDUAL
CAMPUSES AND WHAT'S GOING ON IN
TERMS OF WHO'S HAVING A BETTER
EXPERIENCE SUPPORTING STUDENTS I
WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT I OFFERED
THAT DATA FOR YOU IN TERMS OF
BASIC NEEDS.
NOW WE KNOW THAT 35% OF THE
TOTAL POPULATION I YOU SEE
BERKELEY IS EXPERIENCING A BASIC
NEEDS CHALLENGE 40% OF UC DAVIS
41% AT IRVINE 31% AT LA 50% OF
OF MERCED. 45% OF RIVERSIDE --
737% OF SAN DIEGO 28% OF SAN
FRANCISCO 44% OF SANTA BARBARA
AND 43% OF SANTA CRUZ SO WHEN
YOU ARE ASKED US HOW MANY
STUDENTS ARE STRUGGLING ON EACH
ONE OF THOSE CAMPUSES THOSE ARE
THE RATES AND IT'S EXCITED.
TO PROVIDE THAT INFORMATION TO
YOU ALL.
NOW WHAT ARE WE DOING ABOUT IT A
LOT OF CONVERSATIONS HAPPEN
ABOUT ARE WE JUST GIVING
STUDENTS -- FOOD ARE WE JUST
GIVING THE MONEY TO PAY FOR RENT
AND ACTUALLY A LOT MORE ROBUST
OF THAT BECAUSE OF THE SAME
FEEDBACK THAT WE'VE GOTTEN.
FROM STATE LEADERSHIP FROM
FACULTY FROM DEPARTMENT OF
SOCIAL SERVICES AND FROM THE
STUDENTS THEMSELVES THAT ASKED
THIS IS HOW WE WANT TO BE SERVE
AND WE TRY TO CREATE A MODEL ON
THAT.
SO WE ESTABLISH THAT TEN
CAMPUSES HAVE ACTING BASIC NEEDS
COMMITTEES THAT INCLUDE
UNDERGRADUATE GRADUATE STUDENTS
STAFF FACULTY ADMINISTRATORS AND
COMMUNITY SUBJECT MATTER EXPERTS
AND OR SERVICE PROVIDERS WE
WANTED TO MAKE SURE THAT
EVERYBODY WAS AT THE TABLE.
THE CULTURES OF THESE COMMITTEES
FORMED THE SYSTEM WIDE BASIC
NEEDS COMMITTEE THAT IS ACTIVELY
INVOLVED WITH SYSTEM MIGHT
CONVERSATIONS SEGMENTS SOME OF
YOU ALL SAW -- COLLEEN AND
DENISE EARLIER TODAY WE'RE
WORKING WITH THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGE AND SEE IS YOU TO
STRATEGIZE HOW DO WE DO COUNTY
STRATEGIES AND STATE STRATEGIES
TOGETHER.
AN ARMADA INCLUDES RESEARCH AND
EVALUATION CAMPUS PREVENTION
STRATEGY SUSTAINABILITY
STRATEGIES AND ADVOCACY
STRATEGIES THIS MODEL ALLOWS US
TO ADDRESS THE MICRO WHICH IS
THE STUDENT NEED TO THE MACRO
WHICH IS THE POLICIES AND
SYSTEMS AREAS. TO MOVE US TOWARD
STUDENT ECONOMIC FOOD AND
HOUSING JUSTICE.
THE THIRD AREA THAT YOU WANTED
US TO DISCUSS WAS A RESPONSE TO
THE ON GOING FUNDING.
AFTER FOUR YEARS OF OPERATION
LIES IN ARE YOU SEE BASIC NEEDS
MODEL CAMPUSES IN OUR SYSTEM
MIGHT COMMITTEES ARE READY FOR
ON GOING FINDING.
THE OVERWHELMING MAJORITY OF
FUNDING FOR OUR YOU SEE BASIC
NEEDS EFFORTS HAVE BEEN ONE YEAR
ALLOCATIONS ONE YEAR ALLOCATIONS
HAVE BEEN WONDERFUL TO LEARN
BILL DOT INFRASTRUCTURE AND
IMPROVE OUR EFFORTS ON AN ANNUAL
BASIS.
UNFORTUNATELY THEY HAVE NOT
ALLOWED US TO IMPLEMENT MADE AND
LONG TERM STRATEGIES TO MOVE
TOWARDS LOWER AND BASIC NEEDS
CHALLENGES FROM THE FIRST DAY
THAT THE STUDENT STARTS IN THE
UNIVERSITY TO THE POINT OF
GRADUATION.
WE ARE AS YOU ALL HAVE SEEN YOU
SEEN THE REPORT HOMELESSNESS
ACTUALLY INCREASES AS YOU STAY
IN THE UNIVERSITY FIRST YEAR
HOMELESSNESS RATES IS ABOUT 3%.
AND LAST YEAR RATES ARE ABOUT
15% SO WE WANTED TO INTERVENTION
STRATEGIES TO FLIP THAT ALL THE
ART SO THAT IT STARTS AT A
HIGHER RATE THAT WE DON'T GET WE
DON'T CONTROL STUDENTS COME IN
ALREADY EXPERIENCING HOUSES
THAT'S HOMELESSNESS.
AND WE WANT INTERVENE THAT ON
THE WAY DOWN.
SO WITH THAT SAID ON A PROPOSAL
DEVELOPED BY OUR COMMITTEE
PROGRAMS AND SERVICES AT EACH
CAMPUS WOULD RECEIVE SEVEN
HUNDRED AND FIFTY THOUSAND
DOLLARS PER YEAR. FOR A TOTAL OF
HALF OF THE FUNDING WHICH IS
SEVEN POINT FIVE MILLION AS A
BASELINE ALLOCATION.
THE REMAINING SEVEN POINT FIVE
MILLION FUNDS WOULD BE
DISTRIBUTED ACROSS THROUGH AN
ALLOCATION OF EQUITY BASED ON
ITS ON DUPLICATED POPULATION
THAT WE NOW KNOW ABOUT.
THIS METHOD IS CONSISTENT WITH
HOW YOU SEE HAS USE PASS
ALLOCATIONS AND IT ALLOWS US TO
ADDRESS THE GREATEST NEEDS ON
SOME CAMPUSES THE GREATEST NEED
IS HOUSING FOR EXAMPLE SAN
FRANCISCO.
AND BERKLEY -- ON OTHERS THE
GREATEST THING MAY BE AMONG THE
SUBSET OF POPULATION LIKE
STUDENT PARENTS UNDOCUMENTED
STUDENTS FORMER FOSTER YOUTH AND
GRADUATE STUDENTS WITHOUT ANY
JOB WITHOUT ANY CAMPUS
EMPLOYMENT OR OFF CAMPUS CLIMATE.
THE MODEL WILL ALLOW THE CAMPUS
IS TO TARGET RESOURCES
APPROPRIATELY WE ARE ENCOURAGING
OUR CAMPUSES TO UTILIZE OUR
EQUITABLE FUNDING TO ADDRESS
EQUITY GAPS GENERATED BY FEDERAL
AND STATE POLICIES.
AN EXAMPLE OF AN EQUITY GAP
INTERVENTION IS TO CREATE A
GROCERY SUPPORT AWARD THAT WOULD
MATCH SNAP CAL FOR ASH FINDS FOR
STUDENTS THAT ARE INELIGIBLE FOR
THEM.
WHEREAS SNAPPING CAFES PROVIDES
UP TO ONE NINETY TWO PER MONTH
WITH ADDITIONAL FUNDING FOR
STUDENTS WITH DEPENDENTS WE WILL
CREATE A COMPARABLE AWARD FOR
STUDENTS THAT ARE IN ELIGIBLE
FOR THE SUPPORT.
KEEP POPULATIONS TO NAME HERE ON
DOCUMENTS STUDENTS GRADUATE
STUDENTS STUDENTS WITH
DEPENDENTS AND STUDENTS THAT
HAVE BEEN CUT OFF BY THEIR
FAMILIES WE'VE HAD THIS
CONVERSATION BEFORE SOME OF OUR
STUDENTS COME FROM WEALTHY
BACKGROUNDS BUT THEY GET CUT OFF
BECAUSE OF THEIR GENDER
IDENTITIES A ROMANTIC PARTNER
SOMETHING ELSE.
GOING ON IN THE FAMILY AND THEY
DON'T HAVE ANY ACCESS TO
RESOURCES AND THERE'S NOTHING TO
SUPPORT THEM. TO THE SUCCESS
THAT YOU SEE HAS A G. WITH THE
PASS ONE TIME APPROPRIATINS
DEMONSTRATE THAT THE IS EQUAL
AND EQUITABLE APPROACH WILL WORK
AND LASTLY. FOR THE LAST FOUR
YEARS ARE YOU SEE BASIC NEEDS
EFFORTS HAVE THRIVED IN
PARTNERSHIP WITH BOTH.
OF CAL YES PUBLIC HIGHER
EDUCATION SEGMENTS WHEN WE TALK
ABOUT IS THIS GONNA GENERATED IN
EQUITY ACROSS THE SEGMENTS WHERE
WORKING TOGETHER WITH THE
SEGMENTS.
FROM DAY ONE IN THIS
CONVERSATION.
WE'RE WORKING ALSO WITH THE
FOUNDATION OFCALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY COLLEGES THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL
SERVICES THE CALIFORNIA HOMELESS
YOUTH PROJECTS TO GUESS AND THE
WESTERN CENTER ON LAW AND
POVERTY.
AS WELL AS OTHER ORGANIZATIONS
AND ASSOCIATIONS THAT COME INTO
PLAY AND SERVING THE STUDENTS WE
ARE FULLY COMMITTED TO
CONTINUING OUR VILLAGE APPROACH
TO ENSURE THAT ALL YOU SEE
EFFORTS BENEFIT AND IMPROVE.
THE BASIC NEEDS OF ALL
CALIFORNIA COLLEGE STUDENTS
WHERE ONE HIGHER EDUCATION
VILLAGE AND THE BETTER THAT WE
CARE FOR STUDENTS TODAY THE
BETTER THAT WILL BE AND TAKING
CARE OF THE STATE TOMORROW.
THANK YOU ALL SO MUCH
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
UGH THANK YOU GUYS CHAIR I STILL
WANTED TO ADD THAT WE'RE NOT
JUST ASKING FOR IMMEDIATE
HOUSING ASSISTANCE FUNDS THE
UNIVERSITY DOES HAVE A LONG TERM
PLAN TO CONSTRUCT MORE HOUSING
FOR OUR STUDENTS.
AND THAT BY TWENTY TWENTY FIVE
WE WANT TO ADD ANOTHER FIFTEEN
THOUSAND DORMITORY BEDS TO OUR
CAMPUSES TO MAKE CERTAIN THAT
OUR STUDENTS HAVE ACCESS.
TO SAFE AND AFFORDABLE HOUSING
YEAH I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT
ESPECIALLY.
NOWADAYS -- DID THE EMERGENCY
ISSUES EMERGENCY RE HOUSING AND
TO GET PEOPLE A BRIDGE TO GET.
SOMEWHERE ELSE I WAS REALLY
IMPRESSED BY MEETING WITH -- THE
CHANCELLOR.
THEY'RE ALL APPEAR RECENTLY IN
THE LAST COUPLE OF THE LAST FEW
WEEKS CHANCELLOR BECAUSE OF
COURSE CLOSELY.
AND HE WAS SAYING THAT A FEW
YEARS I'LL HAVE ENOUGH SPACE.
THE END OF BEDS ON THE CAMPUS TO
HOUSE. 80% OTHER STUDENTS FOR
ALL FOUR YEARS MAKE THAT.
WHICH IS AMAZING AND UC SAN
DIEGO.
AND OBVIOUSLY WE HAVE SPACE
ISSUES AT BERKELEY -- LOS
ANGELES -- SANTA CRUZ SANTA
BARBARA SO WE HAVE --
LIMITATIONS THERE THINK OF A LOT
OF ROOM AT RIVERSIDE MY
UNDERSTANDING FOR I'VE BEEN
BEFORE HOUSING.
WE HAVE LAND THERE -- YOU KNOW
THIS IS FOR YOU AND FOR SAY THIS
IS AN ISSUE THAT.
THAT WERE EVEN TALKING ABOUT IT
MIND BOGGLING TO KNOW THAT SOME
OF YOUR STUDENTS ARE SLEEPING IN
THEIR CARS AND YOU DON'T HAVE
ANYTHING TO EAT.
WE WENT TO A OF THAT TOWN HALL
FEW DAYS AGO COUPLE SANDERS
MYSELF HERE AT SAC STATE TALKING
ABOUT THIS ISSUE.
AND THEY HAVE THIS BEAUTIFUL
FOOD PANTRY THAT CAN HAVE THIRTY
SIX AT A TIME AND THEY'RE
PICKING UP FOOD AND JUST A
COUPLE YEARS AGO THERE IS ROOM
FOR FIVE STUDENTS.
THE FACT THAT WE HAVE TO HAVE
THIS FACILITY -- JUST MAKES YOU
SICK TO YOUR STOMACH SO.
THESE ARE ISSUES THAT YOU KNOW
WE'RE NOT GOING TO WALK AWAY
FROM -- WANT TO ADDRESS AND WE
HAVE HAD ONE TIME MY LAST FEW
YEARS AND SO.
CERTAINLY AT I'M I'M I'M PLEASE
THEY WERE HAVING A DISCUSSION
ABOUT HAVING ONGOING -- MONEY
HERE -- INTO THESE BASIC NEEDS
ALSO TIES WITH THE ISSUE WE
TALKED ABOUT EARLIER TODAY A
MENTAL HEALTH ISSUE THAT'S A BIG
ISSUE FOR STUDENTS AS AS YOU
LIVE TO ONE ISSUE THAT I THAT IS
JUST YOU KNOW COULD REALLY
FRUSTRATING FOR SO MANY OF US.
AND AND FOR ONCE AND I CAN.
NOT PUSH TO GET THE YOU SEE HERE
BUT IT'S IS A HIGHER ISSUE AS A
WHOLE -- IS.
SOME YOUR STUDENTS ARE LOW
INCOME BY DEFINITION THEIR PELL
GRANT RECIPIENTS AND THEIR
INCOME IS EXTREMELY LOW.
AND IT'S SUCH A HOP.
SO DIFFICULT SO HARD TO ENROLL
AND CAL FOR ASH YEP ALL THE
PAPERWORK WITH THE COUNTIES AND
THIS AND THAT SO.
YOU KNOW WE'RE TRYING TO PUT
TOGETHER A WORKING GROUP TO TO
FIGURE THIS OUT AND WE WELCOME
ANY SUGGESTIONS OR IDEAS.
BECAUSE THESE ARE THE EXACT
STUDENTS THAT WHO WANT TO GET
HELP AND ONE THEY'RE HUNGRY.
I'M TO WE'RE LEAVING MONEY ON
THE TABLE FROM THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT THROUGH OUR CAL FRESH
PROGRAM SO.
WE REALLY OUGHT TO BE --
STEPPING IT UP TO TO MAKE IT
EASIER FOR OUR STUDENTS TO TO
PARTICIPATE NOW WE HAVE A YOU
HAVE A YES THEY HAVE THAT MAGIC
SOLUTION FOR US TONIGHT SO
SOMETHING'S NOT A SUMMONS SHARE
WITH YOUR EYES THAT SO ACTUALLY --
SENATOR -- PATTY MURRAY WAS ABLE
TO MOVE -- A BILL AT THE FEDERAL
LEVEL THAT HAS UPDATED THE
NATIONAL.
FINANCIAL AID DATA SHARING TREE
AND WHAT THAT DOES NOW IS IT
ALLOWS US TO USE FINANCIAL AID
DATA.
AND WE CAN TAP INTO THAT DATA
FOR PUBLIC ASSISTANT.
REASONS WHEREAS BEFORE WE COULD
NOT USE FINANCIAL AID DATA SO WE
WANTED TO ASK FINANCIAL AID
OFFICES HEY GIVE ME THE LIST OR
THE ROSTER.
OF PELL GRANTS STUDENTS AND WORK
STUDY STUDENTS AND STUDENTS
RECEIVING A CAL GRANT THEY
WOULDN'T BE ABLE TO DO THAT NOW
WE'RE GONNA BE ABLE TO DO THAT
SO WE'RE ACTUALLY WORKING WITH
NASA FAR WE'RE GONNA GO.
TO THE NASA NATIONAL CONFERENCE
WE'RE GONNA BE STRATEGIZING AND
AS SOON AS NEXT THIS UPCOMING
ACADEMIC YEAR WE'RE GONNA BE
ABLE TO CREATE COHORT MODELS OF
INTERVENTION SO THESE THIS
FUNDING THAT WE'RE DISCUSSING
RIGHT NOW.
THEN GETS OPERATIONALIZE IN
TERMS OF HAVING THE STAFFING
STUDENTS STAFFING THAT IS GOING
TO ALLOW US TO SAY EVERY STUDENT
IS GOING TO BE RESPONSIBLE FOR A
SUBSET OF THOSE ROSTERS.
SO THEN YOU HAVE BLACK STUDENTS
SERVING BLACK STUDENTS LGBT PLUS
STUDENTS SERVING LGBT PLUS
STUDENTS SO ON AND SO FORTH AND
REACHING OUT TO THEM TO EDUCATE
THEM ABOUT NOT JUST CAO FRESH.
BUT ALSO ABOUT THE HOLISTIC
SUPPORT SERVICES ON BASIC NEEDS
ON THOSE CAMPUSES WHICH WE NEVER
BEEN NEVER TO DO BEFORE SO WE'RE
REALLY EXCITED ABOUT THOSE
EFFORTS BUT I DO WANT TO POINT
THAT.
IN THE REPORT THAT WE SUBMITTED
TO YOU ALL BACK IN FEB.
AND YOU SEE THE CAL FRESH
NUMBERS YOU'RE STARTING TO SEE
THAT A CAMPUS FOR EXAMPLE LIKE
SANTA BARBARA -- TWENTY SIX
HUNDRED STUDENTS BERKELEY
THIRTEEN HUNDRED DAVIS THIRTEEN
HUNDRED THE CAMPUS IS THAT HAVE
COUNTY RELATIONSHIPS ARE
STARTING TO SEE THEIR NUMBERS GO
UP SO THE POWER HERE IN THE NEW
WORK WORK THAT WE DEVELOP FOR
SOCIAL SERVICES IS.
HOW TO WE ENHANCE THOSE
RELATIONSHIPS AND FOR THE CAMPUS
IS FOR EXAMPLE YOU SEE THAT HAVE
BASIC NEEDS CENTERS HOW DO WE
MAKE THAT CENTER FOR THE
COMMUNITY?
SO THAT WHEN WE'RE DOING CAL
FRESH EFFORTS THE STAFF AND THE
STUDENTS ARE TRAINED TO SERVE
EVERYBODY SO FOR EXAMPLE AT UC
BERKELEY WE KNOW THAT BERKELEY
COMMUNITY COLLEGE IS DOWN THE
STREET FROM UC BERKELEY.
HOW DO WE GET BERKELEY COMMUNITY
COLLEGE STUDENTS TO COME ONTO
CAMPUS AND ALSO GET SUPPORT WITH
THEIR CAL FIRST APPLICATIONS SO
THAT'S HOW WE'RE THINKING ABOUT
IT WE'RE THINKING ABOUT IT?
HOW DO WE DO CROSS SEGMENT
STRATEGIES IN SUPPORT OF THE
STUDENTS AT LARGE?
OKAY MISTER RIGHT CITY THANK YOU
SO I I AM -- NOT -- UNDER THE
UNDERSTANDING WHY.
I MEAN YUBA MUST CHAIR YOU
MENTION A LOT OF PAPERWORK BUT
WHY WHY IF IF THE STUDENTS CAN
GET FOOD.
WHY WHY ARE THEY APPLYING FOR
CALPERS?
YEAH SO A COUPLE THINGS SO ONE
IS -- DAIS THE THE CHALLENGE
THAT COMES UP FOR STUDENTS IS
THAT.
SOME STUDENTS APPLY ON THEIR OWN
AND THEY HAVE REALLY CHALLENGING
EXPERIENCES ON THEIR OWN SO THEN
THEY TELL OTHER STUDENTS THAT IS
NOT WORTH IT TO APPLY.
BECAUSE THERE'S NEW TECHNOLOGY
NOW THAT FACILITIES THAT PROCESS
AND SENSE OF THE NEW FUNDING
THAT WE RECEIVE FROM YACHT NOW
THEIR STAFFING ON CAMPUS. TO
GUIDE STUDENTS SPECIFICALLY
THROUGH IT SO NOW YOU'RE
STARTING TO SEE THE NUMBERS
INCREASE THERE'S ALSO THE HUGE
CONVERSATION OF STUDENTS KNOWING
THAT THEY NEED TO COME IN TO
SUBMIT AN APPLICATION AND GO
THROUGH THE PROCESS.
A LOT OF STUDENTS UNFORTUNATELY
THE COUNTY STILL LEARNING HOW TO
WORK WITH STUDENTS.
SO IN ORDER FOR YOU TO GET CAO
FRESH YOU DON'T JUST APPLY YOU
ALSO HAVE TO COMPLETE AN
INTERVIEW.
AND THAT PHONE INTERVIEW
SOMETIMES THEY GET PHONE CALLS
FROM THE COUNTY AND THEY'RE IN
CLASS OR THERE AND WORK AND THEY
MISS THAT PHONE CALL AND IT'S
REALLY HARD FOR THEM TO MAKE UP
THAT PHONE CALL.
SO THEY HEAR ABOUT THOSE HORROR
STORIES VERY SIMILAR TO STUDENT
LOANS WHEN MANY OF OUR STUDENTS
WHEN THEY'RE THINKING ABOUT
COLLEGE THEY HEAR ABOUT A
HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLARS A LOAN
DEBT.
AND THAT KEEPS THEM FROM
ACCEPTING THE ONE THOUSAND
DOLLARS LOAN THAT THEY NEED
BECAUSE THEY'RE AFRAID THAT IT'S
GOING TO ESCALATE TO THAT LEVEL
THERE'S A LOT OF MISINFORMATION
THAT WERE CLEANING UP.
THE GOOD THING NOW IS THAT OUR
FINANCIAL AID OFFICES ARE
STARTING TO SEND OUT TEXT
MESSAGES TO STUDENTS AND SAYING
HEY YOU ARE POTENTIALLY ELIGIBLE
FOR CALIBRATION THERE'S A TEAM
ON CAMPUS THAT CAN HELP YOU.
AND THAT'S WHEN YOU'RE SEEING
THEIR NUMBER STARTING TO GO UP.
I MADE IT IT SEEMS TO MAKE A LOT
OF SENSE TO ME THAT WE IN A HOME
WE WOULD WOULD WOULD PROVIDE
SUPPORT FOR STUDENTS TO BE ABLE
TO APPLY FOR THE BENEFITS THAT
THEY'RE ENTITLED -- TO I DON'T
KNOW IT JUST SEEMS THAT AT SOME
POINT HEALTHY WE CAN'T LIKE HAND
HOLD THEM THROUGH EVERYTHING YOU
KNOW I MEAN IF THEY'RE HUNGRY.
AND THEY'RE ELIGIBLE FOR
BENEFITS THAN THEY SHOULD.
YOU KNOW DO WHAT IT TAKES TO
APPLYING I THINK THERE'S MORE
THAT THERE'S THESE WORK
REQUIREMENTS. TWENTY HOUR.
WORK REQUIREMENTS YOU HAVE TO
SHOW THE COUNTY OFFICIALS THAT
THEIR STUDENT AND IN OUR
TRAINING.
HAVE STUDENTS GO MORE FULL TIME --
AND I I I KNOW THAT THERE ARE
OTHER PROGRAMS LOOK WE HAVE FOR
EXAMPLE FREE LUNCH IF YOU'RE
FREE LUNCH YOU'RE AUTOMATICALLY
ALSO FOR OTHER PROGRAMS RIGHT SO.
WE IT SEEMS THAT WE SHOULD
SIMPLIFY THINGS I DON'T THINK
THE STUDENTS ARE ARE LAZY AND ON
DO IT.
THEY'RE OBVIOUSLY GOING IN IN
THERE TO GET -- FOOD IN HERE AT
THAT WILL TO WANT SEX. EIGHT TWO
DAYS AGO AND AND TALKED ABOUT
YOU KNOW THE THE OLD BIBLICAL
REFERENCE GIVE SOMEBODY A FISH
FOR A DAY OR TWO TO THE FISH FOR
LIFE GRANTED FOOD STAMPS IS NOT
FISH FOR LIFE BUT WHILE THEY'RE
IN SCHOOL THEY'RE STARVING
STUDENT.
AND THEY THEY SAY IT'S JUST
EXTRAORDINARILY DIFFICULT A LOT
OF THESE ARE THESE FEDERAL
REQUIREMENTS AND SO.
THESE IS NOT OUR PURVIEW TO
CHANGE THAT BUT I I THINK IT'S
SOMETHING WE NEED TO CONTINUE TO
WORK ON IT SO IF THERE ARE SOME
THINGS THAT WE CAN DO IN OUR
POWER TO MAKE IT EASIER FOR
STUDENTS SAID. TO DO THIS PLEASE
LIST NOW -- SO WITH THAT THIS IS
AGAIN A PRIORITY OF OURS WILL.
TAKE A LOOK AT THIS ISSUE AS
WELL AS THE BASIC NEEDS WITH UC
I'M SORRY CSU AND COMMITTEE
COLLEGES AND COME OUT WITH THAT.
MAYBE A REFINED PROPOSAL IN AND
IN MAY.
ALL THIS ISSUE OPEN THE NEXT
ISSUE CAPITAL OUTLAY DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE THANK YOU -- THANK
YOU CHAIR.
RAINY CATS DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE --
SINCE TWO THOUSAND THIRTEEN
FOURTEEN YOU SEEM A USE OF
SUPPORT APPROPRIATION FOR
CAPITAL OUTLAY PROJECTS
ADDRESSING THE NEED TO
FACILITIES THAT SERVE ACADEMIC
PROGRAMS.
AT IN ADDITION THIS AUTHORITY
ALLOWS YOU SEE TO FINANCE THE
COST OF THE FIRST MAINTENANCE
PROJECTS ACADEMIC FACILITIES AND
RELATED INFRASTRUCTURE HOWEVER
SUPPORT APPROPRIATION NOTED THAT
SERVICE CAN BE USED FOR CAPITAL
EXPENDITURES. FOR TWO THOUSAND
NINETEEN TWENTY YOU SEE SUBMIT
ONE DEFERRED MAINTENANCE AND SIX
CAPITAL OUTLAY REQUEST.
ALL ARE QUALIFYING PROJECTS AND
ONCE FUNDED WILL RAISE THE
PROJECT IN MASS AND PERCENTAGE
TO SIX POINT 8% WELL BELOW THE
15% THRESHOLD -- IN ADDITION TO
THE CAPITAL OUTLAY EXPENDITURES
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET PROVIDES A
HUNDRED THIRTY EIGHT MILLION AND
ONE TIME GENERAL FUND TO SUPPORT
DEFERRED MAINTENANCE -- SO WE DO
NOTE THEN THE COMMENTS THAT
THERE'S SOME PROPOSED REPORTING
REQUIREMENTS.
ADMINISTRATION IS HAPPY TO WORK
WITH LEGISLATIVE STAFF TO
PROVIDE INFORMATION REGARDING --
UC'S PROPOSED DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE FUNDING ASSOCIATED
PROJECTS TO ENSURE THE FUNDING
DOES THE US USES THAT OUTCOMES.
HOWEVER WE KNOW CONCERNS WITH
THE BREADTH OF THE ADDITIONAL
REPORTING REQUIREMENTS THANK YOU.
SO THERE ARE TWO ISSUES BEFORE
YOU IN THIS ITEM THE FIRST IS
CAPITAL OUTLAY IN THE SECOND IS
DEFERRED MAINTENANCE.
WILL TOUCH ON EACH ISSUE.
REGARDING CAPITAL OUTLAY IF YOU
TURN TO PAGE NINETEEN OF YOUR
AGENDA THE LIST OF THE ONE
DEFERRED MAINTENANCE AND AND SIX
A CAPITAL PROJECTS THAT THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE NOTED.
ON WE REVIEW THESE PROJECTS --
BACK IN FEBRUARY AND WE RAISE
CONCERNS WITH SOME -- THE
ADMINISTRATION DID PROVIDE FINAL
APPROVAL FOR THESE PROJECTS IN
APRIL SO THE PROJECTS ARE
APPROVED BY THE ADMINISTRATION.
AND WE'RE HAPPY IN THE QUEUE NAY
IF INTERESTED FOR THE COMMITTEE
TO SHARE OUR FULLER ASSESSMENT
ANALYSIS OF EACH OF THE PROJECTS.
REGARDING THE SECOND ISSUE
DEFERRED MAINTENANCE.
OTHER REALLY ARE TO DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE PROPOSALS THE FIRST
IS A HUNDRED THIRTY EIGHT
MILLION DOLLAR ONE TIME GENERAL
FUND AND THE SECOND IS THAT
THIRTY FIVE MILLION DOLLARS IN
BOND FUNDING THAT YOU SEE IN
FIGURE TWENTY EIGHT ON PAGE.
NINETEEN SO THE TOTAL AMOUNT OF
DEFERRED MAINTENANCE FUNDING
BEING PROPOSED THIS YEAR.
IS A HUNDRED SEVENTY THREE
MILLION DOLLARS.
THE UNIVERSITY SUBMITTED TO OUR
OFFICE A LIST OF PROJECTS THAT
WOULD BE USED FOR THE FUNDING OF
THAT LIST TOTAL A HUNDRED FIFTY
SIX HUNDRED FIFTY SEVEN MILLION
DOLLARS SO IT WAS A SUCH A
LITTLE BIT SHORT OF THE TOTAL
AMOUNT OF PROPOSED DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE FUNDING.
WE'RE STILL WORKING WITH THE
UNIVERSITY TO SEE FORGET A MORE --
A COMPREHENSIVE LIST WE HAVE A
FEW THOUGHTS ON REPORTING
LANGUAGE THAT COULD HELP IMPROVE
THE TRANSPARENCY OF THESE FUNDS
ON AND ENSURE THAT THE
LEGISLATURE UNDERSTAND WHICH
PROJECTS ARE BEING FUNDED RAPID
WORK WITH STAFF ON THAT LANGUAGE.
ONE ISSUE THAT A WE DID REYES
SPECIFICALLY FOR DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE IS THAT THE
UNIVERSITY IS PROPOSING TO FIND --
WHAT'S -- WHAT'S KNOWN AS A FAT
INFRASTRUCTURE CONDITION
ASSESSMENT REPORT -- AND THAT
ASSESSMENT BASICALLY LOOKS AT
THE CONDITION OF THE CAMPUS IS
ROADS UTILITIES ALL OTHER SORT
OF ASSOCIATE ENVISIONED FOR
STRUCTURE THAT ISN'T RELATED TO
FACILITIES.
AND THEY'RE PROPOSING SPEND FIVE
MILLION OF THAT. FOR THAT
PURPOSE AND THEY'RE THEY'RE
ALREADY CURRENTLY DOING
SOMETHING SIMILAR FOR THEIR
FACILITIES. ONE OF OUR CHIEF
CONCERNS IS THAT THE UNIVERSITY
WAS GOING TO USE BOND FUNDING
FOR THIS -- REPORT WHICH WE
THOUGHT WAS A POOR USE OF ON
FUNDING THE UNIVERSITY HAS SINCE
STATED THAT THEY'LL USE THEIR
ONE TIME FUNDING FOR THAT AND
THAT DOES.
ADDRESS A SUBSTANTIAL CONCERN WE
HAD WE STILL HAVE SOME
ADDITIONAL CONCERNS IT'S STILL
UNCLEAR TO US WHY EXISTING STAFF.
ARE AND WHERE IT CAN'T TO
PRODUCE AN ESTIMATE OF THEIR IF
THE EXISTING CONDITION OF ON
CAMPUSES AND OF THE OVERALL
EXPENSE OF THE REPORT BUT
UNIVERSITY HAS AT LEAST
ADDRESSED ONE SUBSTANTIAL
CONCERN THAT WE HAD.
THEN FINALLY -- WE RECOMMEND AND
YOU'VE IN THIS COMMITTEE SERVICE
RECOMMEND THIS BEFORE SO GO OVER
QUICKLY BUT WE RECOMMEND THAT
AND AS PART OF FUNDING DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE THAT THE LEGISLATURE
DIRECT THE UNIVERSITY. TO COME
BACK TO IT WITH A LONG TERM PLAN
TO ADDRESS MAINTENANCE THE PLAN
WOULD.
IDENTIFY THE TOTAL COST OF UC'S
MAINTENANCE BACKLOG AND ALSO
PROPOSED A MOVING FORWARD AWAY.
TO ENSURE THAT THE MAINTENANCE
BACKLOG A DOZEN GROWING IT WOULD
PROVIDE -- ESTIMATES OF HOW MUCH
WOULD HAVE TO SPEND EACH YEAR TO
PAY DOWN THE BACKLOG AND KEEP IT
FROM GROWING.
I'M IN THAT WOULD HELP GUIDE
FUTURE LEGISLATIVE BUDGET
DECISIONS RIGHT NOW WE'RE
APPROPRIATING ONE TIME FUNDING
BUT THERE'S A LACK OF CLARITY ON
OF COURSE ARE WHAT THE OVER
ARCHING GOAL IS AND WHETHER OR
NOT THE BACKLOG KEEPS GROWING
AND WHETHER OR NOT WORK.
WE'LL BE ABLE TO FULLY ADDRESS
THE BACKLOG.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ALL DRESSED --
DEFERRED MAINTENANCE CONCERNS
FIRST -- WE HAVE PROVIDED THE
COMMITTEE CONSULTANTS SOME
INFORMATION ABOUT OUR FOUR POINT
FOUR BILLION DOLLAR.
OF DEFERRED MAINTENANCE BACKLOG
IF WE DON'T CONTINUE TO ADDRESS
THAT -- IT'S NOT GOING TO GET
ANY SMALLER -- AND IT MIGHT EVEN
GROW UP MANY OF OUR BUILDINGS --
APPROXIMATELY HALF OF THE CAMPUS
BUILDINGS ARE OVER THIRTY YEARS
IN AGE AND WE'RE REACHING THAT
POINT WHERE WE'RE SEEING A LOT
OF MAJOR SYSTEMS FAILING THIS IS
PART OF THE REASON WHY -- THE
DEFERRED MAINTENANCE BACKLOG IS
GROWING SO RAPIDLY ALSO -- WE
USED TO HAVE A STATE DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE PROGRAM FOR YOU SEE
WAY BACK BEFORE NINETEEN NINETY
FOUR THERE WAS A STEADY
APPROPRIATION ANNUALLY OF TWENTY
MILLION DOLLARS TO DO
MAINTENANCE ON THE CAMPUSES.
DUE TO SOME BUDGETARY PRESSURES
THAT WAS ENDED -- AND THE
RESPONSIBILITY FOR FUNDING THE
DEFERRED MAINTENANCE WAS SHIFTED
ON THAT THE CAMPUS US NOW -- THE
LEGISLATURE HAS AGAIN TURN THIS
AROUND -- SINCE. TWENTY FOURTEEN
YOU BEEN PROVIDING US -- WITH
ANNUAL APPROPRIATIONS TO ADDRESS
OUR DEFERRED MAINTENANCE BACKLOG
BUT DURING THAT TIME.
WHEN THE CAMPUSES WERE
RESPONSIBLE FOR RE DIRECTING
SOME OF THEIR OPERATIONAL
FUNDING TO IT? TOO DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE THOSE -- PROJECTS
STARTED TO PILE UP AND THEY SER
RE TO CRITICAL POINT WHERE --
SYSTEMS NEED TO BE REPLACED ON
SOME OF THESE OLDER BUILDINGS WE
ARE REQUESTING THIS COMMITTEE
APPROVED THE GOVERNOR'S A
PROPOSAL TO PROVIDE US WITH
HUNDRED AND THIRTY EIGHT MILLION
DOLLARS TOWARD OUR DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE PROJECTS WE CAN.
EASILY FIND -- THE PROJECTS ON
CAMPUSES AND I'M HAPPY TO
PROVIDE WELL THE CABINET MEMBERS
A LIST OF THE PROJECTS THAT
WOULD BE -- DONE WE'RE ALSO
HAPPY TO PROVIDE REPORTING -- TO
THE JAIL BC OF THE PROJECTS THAT
WE COMPLETE IF THAT WOULD MAKE
THE COMMITTEE FEEL BETTER ABOUT
THE PROGRESS STUFF WE'RE DOING.
TOWARDS THOSE THOSE PROGRAMS --
IN REGARDS TO THE CAPITAL OUTLAY
PROJECTS -- I ALSO WANTED TO
POINT OUT THAT ON PAGE TWENTY
ONE WE ARE PLANNING ON DOING
SOME NEW CAPITAL OUTLAY PROJECTS.
THAT WOULD -- PROVIDE US WITH --
WITH NEW CLASSROOM FACILITIES
AND ALSO RESEARCH SPACE FOR OUR
CAMPUSES STUFF WE WILL USE OUR
INTERNAL BOND AUTHORITY FOR WE
ARE REQUESTING ANOTHER FIFTEEN
MILLION DOLLARS -- FROM THE
LEGISLATURE TOWARD OUR A. B. --
NINETY FOUR BONDED INDEBTEDNESS
FOR PROJECTS THAT HAVE ALREADY
BEEN COMPLETED OF THAT WERE
APPROVED BY THE LEGISLATURE
SEVERAL YEARS AGO.
THAT -- ARE NOW COMING DUE ON
THE BOND AT CAN ANSWER SOME
QUESTIONS -- SURE YOU KNOW ONE
QUESTION I I JUST.
I JUST FOUND INCREDIBLES IS
TALKING TO MR MURATSUCHI WHO'S
THE ALUMNI.
OF UC BERKELEY AS AS IS MY MY
FATHER [inaudible]
IS THAT.
CRAZY AMOUNT -- DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE BACKLOG AT BERKELEY
VERSES THE WHOLE UC SYSTEM MY
UNDERSTANDING IT'S OF YOUR FOUR
BILLION DOLLAR BACKLOG BERKELEY
REPRESENTS ONE OF YOUR TEN
CAMPUSES.
WILL NINE UNDERGRADUATE CAMPUSES
IT'S SOMETHING LIKE WELL OVER
HALF 50% MAYBE TWO THIRDS OF
ABOUT ONE POINT SEVEN BILLION
YES YEAH [inaudible]
YEAH SO. HUNDRED AND THIRTY FIVE
WHAT IS A HUNDRED YEAH HUNDRED
AND SOME MILLION A YEAR.
ISN'T GOING TO CUT IT.
AND THE CITY BUILDINGS ARE
REALLY OLD HI MISSY BURKE WAS AN
OLD CAMPUS NOT JUST BERKELEY PER
SE BUT WHAT'S OUR OVERALL.
PLAN TO MAKE SURE WE MAKE SURE
OUR CAMPUSES ARE NUMBER ONE SAFE
FOR STUDENTS.
IN THOSE OLD BUILDINGS. FOR
EXAMPLE ON A FAULT LINE IN
BERKELEY.
BUT BASICALLY AT HERE TO THE
EDUCATION STANDARDS WE NEED FOR
STUDENTS.
ARE WE ARE IN THE PROCESS OF
CONDUCTING A SEISMIC -- SAFETY
ASSESSMENT OF OUR BUILDINGS
WHICH WILL REVEAL MORE ABOUT
WHICH BUILDINGS ARE HIGH
PRIORITY PARTLY BECAUSE CODES
HAVE CHANGED AND SOME OF THE
BUILDINGS HAVE GOTTEN OLDER SO
THEY ARE NO LONGER --
POTENTIALLY ABLE TO WITHSTAND
SOME -- MORE INTENSE EARTHQUAKE
SO WE ARE IN THE MIDDLE OF
CONDUCTING AN ASSESSMENT THAT
SHOULD TELL US MORE ABOUT
WHETHER OR NOT BUILDINGS NEED TO
BE REINFORCED OR TORN DOWN --
BUT IN TERMS OF ADDRESSING THE
BACKLOG WE THINK THAT WE NEED TO
TREAT OUR CAMPUSES EQUALLY AND
PROVIDE THEM WITH -- WHICH
DEFERRED MAINTENANCE MONEY THAT
REFLECTS THE AGE OF THEIR
BUILDINGS BUT THAT PROVIDES
EVERY CAMPUS WITH SOME FUNDS SO
THAT THEY CAN ADDRESS THEIR MOST
CRITICAL PROJECTS.
WHEN WHEN CERTAIN PROJECTS LIKE
ROOF REPLACEMENTS AREN'T
ADDRESSED?
AND THE WATER STARTS GETTING
INTO THE WALLS TO PROJECTS THEN
BECOME FAR MORE EXPENSIVE.
SO IT IT IS CHEAPER TO TAKE CARE
OF SOME PROJECTS ON THE ON THE
FRONT END YOU KNOW DO SOME.
DO SOME DEFERRED MAINTENANCE SO
THAT DOESN'T GET WORSE LATER ON
ARE THERE OTHER ALTERNATIVE
FUNDS THAT THE CAMERAS ARE
LOOKING AT TO ADDRESS THEIR
DEFERRED MAINTENANCE IT.
THE ISSUE BECAUSE OBVIOUSLY THIS
PART ON AND OFF COMING OUT OF
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA EVERY
YEAR FROM THE BUDGET PROCESS.
THE UNIVERSITY HAS A SERIES OF
FUNDS THAT WE USE -- TO MANAGE
OUR CORE BUDGET OPERATIONS
OBVIOUSLY NON RESIDENT TUITION
IS ONE OF THEM.
AND IF CAMPUSES WERE ABLE TO
GROW NON RESIDENTS THEY WOULD BE
ABLE TO GET SOME ADDITIONAL
REVENUE DOC WAY BUT I KNOW.
WE HAVE RECEIVED.
NO NO NO.
BUT WE HAVE RECEIVED DIRECTION
FROM THIS COMMITTEE THAT IS NOT
YOUR PREFERRED FULL ROUTE SO WE
WILL.
NOT GO THERE YEAH BUT ALL
SERIOUSNESS IT IS A MAJOR ISSUE
IT'S ONE OF THOSE THINGS WERE.
YOU KNOW.
GOD FORBID THERE'S SOME TRAGEDY
WE'VE TO WAKE UP TO LIKE WE SEE
WITH.
FLOODS AND AND EARTHQUAKES.%
NATURAL DISASTERS WITH ON THAT
TO HAPPEN -- BUT YOU KNOW
OBVIOUSLY THAT'S A VERY OLD
CAMPUS BUT YOU KNOW ACROSS THE
NATION THERE THERE THIS I'M SURE
THIS ISN'T AN ISSUE TO ALL OF
OUR OLDER UNIVERSITIES ON THE
EAST COAST HOW ARE THEY DEALING
WITH THEIR DIFFERENT MEANS
ISSUES THAT THE PUBLIC
UNIVERSITIES.
I'M NOT CERTAIN HOW OTHER PUBLIC
UNIVERSITIES ARE DEALING WITH
THEIR DEFERRED MAINTENANCE
ISSUES I'M NOT -- CERTAIN.
ANOTHER -- POTENTIAL SOURCE OF
REVENUE WE HAVE IS OUR DONORS
ALUMNI EX SPECIALLY BUT SOME
WEALTHIER DONORS -- BUT THEY
USUALLY WANT TO TEAR DOWN A
BUILDING A BUILDING NEW ONE WITH
THEIR NAME ON IT SO.
WE MADE WE GOT A SEXY DONATION
GIVING TO DEFERRED MAINTENANCE
IS HER WHO I DON'T THINK WE'VE
GOTTEN ANYONE NEW SCIENCE
BUILDING A NEW ROOF FOR THE WELL
MAYBE IF THE OF THE YOU KNOW NOW
I DON'T SAY THAT.
OKAY THANK YOU QUESTIONS TWENTY
MEMBERS.
SEEING NONE -- ISSUE NUMBER.
ISSUE NUMBER SEVEN OFFICE THE
PRESIDENT JUST AND JUST TO
RELIEVE THE THE UC PATH
INDIVIDUAL HERE.
WE ARE WITH THAT'S INFORMATIONAL.
NO ACTION IN THE BUDGET AND THAT
WE RECEIVE THE INFORMATION FROM
THE UC SO WE'RE NOT GOING TO
HAVE.
A PUBLIC DISCUSSION ISSUE NUMBER
EIGHT SO.
THIS NG OUT -- A PRESENTATION
THAT I WILL BE SPEAKING -- TO AS
ON REGARDING TO YOU SEE OFFICE
OF THE PRESIDENT BUDGET SO I'M
GOING TO BRIEFLY REVIEW THE UC
OP BUDGET THIS A CONTEXT FOR OUR
DISCUSSION ON THE OFFICE OF THE
PRESIDENT ORGANIZATIONAL
OPTIMIZATION EFFORTS.
AT THE HEART OF THESE
OPTIMIZATION EFFORTS IS
ANSWERING THE QUESTION OF WHAT
VALUE DOES YOU C. O. P. ADD TO
THE UC SYSTEM BASED ON THE
PROGRAMS AND SERVICES THAT IT
PROVIDES.
YOU SEE A PIECE POSITION TODAY
AS A SYSTEM WIDE OFFICE IS
STRONGER BECAUSE OF OURS
ASSESSMENTS AND EFFORTS TO
ENSURE THE ORGANIZATIONS
FUNCTIONING EFFICIENTLY AND
EFFECTIVELY AS POSSIBLE.
A PROCESS THAT PRESIDENT APOLLO
TANO BEGAN EARLY IN HER TENURE
AT U. C. O. P..
THE TOTAL UC OP BUDGET IS EIGHT
HUNDRED SEVENTY SIX POINT FOUR
MILLION AND REPRESENTS TWO POINT
4% OF THE TOTAL THIRTY SIX
BILLION SYSTEM WIDE BUDGET.
THE USE UPS SYSTEM WIDE OFFICE
OF THE UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA
SYSTEM THE MAJORITY OF U. C. O.
P. FUND USES CAN BE DIVIDED INTO
TWO MAJOR CATEGORIES.
PROGRAMS AND INITIATIVES AND
CENTRAL AND ADMINISTRATIVE%
SERVICES THE UC OP BUDGET
PRESENTATION TO THE RETURNS HAS
SIGNIFICANTLY IMPROVED AND
TRANSPARENCY.
AND INCLUDES THE SUMMARY LEVEL
INFORMATION AS WELL AS DETAILED
INFORMATION OF THE ANNUAL BUDGET
FOR EACH PROGRAM.
INITIATIVE AND YOU CO OP
DIVISION.
ON SITE THREE YOU'LL SEE THAT
TOTAL PROGRAMS AND INITIATIVES
BUDGET FOR TWENTY EIGHTEEN
NINETEEN IS THREE HUNDRED NINETY
FIVE POINT SEVEN MILLION OR 45%
OF THE TOTAL YOU SEE -- BE
BUDGET A LOT OF THIS BUDGET
FLOWS THROUGH YOU COPD CAMPUSES
AND OTHER ENTITIES.
THE FOUR PROGRAMS NOTED ON THE
SLIDE ARE EXAMPLES OF PASSED
THROUGH PROGRAMS THAT ARE RUN ON
BEHALF OF THE STATE I MAKE UP
NEARLY TWO THIRDS OF THE
PROGRAMS AND INITIATIVES BUDGET.
ON SLIDE.
FOR YOU'LL SEE THAT CENTRAL
ADMINISTRATIVE SERVICES ARE
ABOUT -- THREE HUNDRED SEVENTY
NINE POINT FIVE MILLION OR 43%
OF THE UC OP BUDGET.
AND THEY SUPPORT SYSTEM WIDE
SERVICES ADMINISTERED CENTRALLY --
AND THE UC OP INTERNAL
OPERATIONS MANY OF THESE
SERVICES ARE SUPPORTED BY A FEE
FOR SERVICE REVENUES WERE USED
TO BE PROVIDES THE SERVICE ON
BEHALF OF THE ENTIRE SYSTEM. TO
ELIMINATE REDUNDANCIES SUCH SUCH
AS GENERAL COUNSEL OR TO RETIRE
RETIREMENT CENTER.
ON SLIDE FIVE YOU'LL SEE THE UC
OP BUDGET IN EIGHTEEN NINETEEN
IS EIGHT HUNDRED SEVENTY SIX
POINT FOUR MILLION WHICH IS A
DECREASE OF 2%.
FROM.
SEVENTEEN EIGHTEEN SINCE THE
STATE AUDIT WAS RELEASED IN
APRIL TWENTY SEVENTEEN U. C. O.
P. HAS LAUNCH SEVERAL EFFORTS TO
CHANGE ITS BUDGET IN PRACTICES.
AND THE REVIEW YOU SEE -- P.
STRUCTURE AND SERVICES
HIGHLIGHTS OF THE UC O. P.
EIGHTEEN NINETEEN BUDGET AND
SOME OF THE CHINA CHANGES
INCLUDE.
THE UC OP TOTAL BUDGET WAS
REDUCED BY THIRTY THREE MILLION
DOLLARS -- IN SEVENTEEN EIGHTEEN
IF YOU EXCLUDE THE UC PASS.
IF WE INCLUDE THE INCREASED IN A
CAN CAN I ASK YOU TO ENTER THIS
IS SORRY UNORTHODOX BUT WE TAKE
A THIRTY SECOND TIME OUT.
AND CAN YOU.
AT TAX YOUR FELLOW FROM YOU SEE
PATH AND ASK HIM TO TO COME BACK
HE JUST LEFT AND WE DO WANT TO
HEAR THAT ITEM -- YEAH BEFORE
YOU GET ON THE FREEWAY SO.
I DON'T KNOW IF I HAVE HAS --
OKAY -- OUR STAFF RAN OUT THERE
TO SEE IF WE CAN FIND IT BUT IF
YOU DO.
HAVE IS INFORMATION.
YEAH I DO HAVE THIS MOBILE
NUMBER -- CAN I CALL HAVE DO ON
THE TEXT OF WHATEVER YOU NEED
YOU SO YOU CAN STAND UP THE
WALKWAY FIRST YEAH YOU SHOULD
GET OUT TO FOUR YEAH YOU YOU
WILL TAKE A LITTLE RECESS YOU
CAN YOU CAN WALK AWAY
[inaudible]
CONTACT.
ATTACKS THAT HAVE A GOLF COURSE
THAT'S OKAY YOU YOU YOU --
CERTAINLY -- YOU'RE DOING YOUR
BEST OKAY.
PLEASE CONTINUE ALRIGHT WHERE
WAS I YES I WAS TALKING ABOUT ON
SLIDE -- FIVE ACTUALLY -- SO I
FIVE SOME OF THE HIGHLIGHTS OF
THE UC O. P. EIGHTEEN NINETEEN
BUDGET AND SOME OF THE CHANGES
THAT WE'VE ALREADY IMPLEMENTED
INCLUDED.
THAT THE UC OP TOTAL BUDGET WAS
REDUCED BY THIRTY THREE MILLION --
IF YOU EXCLUDE YOU SEE PASS AND
IF WE INCLUDE THE INCREASE THE
UC PASSED CENTER THE BUDGET WAS
DECREASED BY ABOUT FOURTEEN
MILLION -- THIS WAS PART OF A
THIRD THE THIRTY THREE MILLION
DOLLAR REDUCTION REPRESENTED
ELIMINATING ONE TIME TEMPORARY
BUDGET THAT YOU SEE -- P. USED
TO HAVE AND CREATING A VERY
SPECIFIC ACCOUNT FOR THESE
PURPOSES TO TRACK THAT -- THE
TOTAL ONE TIME BUDGET-- FOR
THESE PROJECTS HAS BEEN CUT BY
38%.
AND LASTLY USE YOUR P. ALLOCATED
FORTY MILLION DOLLARS TO
CAMPUSES.
OF FROM OUR RESERVES OF TO FUND
STUDENT HOUSING PRIORITIES
ACROSS THE SYSTEM AND UC
RIVERSIDE SCHOOL OF MEDICINE FOR
TEN MILLION DOLLARS.
THOSE WERE THAT WAS A ONE TIME
TRANSFERRED THAT WE WERE ABLE TO
DO.
ON SLIDE -- SIX YOU'LL SEE THAT
AS PART OF THE FOURTEEN MILLION
DOLLAR BUDGET REDUCTION JUST
MENTIONED.
FUNDS WERE REDIRECTED FOR
ENROLLMENT AB NINETY SEVEN THE
BUDGET ACT OF TWENTY SEVENTEEN
REQUIRED THE OFFICE OF THE
PRESIDENT LEGISLATIVE STAFF THE
LA -- DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE TO
ASSESS YOU SEE OKAY ELATED
PROGRAMS AND INITIATIVES TO
DETERMINE IF FUNDS COULD BE
REDIRECTED FOR ENROLLMENT GROWTH.
AFTER REVIEWING SIXTY THREE
PROGRAMS WITH MULTIPLE ROUNDS
INTERNAL CONSULTATION AMONG
UNIVERSITY STAKEHOLDERS.
MANY MEETINGS AMONG YOU SEE
SACRAMENTO'S STAFF
REPRESENTATIVES FROM THE
ASSEMBLY SENATE THE DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE.
AND THE SUBMISSION OF MORE THAN
ONE HUNDRED DOCUMENTS IT WAS
AGREED THAT YOU SEE -- P. WOULD
PERMANENTLY REDUCE ITS BUDGET BY
EIGHT POINT FIVE MILLION DOLLARS.
IN EIGHTEEN NINETEEN AND RE
DIRECT FIFTEEN MILLION TO
SUPPORT ENROLLMENT GROWTH AT THE
CAMPUSES FOR THE SAME FISCAL
YEAR.
ON SLIDE SEVEN YOU'LL SEE
MULTIPLE QUESTIONS REGARDING THE
APPROPRIATE ROLE OF YOU SEE --
P. THAT HAVE BEEN EXPLORED
THROUGHOUT THE REGION TO RECENT
EVALUATIONS ASSESSMENTS AN
INDEPENDENT REVIEWS.
THESE INCLUDE -- THINGS LIKE OUR
FUNCTIONS I FEW COPD PLICATA
THAT THE CAMPUS SAYS.
ARE YOU STILL BE SERVICES AND
PROGRAMS ALIGNED WITH THE
UNIVERSITY'S OVERALL MISSION OF
PUBLIC INTEREST ACADEMIC AND
RESEARCH MISSIONS.
IS USE YOUR P. APPROPRIATELY
STAFFED WHAT OUTREACH EFFORTS
HAS USED CO OP MADE SOLICIT
STAKEHOLDER INPUT ON PROGRAMS
AND SERVICES.
AND HAS THE OPTIMIZATION EFFORT
HAD AN IMPACT ON TO USE YOU'LL
BE BUDGET.
OVER THEPAST FEW YEARS U. C. O.
P. HAS IMPLEMENTED A NUMBER OF
INDEPENDENT REVIEWS. FOR OUT OF
THE FIVE REVIEWS YOU SEE LISTED
ON SLIDE -- EIGHT WERE GENERATED
AS A RESULT OF THE STATE AUDIT.
THE WHO RUN REPORT WAS
COMMISSIONED BY THE PRESIDENT SO
WE DON'T INCLUDE THAT AT THAT --
AS PART OF THAT AUDITS
REQUIREMENT A IN GENERAL THE
FINDINGS FROM THE INDEPENDENT
REVIEWS AFFIRMED THAT YOU SEE --
PEAS EXERCISING BEST PRACTICES
MEETING INDUSTRY STANDARDS AND
PERFORMING SERVICES IN A MANNER
THAT IS VALUED BY THE CAMPUSES.
THE CALIFORNIA STATE AUDITOR
RECOMMENDED REVIEWS INCLUDED THE
PRICE WATERHOUSE COOPERS AUDIT.
WHICH WAS RECOMMENDED THAT THE
REGION'S BY THE STATE AUDITOR TO
REVIEW YOU CO.
STATEMENT OF REVENUES AND
EXPENSES THE PRICE WATERHOUSE
COOPER AFFIRMS THE DATA WAS
REPRESENTED FAIRLY AND IN
ACCORDANCE WITH GENERALLY
ACCEPTED ACCOUNTING PRINCIPLES.
THE AUDITOR FELT THAT THE
BREADTH AND SCOPE OF THE PRICE
WATERHOUSE COOPERS AUDIT WAS
INSUFFICIENT AND ASKED TO
RETURNS TO IN PARK ON A REVIEW
THAT INCLUDED BUDGETING PROCESS
AND RESERVE CONTROLS.
AT WHICH POINT TO LLOYD WAS
RETAINED.
DELOITTE FOUND THAT UC OPIES
CONTROLS WERE IN FACT EFFECTIVE.
THAN CHAU BURKE AND NEVER SHANK
UNDERSTOOD UNDERTOOK A TEN
CAMPUS SURVEY AT THE REQUEST OF
THE REGION'S TO GATHER
INFORMATION FROM THE CAMPUS
PERSPECTIVES.
ON THE VALUE LEVEL OF SERVICES
PLACEMENT OF SERVICES AND
PROGRAMS UNDER THE UC ABUSE ROLE
AS A SYSTEM WIDE OFFICE.
THE REPORT WAS SHARED WITH THE
REGION'S AND A WORKING GROUP
CONSISTING OF THE PRESIDENT
CHAIR AND THREE CHANCELLOR'S
REVIEWED THE OUTCOMES OF THE
REPORT.
LITTLE REDUNDANCY WAS FOUND AND
CAMPUSES GENERALLY SUPPORTED YOU
SEE -- P. AS ADDING VALUE AND
SERVICE AND TO THE CAMPUSES AND
THE OVERALL MISSION.
SULLIVAN CUTTER WAS RETAINED TO
LOOK AT THE STAFF COMPENSATION
METHODOLOGY TO ENSURE THAT THEY
ALIGN WITH THE BEST PRACTICES.
THEIR FIRM THAT YOU SEE -- PIECE
APPROACH THE SALARY RANGE
ADJUSTMENTS FOR NON REPRESENTED
EMPLOYEES MESSED WITH THE BEST
PRACTICES AND THE BOARD OF
REGENTS ENDORSED THEIR FINDINGS.
AND YOU SEE PRESIDENT REQUESTED
A REVIEW OF WHO ROBBED MOVE DOWN
BY FOUR ON WHO RUN WAS
COMMISSIONED BY THE PRESIDENT TO
LOOK AT THE OPTIMIZATION.
AND EFFICIENCY AND PRIMARILY TO
ASSESS WHERE CERTAIN UC OP
FUNCTIONS MAY BE MOST
EFFECTIVELY PERFORMED AT OPG A
CAMPUS OR AN INDEPENDENT
LOCATION.
THE KORAN OPTIONS PRESENTED TO
THE PRESIDENT FOR ANALYZE THIS
PART OF THE UC OP RESTRUCTURING
EFFORT.
IN FEW CASES SUCH AS YOU SEE
HEALTH IN A ON OUR AND ADVISORY
COMMITTEE WAS APPOINTED BY THE
PRESIDENTAND CHARGED WITH
DETERMINING A SET OF
RECOMMENDATIONS FOR EACH
DIVISION.
BUT THE EXECUTOR BUDGET
COMMITTEE STONE ON THE NEXT
SLIDE WAS RECONVENED AS PART OF
THE CSA RECOMMENDATIONS THIS
BODY INCLUDES CAMPUS
REPRESENTATION U. C. O. P.
LEADERSHIP AND ACADEMIC SENATE.
THE EXECUTIVE BUDGET COMMITTEE
PROVIDES RECOMMENDATIONS THE
PRESIDENT ON THE U. C. O. P.
ANNUAL BUDGET.
THE EXECUTIVE BUDGET COMMITTEE
HAS CONVENED ON FIFTEEN FIFTEEN
DIFFERENT OCCASIONS TO DATE.
ON THREE OF THESE OCCASIONS THEY
HOLD ALL DAY MEETINGS TO DO DEEP
DIVES TO EACH OF THE U. C. O. P.
DIVISIONS.
THIS FORMED A SOLID BASIS OF
UNDERSTANDING OF OF THE OVERALL
YOU SEE HOPE YOU'RE GONNA
STATION WHICH WAS HELPFUL IN
GUIDING THEIR DISCUSSION AND
RECOMMENDATIONS THROUGH THE
NINETEEN TWENTY BUDGET PROCESS.
YOU SEE -- PIAS UNDERGONE
SEVERAL SIGNIFICANT
ORGANIZATIONAL ASSESSMENT SINCE
TWENTY SEVENTEEN HAVE YOU WRAP
IT UP WE'RE WAITING FOR THE
HONOR.
TO PROCEED TO ALL RIGHT -- I
THINK WHAT I JUST WANT TO SAY --
IN CONCLUSION IS THAT -- WE HAVE
SPENT A TREMENDOUS AMOUNT OF
TIME AND EFFORT -- TO INCREASE
OUR TRANSPARENCY AT THIS POINT
WE DO FEEL THAT THERE'S A LOT
MORE PUBLIC INFORMATION ABOUT
THE UC OP BUDGET AND WE ARE
DOING FAR MORE CONSULTING WITH
OUR CAMPUSES WITH SENIOR
LEADERSHIP AND RECEIVING MORE
INPUT ON WHAT THE UC OP BUDGETS
TO THANK YOU LINE ALLOW OUR
STATE.
AUDITOR THANK YOU I'M COME BACK
AND VISIT WITH US.
WE STARTED THIS DISCUSSION TWO
YEARS AGO AND APPRECIATE -- YOUR
WORK THEN IT IT HELPED -- GUY
THIS LAST TWO YEARS WITH OUR
BUDGET ACTIONS AND FRANKLY.
OKAY WE WERE SUCCESSFUL IN
REDIRECTING SOME OF THOSE
RESOURCES TO STUDENTS AND
ROLLING MORE CALIFORNIANS OUR
NUMBER ONE PRIORITY.
SO -- WITH THAT WOULD ALLOW YOU
AND THEY SAID HONOR TEAM TO GIVE
US AN UPDATE ON PERSPECTIVE ON
THE BUDGETING AND PRACTICES OF
THE OFFICE THE PRESIDENT.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE FOR THE
RECORD MY NAME IS KATIE CARTING
AS AND I AM A SENIOR AUDITOR THE
CALIFORNIA STATE AUDITOR'S
OFFICE I WAS A SUPERVISOR ON THE
ORIGINAL APRIL TWENTY SEVENTEEN
ON IT AND HAVE CONTINUED TO WORK
ON OUR FOLLOW UP EFFORTS.
I'M GOING TO SUMMARIZE THE
STATUS IF YOU SEE A PEACE
IMPLEMENTATION OF OUR
RECOMMENDATIONS IN THE
RECOMMENDATIONS THAT ARE DUE
APRIL.
TWENTY NINETEEN SO YOU SEE A P.
JUST SUBMITTED THEIR RESPONSES
TO THE TWENTY NINETEEN
RECOMMENDATIONS TO US LAST
THURSDAY SO WE'RE CURRENTLY AND
WORKING ON ASSESSING THEIR
IMPLEMENTATION AS OF TODAY.
SORANA FOR FOUND MANY ISSUES
THAT YOU SEE -- P. INCLUDING A
HUNDRED SEVENTY FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS AN UNDISCLOSED
RESTRICTING DISCRETIONARY
RESERVES.
THE OPPORTUNITY FOR YOU SEE --
PETER REALIZE SAVINGS BY
ADJUSTING COMPENSATION PAID IT
STAFF AND THE ABSENCE OF A
COMPREHENSIVE LIST OF SYSTEM
WIDE INITIATIVES. TO ADDRESS
THESE ISSUES ARE ON IT INCLUDED
A THREE YEAR PLAN MADE UP OF
THIRTY THREE RECOMMENDATIONS FOR
YOU SEE -- PETE OVER ALL ITS
OPERATIONS.
THE FIRST YEAR WE WANTED YOU SEE --
P. TO FOCUS ON EVALUATING ITS
CURRENT PRIORITIES AND DECISIONS
THE SECOND YEAR WE ASKED YOU SEE --
**** AT TARGETS AND IMPLEMENT
POLICIES AND THE THIRTY YEAR
WHICH WOULD BE APRIL TWENTY
TWENTY WE WANT YOU SEE -- P. TO
MEET THOSE TARGETS AND EVALUATE
ITS NEW POLICIES. FOR THE YEAR
ONE RECOMMEND RECOMMENDATIONS
YOU SEE OPS FULLY IMPLEMENTED
EIGHT OF THE TEN THE FULLY
IMPLEMENTED RECOMMENDATIONS
INCLUDED YOU SEE OKAY REVIEWING
RESTRICTIONS IN COMMITMENTS ON
ITS FUNDS.
DEVELOPING A METHOD FOR WEIGHING
COMPARABLE PUBLIC AND PRIVATE
SECTOR PAY DATA WHEN IT SETTING
IT SALARIES.
AND DEVELOPING A COMPREHENSIVE
LIST OF SYSTEM WIDE INITIATIVES.
HOWEVER AS OF FEBRUARY TWENTY
NINETEEN TWO OF OUR MOST
IMPORTANT RECOMMENDATIONS REMAIN
PARTIALLY IMPLEMENTED.
SPECIFICALLY RECOMMENDED THAT TO
DETERMINE THE AMOUNT OF MONEY IT
CAN REALLOCATE TWO CAMPUSES YOU
C. O. P. NEEDED TO DEVELOPERS
ARE POLICIES THAT GOVERN HOW
LARGE IT'S RESERVE SHOULD BE.
AND THE PURPOSE FOR WHICH THEY
CAN BE USED.
AS OF OUR MOST RECENT FOLLOW UP
PUBLISHED ON FEBRUARY TWENTY
NINETEEN WE DETERMINED YOU SEE
IF YOU COULD NOT PROVIDE
POLICIES FOR PROGRAM SPECIFIC
RESERVES TOTALING A HUNDRED
TWENTY TWO MILLION DOLLARS.
WE ALSO CONCLUDED THAT IN THE
ABSENCE OF SUFFICIENT RESERVE
POLICIES -- THAT IDENTIFIED FOR
EXAMPLE HOW TO HANDLE EXCESS
FUND BALANCES YOU SEE
STAKEHOLDERS WOULD FIND IT
DIFFICULT TO DETERMINE WHAT
PORTION OF FUND BALANCES COULD
POTENTIALLY BE REALLOCATED THE
CAMPUSES.
LAST WEEK YOU SEE A PIECE
AMENDED GUIDELINES RELATED TO
ITS RESERVES THAT WERE CURRENTLY
ASSESSING.
ANOTHER RECOMMENDATION DUE IN
APRIL TWENTY EIGHTEEN REQUIRED
YOU SEE -- PETE IMPLEMENTOR
RECOMMENDED ONE PAGE BUDGET
PRESENTATION BUT WE HAVE RATED
THIS RECOMMENDATION IS PARTIALLY
IMPLEMENTED BECAUSE THE BUDGET
PRESENTATION CONTINUES TO LACKS
SUFFICIENT TRANSPARENCY.
ESPECIALLY AROUND YOU SEE --
PEAS OR SERVICE. TO ME THE
INTENT OF OUR RECOMMENDATION
WHICH IS THE CLEARLY DISPLAY THE
AMOUNT OF SURPLUS FUNDS IT HAS
AT THE END OF EACH YEAR IF WE
BELIEVE THE FUND BALANCES IN
RESERVES NEED TO BE PRESENTED ON
THE SAME SCHEDULE AS REVENUES
AND EXPENDITURES.
WE ALSO REMAIN CONCERNED THAT
THE TIMING OF YOU SEE A PIECE
BUDGET WHICH THE REGION'S WILL
PROVE IN A COUPLE OF WEEKS
HINDERS THE STATE BUDGET PROCESS.
FOR YOUR TWO RECOMMENDATIONS YOU
SEE OF HE IS FULLY IMPLEMENTED
THREE OF THE ELEVEN
RECOMMENDATIONS THAT WE MADE.
THIS IMPLEMENTED BEST PRACTICES
FOR BUDGETING BY DEVELOPING A
ROBUST INTERNAL BUDGET MANUAL.
IT'S PUBLISHED ITS REVIEW OF
THUNDERSTRUCK SHINS AND
COMMITMENTS AND IS ALSO
PUBLISHES RESULTS OF ITS REVIEW
OF SYSTEM WIDE INITIATIVES.
THERE MANY RECOMMENDATIONS THAT
YOU SEE A P. RESPONDED TO TO US
LAST WEEK INCLUDE BUDGETING
RECOMMENDATIONS RELATED TO
PRESENTING A COMPREHENSIVE
BUDGET TO THE REGION'S THE
LEGISLATURE AND THE PUBLIC.
STAFFING RECOMMENDATIONS RELATED
TO ADJUSTING IT SALARIES
ACCORDING TO PUBLIC AND PRIVATE
SECTOR COMPARISON RESULTS
NEARING ITS SALARY RANGES AND
DEVELOPING A WORK FORCE PLAN.
FINALLY WE HAVE ALSO ASKED YOU
SEE A P. TO ESTABLISH SPENDING
TARGETS FOR SYSTEM WIDE
INITIATIVES AND ADMINISTRATIVE
COSTS AS WELL AS TO CREATE A
PLAN FOR REALLOCATING FUNDS THAT
IT SAVES. TWO CAMPUSES AS IT
REDUCES ITS COSTS.
THESE RECOMMENDATIONS WILL DELVE
INTO THE FINAL YEAR OF OUR THREE
YEAR PLAN WHICH WILL REQUIRE YOU
SEE YOU SEE A P. TO EVALUATE ITS
PRACTICES.
REALLOCATE FUNDS TO CAMPUSES AND
PUBLICLY REPORT ON ITS PROGRESS.
WE RECOGNIZE YOU SEE -- PEAS
RESOURCE INVESTMENT IN PROGRESS
THUS FAR IN IMPLEMENTING OUR
RECOMMENDATIONS BY IMPROVING ITS
FISCAL STAFFING AND SYSTEM WIDE
INITIATIVE PROCESS SEES.
HOWEVER YOU SEE A P. STILL NEEDS
TO FULLY IMPLEMENT SEVERAL KEY
RECOMMENDATIONS TO SUCCESSFULLY
ADDRESS THE CONCERNS THAT WE
IDENTIFIED IN OUR REPORT.
I'M HAPPY TO TAKE ANY QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU I I GUESS THE THE MAIN
QUESTION I ASK IS THAT CAN YOU
GO OVER AGAIN THE NUMBER YOU
THROUGHOUT HUNDRED AND TWENTY
TWO MILLION SO.
OUT THERE ARE A LOT OF
RECOMMENDATIONS AND INSIGHT FROM
THE AUDIT TWO YEARS AGO BUT ONE
LARGEST TAKEAWAYS FROM OUR
COMMITTEE WAS.
THEIR RESOURCES AT THE OFFICE
THE PRESIDENT WHILE THEY YOU
KNOW MAY LOOK GOOD ON PAPER.
THEY COULD BE BETTER UTILIZED ON
CAMPUS AS WE HEARD EARLIER THAT
STUDENTS HAVE ENOUGH FOOD.
HOMELESS SLEEPING IN CARS SO
THOSE ARE PRIOR IS IT AS WELL AS
ALWAYS OUR TOP ONE ROLLING MORE
CALIFORNIANS SO -- WHAT WHAT IS
YOUR CONCLUSION THERE AGAIN AS
FAR AS WHAT WE THINK IS --
DISCRETIONARY AND AVAILABLE AT
THE OFFICE THE PRESIDENT THAT
ONE TWENTY TWO MILLION NUMBER.
SEVEN ONE HUNDRED TWENTY TWO
MILLION IS RESERVES THAT YOU SEE
A P. DIDN'T HAVE POLICIES FOR AS
OF FEBRUARY -- TWENTY NINETEEN
THE AMOUNT THAT WE NEED AND WE
DISCUSS THIS WITH YOU SEE OKAY
EXTENSIVELY AS OF FEBRUARY
TWENTY NINETEEN THE AMOUNT THAT
THEY SAW AS POTENTIALLY
AVAILABLE FOR REALLOCATION WAS
NINE POINT SEVEN MILLION.
AND THAT'S DISCRETIONARY MONEY
THAT YOU SEE -- HE WAS HOLDING
FOR ITS OWN PURPOSES.
THAT WAS FOR THEIR INITIATIVE
AND ONE TWENTY TWO WAS.
AN OVERALL.
CORRECT MOST OF THOSE ARE
PROGRAM SPECIFIC RESERVES SO --
THEY'RE NOT RESTRICTED LEGALLY
UNDER ANY TYPE OF STATE LAW YOUR
ACCOUNTING STANDARD BUT THEY'RE
RESTRICTED FOR PURPOSES USUALLY
DESIGNATED BY THE REGENTS AND
AGAIN THERE'S ONGOING MONEY
EVERY YEAR FOR THESE INITIATIVES
BUT THIS IS KIND.
OF SPARE CHANGE EVERY YEAR ADDED
UP.
CORRECT AND THE EIGHT DAYS SO
FAR IT'S BEEN INTERESTING AT AT
THE TIME OF THE ON A WE SAW A
HUNDRED AND SEVENTY FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS IN FUND BALANCES IN
RESERVES -- AS OF FEBRUARY
TWENTY NINETEEN THAT NUMBER WAS
UP AT THREE HUNDRED TWENTY ONE
MILLION AND PART OF THAT IS THAT
YOU CO OP HAS GONE THROUGH CLEAN
UP ITS ACCOUNTS IDENTIFIED
ADDITIONAL MONEY AND FUND
BALANCES.
SO IT'S NOT A COMPLETE APPLES TO
APPLES COMPARISON TO LOOK AT
THOSE TWO NUMBERS BUT OUR OUR
CONCERN THAT WE EXPRESS IN
FEBRUARY TWENTY EIGHTEEN IS THAT
YOU SEE -- P. NEED AND BETTER
POLICIES AROUND ENSURING THAT
ITS RESERVES OR APPROPRIATE.
YES THE BEG THE QUESTION YOU
KNOW WHY CAN'T WE USE THOSE
MONIES FOR OTHER UC PRIORITIES.
DEFERRED MAINTENANCE AT UC
BERKELEY -- ONE TIME MONEY FOR
STUDENT NEEDS AND AND HUNGER AND
HOMELESSNESS EMERGENCY GRANTS
AND SO -- YOU SEE.
SOME OF THE RESERVES ARE NEEDED
BECAUSE OF THE SIZE OF THE
PROGRAMS THAT THEY SUPPORT YOU
HAVE TO HAVE -- IT'S COMMON TO
HAVE OF EXPRESSLY FOR REVOLVING
FUNDS THAT -- IT'S COMMON TO
HAVE.
RESERVES THAT CAN BE UTILIZED
THROUGHOUT THE YEAR IF REVENUES
ARE NOT COMING IN AT THE PACE
STUFF WAS ANTICIPATED -- I'M NOT
OF FAMILIAR WITH THE NINE
MILLION DOLLARS -- SPECIFICALLY
REFERENCED BY THE AUDITOR AND I
WILL HAVE TO GET MORE
INFORMATION FOR YOU ON THAT.
YEAH.
WELL IT JUST SEEMS THAT -- WE
HAD THIS ISSUE TWO YEARS AGO.
AND THE ARGUMENT WAS -- NO THOSE
ARE ALL ACCOUNTED FOR THOSE ARE
ALL NEEDED WORK WE REALLY NOT
GOING TO HAVE THOSE RESERVES AND
TWO YEARS LATER WE COME BACK AND
WE STILL HAVE.
THAT AND YOU KNOW.
THE NOTION THAT WE NEEDED IN
CASE MONIES DON'T COME THROUGH A
CERTAIN TIME KIND OF FAR THAT
FIND THAT HARD TO BELIEVE THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA OFFICE
THE PRESIDENT BUDGET IS.
CLOSE TO BILLION DOLLARS RIGHT.
TWO HUNDRED EIGHT HUNDRED
SOMETHING MILLION DOLLARS OF THE
TOTAL TWENTY SIX BILLION OUR
ENTERPRISE AND SO.
IT'S LIKE YOU'RE RUNNING A CASH
FREE TIME -- SO JUST BEGS THE
QUESTION AS FAR AS WHETHER OR
NOT THESE PRIORITIES ARE NUMBER
ONE THE RIGHT PRIORITIES. FOR
OTHER NEEDS THROUGHOUT.
THE UC SYSTEM.
AND NUMBER TWO EVEN IF THEY ARE
THE RIGHT PRIORITIES.
THESE RESERVES ARE STILL IN
PLACE.
WE WE HAVE GONE THROUGH THE
RESERVES AND WE DID IDENTIFY
FORTY MILLION DOLLARS THAT WE
THOUGHT.
COULD REASONABLY BE TRANSFERRED
WITHOUT JEOPARDIZING PROGRAMS --
AND THOSE TRANSFERS ALREADY TOOK
PLACE WE ARE TALKING ABOUT ONE
TIME MONEY HERE I DO ONE GRAMS A
SO YESDOT -- SO IN TERMS OF
USING THAT FOR ENROLLMENT THE
DIFFICULTY THERE ABOUT INSANE I
SAID.
STUDENT NEEDS DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE.
I'LL HAVE TO GET BACK TO YOU ON
THE NINE MILLION SORRY.
DON'T HAVE THERE ARE THERE ARE
ONGOING PROGRAMS IN THE OFFICE
THE PRESIDENT MISTER TIPS WHICH
WE'VE ALWAYS -- INQUIRE WHETHER
OR NOT THOSE ONGOING PROGRAMS
ARE WORTHY WHEN YOU.
LOOK AT THE TRADE OFFS FOR
ENROLLMENT IF YOU ASK MARKETS MY
CONSTITUENTS.
YOU KNOW THIS WEEK IN THE LITTLE
LEAGUE FIELD HEY THIS UNIVERSITY
OF CALIFORNIA INITIATIVE THE
OFFICE THE PRESIDENT IS DOING X.
Y. Z..
AND AND I GUESS -- BUT NONE OF
THE KIDS IN MY NEIGHBORHOOD CUT
IN THE UC THIS YEAR AND GETTING
EXPAND ROMAN BYE.
BYE ONE ADDITIONAL SLOT SO.
THOSE ARE TRADE OFFS WE HAVE TO
CONTINUE TO ADDRESS.
MR MESSAGING YES I I WANTED TO
LITTLE.
CLARIFICATION THE ARMS OF THE
HUNDRED TWENTY FIVE MILLION.
OR SO THAT YOU IDENTIFIED THAT
DIDN'T HAVE THE THE POLICIES FOR
THE RESERVES IT WAS AT YOUR
THAT'S CORRECT OKAY SO WHAT
EXACTLY DO YOU MEAN MY POLICIES.
SO OUR RECOMMENDATION WAS THAT
YOU SEE A P. ESTABLISH POLICIES
GUIDING WHAT'S THE PURPOSE OF
THE RESERVE LOOKING AT AND WHAT
SOME ACCEPTABLE MINIMUM AND
MAXIMUM FOR THOSE RESERVES ON
WHAT HAPPENS IN THE CASE THAT
THERE'S ACCESS -- RESERVES SO SO
THERE WASN'T EVEN.
A AND IDENTIFIED PURPOSE FOR A
HUNDRED TWENTY FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS IN RESERVES.
NOT NOW WITHIN A POLICIES SO
SOME OF THOSE PROGRAMS WOULD
HAVE A PURPOSE FOR THE PROGRAM
BUT NOT IN TERMS OF THE RESERVE
WHAT WHAT OKAY SO THAT SAYS
RESERVE IT BE A PURPOSE
IDENTIFIED PURPOSE FOR THE
PROGRAM.
BUT NOT FOR THE RESERVE CORRECT
Là BUT PRESUMABLY IT WAS A
RESERVE FOR THE PROGRAM.
AND SO THE IT WAS IT WAS A
RESERVE TO BE INTENDED FOR THE
PURPOSES OF THE PROGRAM CORRECT
AND I THINK WHAT WE WERE LOOKING
FOR FROM YOU SEE -- P. WAS MORE
SPECIFICITY AROUND WHAT'S THE
APPROPRIATE AMOUNT FOR THIS
RESERVE OKAY AND IF YOUR IF
YOU'RE KEEPING A RESERVE -- WHEN
WOULD YOU IDENTIFY WHEN THERE'S
TOO MUCH MONEY IN THAT RESERVE
THAT COULD POTENTIALLY BE
REALLOCATED TO A DIFFERENT
PROGRAM SORRY SO SO AGAIN WE'RE
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT?
THEIR THAT THERE NEEDS TO BE A
SOME MORE CLARITY IN TERMS OF
THE THE THE THE THE ACCOUNTING
OF OF THE OF THE FUNDS THAT'S
BUT IN TERMS OF THE IT THERE IN
EACH.
THE DOLLAR OF THOSE HUNDRED
TWENTY FIVE BILLION IN RESERVES
HAD A IDENTIFIED PURPOSE FOR
PROGRAM.
THEY WERE TIED DIRECTLY TO THE
PROGRAM YES.
SO IT'S NOT.
LIKE IT WAS A ON IDENTIFIED
SLUSH FUND.
BUT HOW IT WORKS WE'RE NOT
CALLING IT THAT BUT IT IS WHAT
IT IS IT'S RESERVE IT
POTENTIALLY COULD STAY THERE OR
BE UTILIZED FOR OTHER SURE YOU
SEE NEEDS ON A ONE TIME.
ON A ONE TIME BASIS -- SIR CAN I
POINT OUT THAT OUR REGION STOOD
ADOPT A POLICY ON JANUARY TWENTY
FOUR TWENTY EIGHTEEN ON OUR
RESERVES -- THAT REQUIRES --
THAT THE RESERVES NOT EXCEED
THREE POINT 5% OF THE TOTAL
FUNDS THAT IN THE PROGRAMS
WITHOUT COMING BACK TO THE
REGION'S THEM.
WHEN WHAT'S THE?
PERCENTAGE HERE WITH THE ONE
TWENTY TWO NINE I'M NOT CERTAIN.
I SEEMS PROBABLY MORE THAN.
THREE POINT 5% RIGHT -- I'M
POSSIBLY NOT I DON'T KNOW.
THE WHOLE OFFICE OF THE
PRESIDENT BUDGETS EIGHT HUNDRED
MILLION SIR YOUR INITIATIVES.
I'LL HAVE TO GET BACK TO YOU ON
THAT YEAH MATH DOESN'T ADD UP.
OKAY MIXTURE THIS MESSAGE YEP
THANK YOU -- DIE I WANTED -- TO
DRILL DOWN A LITTLE BIT MORE IN
TERMS OF THE THE CENTRAL OF
ADMINISTRATIVE SERVICES PIE
CHART THAT YOU PROVIDE.
LIKE LIKE FOR EXAMPLE. THREE
POINT ONE MILLION DOLLARS.
ANNUALLY.
IN YOUR ANNUAL BUDGET FOR THE
SECRETARY THE REGION'S.
WHAT IS THE NATURE OF THAT?
I'M SORRY CAN YOU REPEAT THE
QUESTION.
ON THE PIE CHART FOR TO SIGN ON
YOUR CHARTER SERVICES ON YOUR
CHART THERE IS A LINE ITEM THREE
POINT ONE MILLION DOLLARS FOR
SECRETARY OF THE REGION'S.
YES THAT'S THE OFFICE THAT
MANAGES THE REGENTS THAT GETS
THEM THEIR INFORMATION BOOKSTORE
TRAVEL -- MAKE CERTAIN THAT THE
PUBLICATIONS FOLLOW ALL THE
PROPER GUIDELINES THAT'S WHERE
OUR AUDIT IMPLEMENTATION ALSO.
A LOT OF OUR SYSTEM WIDE --
AUDIT COMPLIANCE IS RUN OUT OF
IN ORDER TO BE INDEPENDENT FROM
THE REST OF THE OFFICE OF THE
PRESIDENT.
HOW MANY HOW MANY EMPLOYEES ARE
WE TALKING ABOUT IN TERMS OF THE
SECRETARY THE REASONS?
I DO NOT KNOW I I DON'T HAVE IN
FRONT OF ME HOW MANY EMPLOYEES
ARE IN THE IMMEDIATE OFFICE OF
THE REGIONS.
THE PRESIDENT'S EXECUTIVE OFFICE
HAS A FOUR POINT FOUR FIVE OF
FOUR POINT FOUR MILLION DOLLAR
ANNUAL BUDGET.
THAT'S CORRECT AND AND AND WHAT
WHAT IS THE NATURE OF THAT -- TO
THAT IS T. ANALYSTS WHO ARE
SUPPORTING THE PRESIDENT WHO ARE
HELPING TO RUN THE WHO.
WORK ON THOSE PROGRAMS THAT THE
SYSTEM WIDE OFFICES UNDERTAKING
THAT WILL THEN HAND OFF -- TO
CAMPUSES USUALLY -- THE OFFICE
OF THE PRESIDENT FOR EXAMPLE --
WAS THE ONE THAT GENERATED ARE
UNDOCUMENTED STUDENTS CENTERS.
AND THEY DID A LOT OF THAT
ANALYSIS AND GOT WORKED WITH THE
CAMPUS IS TO GET THEM STARTED --
SO THERE SEVERAL ANALYSTS THERE
WHO WORK ON HIGH PRIORITY SYSTEM
WIDE ISSUES THAT ARE GETTING
LAUNCHED -- AND THEY SUPPORT THE
PRESIDENT.
AND THEN SIX POINT SEVEN MILLION
DOLLARS ANNUALLY FOR ETHICS AND
COMPLIANCE.
BUT WHAT IS THAT.
I WILL GET YOU INFORMATION ON
THE MISSION STATEMENT SOME
PURPOSES OF EACH OF THESE
OFFICES.
I DON'T HAVE THE MISSION
STATEMENTS AND EXACT -- TASKS OF
EACH OFFICE IN FRONT OF ME.
THE THIRTY FIVE MILLION DOLLARS
IN INVESTMENTS IS THAT FOR THE
PENSION -- YES THAT'S CORRECT
THAT'S TO RUN THE UC PENSION AND
ALSO -- ARE YOU SEEN DOWN MEANT.
AND THEN FIFTY ONE POINT FIVE
FOR ACADEMIC AFFAIRS WITH THE
YOU KNOW THE GENERAL NATURE OF
THAT.
OUR ACADEMIC AFFAIRS IS WHERE WE
DO THE IT'S WHERE WE HAVE OUR
APPLICATIONS STUDENT
APPLICATIONS THAT THEY DO
ACADEMIC POLICY FOR THE
UNIVERSITY THE ACADEMIC SENATE
THIS LOCATED THERE ARE SYSTEM
WIDE ACADEMIC SENATE -- AND THEY
THEY WORK ON A MULTITUDE OF THE
UNIVERSITY'S ACADEMIC
[inaudible]
MISSION -- OKAY I YEAH I I I
WOULD I WOULD LIKE MORE.
DETAILED.
INFORMATION ON I I APOLOGIZE I'M
NOT WELL VERSED IN THIS THE THE
INDIVIDUALS WHO USUALLY WORK ON
THIS BUDGET ARE -- WHAT FOR NOT
ABLE TO ATTEND TODAY OKAY?
NUMBER I WILL BRING EXPERTS BY
TO SPEAK WITH YOU THANK YOU.
THANK YOU AND THEN THERE'S GOING
TO BE FOLLOW UP FROM YOU AFTER
YOU DO THE AS FAR AS THE THAT.
THEIR TRADITIONAL.
A FOLLOW UP FROM THE AUDIT
PROCESS FOR IS IT.
A FEW YEARS I THINK WE ALERTED
DISARRAY YEAH THAT'S CORRECT SO
THE APRIL TWENTY NINETEEN
ASSESSMENT WE'RE WORKING ON
RIGHT NOW -- I CAN LET.
THE THE COMMITTEE KNOW WHEN
WE'RE DONE WITH THAT IS THAT THE
FINAL ASSESSMENT -- WE'RE
ANTICIPATING AT LEAST ONE
ADDITIONAL ASSESSMENT TO LOOK
INTO THE APRIL TWENTY TWENTY
RECOMMENDATIONS NEXT YEAR.
FINAL OKAY ONE MORE FROM YOU AND
SO WHAT'S THE PROCESS WHEN YOU
DO THIS REVIEW HE SENT A REPORT
OUT TO LEGISLATURE WITH THE
FINDINGS IN -- SO WE PUBLISH IT
ONLINE AND THERE'S ANOTHER
REPORT THAT COMES ON JANUARY OF
EVERY YEAR THAT.
SUMMARIZES ARE ALL OF THE
ASSESSMENTS FOR ALL THE ON IT SO
WE DO.
BUT IT'LL BE PUBLISHED ONLINE
MUCH SOONER THAN THAT OKAY THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU THANK YOU FOR THE
INFORMATION AND WE WILL CONSIDER
THIS AS WE FINALIZE OUR TWENTY
NINETEEN TWENTY TWENTY BUDGET
FOR THE UC.
ISSUE NUMBER EIGHT WE ARE GOING
TO DISCUSSING THE UC.
PATH PROJECT
[inaudible]
YEAH.
IS ONE OF THE OKAY.
GOOD EVENING I APPRECIATE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO LET THE TRAFFIC
THAN OUT EVEN FURTHER -- THIS
EVENING UP TODAY'S UPDATE IS
VERY SHORT AND I APPRECIATE THE
OPPORTUNITY -- TO UP BRING YOU
UP TO SPEED BASED ON THE
BRIEFING WE PROVIDED LAST YEAR.
SLIDE TO THIS DECK IS JUST A
IT'S A KIND OF A CENTERING POINT
FOR WHAT YOU SEE PATH IS.
THE NAME ITSELF CONTAINS AN
ACRONYM OF ITS COMPONENT PARTS
SO IT'S A SYSTEM THAT PROVIDES
FOR PAYROLL.
ACADEMIC PERSONNEL TIME KEEPING
AN HR.
THROUGH A SHARED SERVICES CENTER
IN RIVERSIDE CALIFORNIA --
PROVIDING ULTIMATELY.
PAYROLL H. R. BENEFITS
ADMINISTRATION SERVICES FOR ALL
TWO HUNDRED TWENTY THOUSAND YOU
SEE EMPLOYEES -- IF YOU LOOK AT
SLIDE THREE IN THE DECK -- THIS
REALLY SHOWS OUR PROGRESS LAST
YEAR WHEN I WAS HERE WE HAD JUST
OVER SIXTEEN THOUSAND EMPLOYEES.
WHO HAD TRANSITION TO UC PATH --
AS OF MARCH OF THIS YEAR WE HAVE
ADDED -- PROXIMATE LEE SEVENTY
THOUSAND ADDITIONAL POINTS ARE
EIGHTY THOUSAND DIGITAL BOYS
WERE NOW JUST OVER A HUNDRED
THOUSAND EMPLOYEES SERVE BY YOU
SEE PATH.
ULTIMATELY THE TARGET IS ALL TWO
HUNDRED THIRTY THOUSAND YOU SEE
EMPLOYEES.
THAT SECOND SLIDE ALSO THEN
DEMONSTRATES THE REMAINING
DEPLOYMENTS -- BETWEEN NOW AND
THE TIME WE FINISH THE
DEPLOYMENT PART OF THIS
INITIATIVE -- IN IN THOSE WE
HAVE FOUR REMAINING DEPLOYMENTS
WILL BRING DAVIS IN THE AG AND
NATURAL RESOURCES PROGRAM LIVE
THIS FALL -- WITH AN OCTOBER
FIRST PAYCHECK.
AND THEN THE REMAINING LOCATIONS
ARE INTENT IS TO HAVE ALL OF
THEM READY. TO TO MOVE TO YOU
SEE PASSED BY DECEMBER.
BUT TO SPREAD OUT THE
DEPLOYMENTS -- IN AN EFFORT TO
SMOOTH THE TRANSITION FOR THOSE
EMPLOYEES WORKING WITH THE UC
PATH CENTER.
WE'VE HAD AN OPPORTUNITY TO
LEARN QUITE A BIT AS WE'VE GONE
THROUGH THIS PROJECT -- AND ONE
OF THE FACTORS THAT ADDS THE
HIGHEST VALUE AND QUALITY.
OF FOR CAMPUS MOVING TO YOU SEE
PATH IS -- DIMINISHING THE SIZE
OF THE DEPLOYMENT POPULATION SO
YOU SEE FOR REMAINING
DEPLOYMENTS.
THOSE ARE ALL AT SMALLER
POPULATIONS THAN WE HAD
ORIGINALLY PROJECTED OF THE
FINAL DEPLOYMENT BEING IN APRIL
OF TWENTY TWENTY CELESTIN YOU'RE
FROM NOW ARE ARE PROJECT -- ARE
PROJECTED IN DATE -- WILL HAVE
OCCURRED -- ALONG THE WAY --
WE'VE HAD SOME CHALLENGES AND
SPECIFICALLY.
YOU HAVE HEARD ABOUT SOME OF OUR
CHALLENGES WITH STUDENT PAY AND
I DON'T WANT TO SPEND A LITTLE
TIME ON THIS NEXT SLIDE --
TALKING TO WHAT -- THOSE ISSUES
INVOLVED.
AS WE'VE DEPLOYED IF IF YOU LOOK
AT THE EARLY DEPLOYMENTS WE
PICKED SMALLER CAMPUSES WITH
RELATIVELY LESS COMPLEX PAYROLL
POPULATIONS -- BECAUSE WE WERE
ROLLING OUT NEW SOFTWARE -- WE
WANT TO WORK WITH SMALLER
CAMPUSES TO WORK OUT ISSUES.
THE MERCED IN RIVERSIDE
DEPLOYMENT IN DECEMBER OF TWO
THOUSAND SEVENTEEN BY ALL
ACCOUNTS WAS SUCCESSFUL BUT OVER
TIME WE DISCOVERED WE HAD A
NUMBER OF SMALL.
I DEFECTS THAT IMPACTED GRADUATE
STUDENTS IN PARTICULAR -- AS IT
RELATED TO THEIR FIKE
ELIGIBILITY AND PER YEAR EARLIER
CONVERSATIONS THIS EVENING --
GRADUATE STUDENTS IN PARTICULAR
ARE AMONG THE MOST COMPLEX --
EMPLOYEE PAY SITUATIONS THAT WE
HAVE TO MANAGING THE UNIVERSITY.
GRAD STUDENTS HAVE UP MULTIPLE
APPOINTMENTS THAT THE KERRY
SIMULTANEOUSLY THOSE
APPOINTMENTS CAN BE A
COMBINATION OF BI WEEKLY AND
MONTHLY JOBS -- THOSE KINDS OF
PACE CYCLES GENERATE DIFFERENT
KINDS OF DEDUCTION REQUIREMENTS.
AND THEY CHANGE JOBS MORE OFTEN
THAN ANY YOU SEE EMPLOY THEY CAN
CHANGE JOBS MULTIPLE TIMES
DURING THE TERM.
UP SO THEY ALL OF THOSE CHANGES --
TEND TO COMBINE TO CREATE -- A
PROCEDURAL -- CHALLENGES FOR THE
UNIVERSITY TO MANAGE -- AT A
100% ERROR FREE RATE -- BUT WE
DID DISCOVER SYSTEM DEFECTS
EARLY ON THOSE WERE ALL FIXED BY
AUGUST OF TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN
ALONG THE WAY WE BEGAN TO WORK
MORE CLOSELY WITH THE GRADUATE
STUDENT.
POPULATIONS -- BECAUSE WE FOUND
THE CAMPUSES WERE TREATING THEM
AS REGULAR STAFF EMPLOYEES IN
GRADUATE STUDENTS HAVE VERY
UNIQUE.
CIRCUMSTANCES AND THEY'VE HAD
TYPICALLY NON -- ADMINISTRATIVE
PATHWAYS TO RESOLVE PAY PROBLEMS
WHEN THEY ARISE SO A GRAD
STUDENT FOR EXAMPLE THE CENTER
OF THEIR UNIVERSE IS THERE
DEPARTMENT.
BUT A TYPICAL EMPLOY WOULD GO TO
PAYROLL DEPARTMENT IF THEY HAD A
PAY PROBLEM GRADUATE STUDENTS GO
TO THEIR HOME DEPARTMENT SO
WE'VE HAD TO FIGURE OUT WAYS.
TO PROVIDE BETTER SUPPORT
SERVICES AND BETTER
COMMUNICATION WITH THOSE
DEPARTMENTS SO THAT IF AND WHEN
A STUDENT HAS A PAY PROBLEM.
WE CAN GET IT RESOLVED MORE
QUICKLY -- AND THEY'RE PUT UNDER
LESS FINANCIAL STRESS -- WE HAD
ANOTHER DEPLOYMENT TO LOS
ANGELES AND SANTA BARBARA LAST
SEPTEMBER -- WE DIDN'T HAVE
SYSTEM PROBLEMS AT THAT POINT
BUT THE SCALE OF THAT DEPLOYMENT.
OF RESOLVE SOME PROCEDURAL
ISSUES THAT WE SINCE -- RESULT I
WOULD OBSERVE THAT WE'VE ALSO
NOW DONE A COUPLE OF THINGS TO
REALLY HELP ANYONE WHO IS A PAY
PRBLEM YOU SEE.
FIRST THING WE'VE DONE IS WE'VE
BEGUN.
ISSUING WHAT WE CALL PAY CARDS
THESE ARE PRE LOADED DEBIT CARDS
THAT ARE IMMEDIATELY AVAILABLE
TO EMPLOY IF WE FIND OUT THERE'S
A PAY PROBLEM WE CAN GET THEM
PAID THE NEXT DAY WITH A PAY
CARD THAT THEY CAN PICK UP ON
CAMPUS.
SO THEY DON'T HAVE TO WAIT FOR A
CHECK -- WE HAVE ALSO -- BEGUN --
OTHER PROCEDURES WORKING WITH
CAMPUSES IF IN EMERGENCY
SITUATIONS AN EMPLOYEE NEEDS.
AN AMOUNT OF THEIR PAY BUT NOT
THE FULL PAY TO GET TO THE NEXT
PAY PERIOD WE'VE WORKED OUT
THOSE PROCEDURES AS WELL.
AND THEN FINALLY I WOULD OBSERVE
THAT -- WE ARE WE HAVE NOW A
SMALL UNIT WITHIN THE PAST
CENTER.
THAT IS COMPLETELY DEDICATED TO
RESOLVING ANY KIND OF STUDENT
PAY ISSUE ONCE WERE AWARE OF IT
WE HAVE A TIGER TEAM -- THEY CAN
RESOLVE IT AS QUICKLY AS
POSSIBLE FOR THAT STUDENT -- THE
OTHER OF THE PROGRESS THAT I
WOULD OBSERVE IN OUR PAY IN OUR
DEPLOYMENTS.
WE DEPLOYED BERKELEY IN MARCH OF
THIS YEAR SO WE ADDED ANOTHER
ROUGHLY TWENTY FOUR THOUSAND
EMPLOYEES TO YOU SEE PATH --
THAT HAS BEEN OUR MOST EFFECTIVE
DEPLOYMENT TO DATE -- WHEREAS
WITH THE OTHER CAMPUSES WE HAD A
BIG SPIKE IN CALLS TO THE UC
PASSED CENTER -- WITH SPECIFIC
ISSUES OUR INITIAL TWO MONTHS
WORKING WITH BERKELEY -- WHO ARE
NOW ROUGHLY 2425% OF THE PERIL
POPULATION?
THEY'RE GENERATING LESS THAN 19%
OF THE CASES THAT COME INTO THE
UC PATH CENTER.
SO PROPORTIONATELY WE'RE
ACTUALLY HAVING A MUCH BETTER
SUCCESS WITH BERKELEY AND WE'VE
HAD WITH PREVIOUS DEPLOYMENTS SO
WE'RE APPLYING LESSONS LEARNED
FROM EACH OF OUR DEPLOYMENTS --
IN PARTICULAR THE STEPS WE'VE
TAKEN TO WORK WITH STUDENT
GROUPS DIRECTLY TO COMMUNICATE
THE CHANGES TO HELP THEM
UNDERSTAND HOW TO GET SUPPORT IF
THEY HAVE ISSUES.
AND TO WORK WITH DEPARTMENTS WHO
ARE DOING TRANSACTION DATA ENTRY
TO MAKE SURE THEY HAVE THE
APPROPRIATE TRAINING.
ALL OF THOSE COMBINED -- HAVE
WORKS TO IMPROVE -- OUR ABILITY
TO DELIVER STUDENT PAY
ACCURATELY AND ON TIME.
AND I SHOULD OBSERVE THAT WITHIN
THAT ACCURATELY ON TIME -- OUT
OF THE GATE WERE ROUGHLY 98299% --
AND SO WE'RE DEALING WITH A ONE
TO ONE AND A HALF PERCENT OF THE
POPULATION WHERE WE FIND.
SOME ISSUE THAT HAS TO BE
RESOLVED ROUGHLY 42405% OF THOSE
CASES ARE SIMPLY BECAUSE THE
CAMPUS HAS NOT SUBMITTED TIME
CORRECTLY.
THE THE TIME FILES FOR THEFOR
THE EMPLOYEES ON TIME OR
ACCURATELY WE HAVE TO GO BACK
RESULT THE TIME FILES ONCE WE DO
THAT -- THE PAY IS FINE.
BOB AS A FINAL STEP I WANT TO
ACKNOWLEDGE THAT -- THE STUDENT
PAY ISSUES WE HAD -- HAD
VISIBILITY WITH THE PRESIDENT
SHE HAS CONVENED A STUDENT PAY
WORKING GROUP.
THAT HAS -- AN OBLIGATION TO
DELIVER A REPORT TO HER BY JUNE
THIRTIETH OF THIS YEAR.
WITH RECOMMENDATIONS
SPECIFICALLY AROUND IMPROVING
PAY FOR STUDENTS IN THE SHORT
TERM AND BY THAT SHE MEANS.
ANY IMPROVEMENTS WE CAN MAKE IN
TIME FOR THE DAVIS AN A AND R.
DEPLOYMENT THIS FALL.
AND THEN LONGER TERM ARE THERE
POLICY ISSUES THAT THE
UNIVERSITY USES.
THAT MAKES STUDENT PAY MORE
COMPLEX THAN IT NEEDS TO BE.
AND OTHER POLICY RECOMMENDATIONS
THAT WE CAN PURSUE A TO SIMPLIFY
OR OR REDUCE THE COMPLEXITY OF
STUDENT PAY.
IN EXAMPLE I WOULD GIVE THERE IS
AROUND PAY PERIODS AND AGAIN
WITH THE GRADUATE STUDENTS WHO
HAVE COMPETING MONTHLY.
AND BI WEEKLY PAY PERIODS ONE OF
THE QUESTIONS WE HAVE TO ASK
OURSELVES.
DOES IT CONTINUE TO MAKE SENSE
TO HAVE STUDENT POSITIONS.
THAT LIVE IN TWO DIFFERENT PAY
CYCLES SHOULD WE CONSIDER
SOMETHING LIKE ALL STUDENT PLAYS
HAVE IN COMMON PAY CYCLE WHICH
WOULD REDUCE THAT COMPLEXITY.
SO THAT'S PART OF WHAT THIS
STUDENT PAY WORKING GROUP IS
LOOKING AT AND WILL DELIVER IN
THEIR REPORT TO THE PRESIDENT IN
JUNE.
OKAY.
UP IN THE NEXT SLIDE A ONE OF A
JUST QUICKLY REVIEW OUR CURRENT
YEAR -- FORECAST -- AND COMPARED
TO OUR BUDGET.
INITIALLY THE BUDGET THAT.
WAS APPROVED FOR THIS YEAR WAS
SIXTY SEVEN POINT SEVEN MILLION
DOLLARS -- AND IN THE ALLOCATION
THAT -- WHILE WE WERE PROVIDED
THERE WAS A A BASE AMOUNT OF
GENERAL FUNDS FROM THE
LEGISLATURE.
US AID A CHARGE BACK TO THE
CAMPUSES -- THROUGH A CAMPUS
ASSESSMENT FOR ANY REMAINING
EXPENSE.
OUR CURRENT FORECAST FOR THE
YEAR IS UP TO SEVENTY SIX
MILLION DOLLARS -- SO WE
SUBMITTED A BUDGET CHANGE
PROPOSAL TO DO F. R. D. O. F.
APPROVED THAT A CHANGE.
AND SO WE ARE NOW COMMUNICATING
WITH THE CAMPUS IS -- WHO WILL
BEAR THAT ADDITIONAL --
COMPONENT IN THEIR ASSESSMENT
THIS YEAR.
THAT A POINT TWO MILLION REALLY --
CENTERED AROUND THE DEBT SERVICE
AMOUNT THAT YOU SEE AT THE
BOTTOM OF THAT PAGE -- TABLE ON
SLIDE -- FIVE WE HAD PROJECTED
SOME SAVINGS FORM ARE HOSTING
COSTS FOR THE TECHNICAL SOLUTION
FOR YOU SEE PATH.
THAT DID NOT -- A MATERIALIZE
THIS YEAR.
AND THEN WITH THE LA IN SANTA
BARBARA DEPLOYMENT WE HAD SOME
ADDITIONAL STABILIZATION COSTS
WHICH ARE REALLY LABOR COSTS --
AND SO THAT'S WHAT DROVE -- THE
CHANGE FROM THE BUDGET INTO THE
FORECAST THIS YEAR -- OF AS WE
LOOK FORWARD TO THE NEXT FISCAL
YEAR -- WERE REALLY LOOKING AT
THE SAME -- OPERATING BUDGET THE
OPERATING BUDGET FOR YOU SEE
PATH IS -- PART OF WHAT'S
INCLUDED IN THE OFFICE OF THE
PRESIDENT -- BUDGET -- THAT'S
BEEN SUBMITTED -- SO THE
INFORMATION THAT'S HERE IS
REALLY -- A DUPLICATIVE OF
WHAT'S IN THE UC O. P.
PRESENTATION -- BUT IT'S HERE
JUST AS A AS A WAY OF SIGNALING
UP SMALL CHANGES IN EACH OF THE
VARIOUS LINE ITEMS HERE BUT
ROUGHLY LANDING IN THE SAME SPOT
AT THIS POINT -- THE DEBT
SERVICE -- IS SOMETHING THAT
SELL A HOLD OVER FROM OUR
PROJECT THE PROJECT WAS FUNDED
INITIALLY WITH A TWO HUNDRED
TWENTY MILLION DOLLAR BOND IT'S
A TWENTY YEAR BOND.
THE FIRST FIVE YEARS OF THAT OR
DEBT I'M SORRY ARE -- INTEREST
ONLY PAYMENTS.
AND IN YOUR FIVE WHICH WILL BE
FISCAL YEAR.
TWENTY TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO UP
THE PRINCIPAL AND INTEREST WILL
KICK IN.
FINALLY ON THIS LAST SLIDE -- IS
ACTUALLY A VIEW OF THE PROJECT
EXPENSES WHAT IT'S COST THE
UNIVERSITY. TO BRING YOU SEE
PATH INTO PRODUCTION -- OUR
OVERALL FORECAST FROM BEGINNING
TO END FOR IMPLEMENTATION OF YOU
SEE PATH.
WITH CENTRAL EXPENSES IS FIVE
HUNDRED AND FIFTY THREE POINT
TWO MILLION DOLLARS. TO DATE AS
OF CLOSE OF OF MONTH FOR MARCH
WHICH SPENT FOUR HUNDRED EIGHTY
NINE MILLION OF THAT WE HAVE
SIXTY FOUR POINT TWO REMAINING.
BETWEEN NOW IN THE THE END OF
THE NEXT FISCAL YEAR -- DRAW
YOUR ATTENTION TO THE NOTE THESE
COSTS ARE FUNDED DIRECTLY
THROUGH A CAMPUS ASSESSMENT --
THIS IS NOT AN OPERATING EXPENSE
THESE ARE CAPITALIZED EXPENSES --
SO -- IT'S HANDLED DIRECTLY
THROUGH THAT ASSESSMENT -- WE
HAVE ALSO BEEN COLLECTING THE
CAMPUS COMPONENT OF EXPENSE.
ALTHOUGH WE DO NOT EXERT DIRECT
MANAGEMENT OVERTHOSE EXPENSES
SO WE EVERY SIX MONTHS WE ASK
THE CAMPUSES TO UPDATE US ON
THEIR FORECAST EXPENDITURES IN
SUPPORTING THE LOCAL COMPONENT
OF YOU SEE PATH DEPLOYMENT --
THEY'VE REPORTED A HUNDRED AND
FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS SPENT TO
DATE -- AND BURKE A FOR CASTING
AN ADDITIONAL SEVENTY SIX POINT
EIGHT TO CLOSE OUT THE CAMPUS
COMPONENT OF THIS DEPLOYMENT.
FOR TOTAL OF TWO HUNDRED AND
TWENTY SEVEN SO MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE THAT'S
THE UPDATE ON YOU SEE PATH BE
DELIGHTED TO TAKE YOUR QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU FOR COMING BACK.
AT MY REQUEST I'M GLAD YOU
CAUGHT ME YEAH.
OF AND I THANK YOU FOR THE
UPDATE THAT I GOT -- IN
RIVERSIDE ON THE PAST -- I THINK
BACK IN DECEMBER JANUARY OF THIS
YEAR -- AND AND FOR MY
COLLEAGUES WHO ARE HERE.
I I WANT TO POINT OUT THE UC
PATH IS LOCATED -- IN RIVERSIDE.
A FEW MILES FROM THE UC OUR
CAMPUS BUT NOT ON THE CAMPUS.
AND SO IT IT IT OPERATES.
INDEPENDENTLY REALLY OF THE
CAMPUS OF UC ARE CORRECT.
BUT I DID GET TO GO TO THE
RIBBON CUTTING.
CEREMONY -- FOR FOR FIVE YEARS
AGO. SIX I THINK YEAH SIX YOUR
HONOR -- YES SIX YEARS AGO.
AND THERE'S AN IRONY ABOUT THIS
THIS PROJECT.
AND IT'S IT'S NOT A GOOD IRONY --
IF YOU LOOK HERE AT AT OUR
BACKGROUND MATERIAL ADDITION ON
ISSUE.
EIGHT THE UC PATH WAS ONE OF THE
IDEAS THAT CAME OUT OF COST
SAVINGS.
SO THAT YOU SEE PATH AND THE
IDEA OF CENTRALIZING.
OF PAYROLL FOR YOU SEE WAS SEEN
AND PROPOSED TO US AS A COST
SAVER.
A WAY OF CENTRALIZING AND SAVING
MONEY.
IN HERE ON PAGE TWENTY SEVEN IT
SAYS SEVEN HUNDRED AND FIFTY
THREE MILLION DOLLARS IN COST
SAVINGS -- AS IT WAS PRESENTED
TO US. SIX YEARS AGO.
OF CENTRALIZING PAYROLL
[inaudible]
OF BUT BUT IN AN ALSO HERE IT
SAYS THE PROJECT IS MILLIONS OF
DOLLARS COSTLIER THAN THE FIRST
ESTIMATE.
WHICH WAS A HUNDRED AND SEVENTY
MILLION SO THE DIFFERENCE
BETWEEN THE FIRST ESTIMATE.
OF A HUNDRED AND SEVENTY MILLION.
AND THE AND THE TOTAL CLASS.
TODAY FIVE HUNDRED AND FIFTY
THREE MILLION.
SO THE DIFFERENCE.
BASICALLY -- A CLOSE I DO THE
MATH IN MY HEAD.
ABOUT THREE HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS MORE.
ROUGHLY ROUGHLY.
AND NO COST SAVINGS [inaudible]
AT ALL.
RIGHT NO NO NO COST SAVINGS AT
ALL MOVING FORWARD -- IT IS THE
THE THE IRONY TO ME IS YOU KNOW
THAT THAT SOMETHING THAT WAS
SUPPOSED TO HAVE BEEN A COST
SAVER.
IS SO MUCH MORE OVER BUDGET --
WHEN IT IS OVER?
WHEN IT'S OVER AND ALL THE THE
CAMPUSES ARE BROUGHT?
ONLINE.
WILL IT SAVE ANY MONEY TO YOU
SEE.
SO THAT CAN I OFFER AN ANSWER
THAT MAY TAKE A COUPLE OF
PARAGRAPHS TO WORK THROUGH.
THE ANSWER IS OVER TIME THE
POTENTIAL EXISTS SO WHAT WE
STARTED WITH.
IN THE CURRENT ENVIRONMENT ARE
ELEVEN DIFFERENT VERSIONS OF A
PAYROLL SYSTEM THAT HAVE BEEN IN
PRODUCTION FOR FORTY YEARS.
SO ALL ELEVEN OF THOSE HAVE A
COMMON CORE OF OF DOING PAYROLL
BUT ALL ELEVEN HAVE BEEN HEAVILY
CUSTOMIZED BY THE CAMPUS IS OVER
TIME.
AND THE UNIVERSITY INCREASINGLY.
FINALLY HAD TROUBLE ACTUALLY
DELIVERING PAYROLL SO THERE IS A
RISK ASSOCIATED WITH STAYING
WHERE WE WERE -- BUT WE ALSO HAD --
INCREASING COMPLIANCE ISSUES IN
MEETING IN PARTICULAR FEDERAL --
REGULATORY OF COMPLIANCE -- YOU
SEE.
OBVIOUSLY DEPENDS SIGNIFICANTLY
ON FEDERAL RESEARCH DOLLARS FOR
PORTION OF ITS BUSINESS.
THOSE RESEARCH DOLLARS COME WITH
VERY HIGH COMPLIANCE
REQUIREMENTS INCREASINGLY YOU
SEE WAS NOT ABLE TO MEET THOSE
COMPLIANCE REQUIREMENTS SO WE
HAD TO DO SOMETHING.
I CONCUR THAT THE PROJECT WAS
OVERSOLD AT THE BEGINNING.
THAT WAS A BUSINESS DECISION BY
OTHER INDIVIDUALS IN THE
UNIVERSITY -- PROBABLY HELPED
OUT BY A VERY AMBITIOUS A
CONSULTING FIRM THAT -- WAS
QUICKLY REMOVED FROM THE PROJECT --
BUT TO GET TO EFFICIENT TO GET
TO EFFICIENCIES WHICH IS WHERE
WE GET THE SAVINGS.
WE HAD TO SPEND.
A COUPLE OF YEARS WORKING WITH
THE LOCATIONS THE CAMPUSES ON
STANDARDIZING THE WAY WE DO
BUSINESS.
EVERY CAMPUS HAD A DIFFERENT WAY
OF HIRING PEOPLE EVERY CAMPUS
HAD A DIFFERENT WAY OF EXTENDING.
BY ARRANGEMENT AGREEMENTS. FOR
FOR NOTE TAKERS IN CLASSROOMS IN
SO STANDARDIZING.
THE CLASSIFICATIONS WE WERE
USING STANDARDIZING HOW WE DO
HIRES AND TERMINATIONS AND
PROMOTIONS AND MERITS.
SO THAT FROM ONE LOCATION TO THE
NEXT IT WAS A REPEATABLE
PREDICTABLE EXPERIENCE.
WAS A BIG ACCOMPLISHMENT IN THIS
PROJECT. TO GET TO EFFICIENCY
YOU FIRST HAVE TO GET YOUR
STANDARDIZATION AND I WOULD SAY
THAT THAT IS ONE OF THE BIGGER
ACCOMPLISHMENTS OF WHAT WE'VE
DONE TO DATE.
EVERY CAMPUS NOW DOES HIRING THE
SAME WAY ONCE THERE AND YOU SEE
PATH.
THEY MANAGE -- EMPLOYEES IN
POSITIONS AND VACANCIES THE SAME
WAY AND YOU SEE PATH.
AND SO WE NOW HAVE A
STANDARDIZED WAY OF DOING
BUSINESS ONCE EVERYONE IS ON I
AM HIGHLY CONFIDENT WE WILL BE
UNDER EXTREME PRESSURE FROM.
THE CAMPUSES WHO IS SENT
ESSENTIALLY OUR OUR ONGOING
FUNDERS THROUGH A FEE FOR
SERVICE MODEL. TO REDUCE THE
COST OF PATH AND TO REDUCE THE
COST OF PATH IT'S GONNA REQUIRE.
THAT WE FIND EFFICIENCIES IN
WITH THE WAY WE DELIVER THOSE
SERVICES THE CAMPUS IS WILL NOT
WANT TO GIVE UP QUALITY OF
SERVICE.
BUT THEY WILL WANT TO DRIVE DOWN
THE COST OF THE SERVICE SO WE'RE
GONNA HAVE TO FIGURE OUT HOW TO
DELIVER WHAT WE'RE DOING. FOR
LESS OR TO ACCOMMODATE CONTINUED
GROWTH IN THE UNIVERSITY WITHOUT
GROWTH IN THE ADMINISTRATIVE
OVERHEAD OF YOU SEE PATH.
AND THAT'S ULTIMATELY GOING TO
DRIVE THE EFFICIENCY BENEFITS OF
YOU SEE PATH ONCE WE HAVE
EVERYONE IN THE SYSTEM.
IT IS THE ANSWER HELP.
SOMEONE OKAY AND AND I I I KNOW
YOU KNOW HOW LATE IN THE EVENING
IT HAS BECOME -- BUT AGAIN.
I DON'T REMEMBER ALL THE OTHER --
THINGS THAT YOU SEE BROUGHT
FORWARD AND I WISH I DID -- THAT
WERE COST SAVINGS -- BECAUSE
THIS ONE WAS ONE OF THEM ONE AND
I FORGET WHAT THE OTHER ONES ARE
WORK.
THAT THEIR WORK IS ALREADY
WORKING SMARTER AND THERE WERE
THERE WERE OTHERS THERE WERE
OTHERS BUT THIS ONE CERTAINLY.
DIDN'T DIDN'T MAKE IT I DON'T
THINK -- AND THEN YOU SAID YOU
KNOW 1% OF ALL THE ALL THE THE
PAYCHECKS ONE STUDENT ONE ONE
ONE TO ONE AND A HALF PERCENT
AND BUT THAT.
1% OR ONE AND A HALF PERCENT OF
PAYCHECKS.
REPRESENTS WHAT NUMBER OF
BECAUSE IT'S A BIG NUMBER IT IS
A BIG NUMBER AND WHAT NUMBER IS
THAT SO ON AN AVERAGE SO WITH A
HUNDRED THOUSAND EMPLOYEES
CURRENTLY -- THAT WOULD MEAN
WE'RE DOING ONE MONTHLY PAY
CYCLE AND TO BI WEEKLY PAY
CYCLES ROUGHLY PER MONTH.
SO WE'RE REALLY TALKING ROUGHLY
THREE HUNDRED THOUSAND CHECKS A
MONTH.
SO 11% OF 300-100-03000. THREE
THOUSAND SO THAT'S HOW THAT 1%
THAT'S THREE THOUSAND AND AND
AND AND JUST FOR MY COLLEAGUES.
THAT'S THREE THOUSAND GRADUATE
STUDENTS.
WHOSE PAYCHECKS WERE WRONG. FOR
RICH A LOT OF INDIVIDUALS IF I
COULD OFFER JUST A SLIGHT
CORRECTION -- IT'S PAYCHECKS THE
REQUIRE SOME KIND OF
INTERVENTION.
RIGHT SO WE RUN.
I'M I'M GONNA GET THE WEEDS AND
MAYBE THAT'S NOT A GOOD PLACE TO
BE.
BUT THERE'S A THREE DAY PERIOD
BETWEEN THE TIME WE ACTUALLY RUN
A PAYROLL CALCULATION.
AND THE TIME WE ACTUALLY DELIVER
PAY.
AND THAT THAT ONE TO ONE AND A
HALF PERCENT.
DURING THAT THREE DAY PERIOD WE
RUN REPORTS FOR THE CAMPUSES
SUCH AS ZERO PAY REPORT THAT
SAYS.
HERE'S ALL THE EMPLOYEES THAT IT
SHOULD BE GETTING PAID THAT WERE
SHOWING ZERO VALUE FOR DID YOU
NOT SUBMIT TIME FOR THEM.
YOU KNOW WAS THERE OF A FILE
THAT YOU DIDN'T GET TO US THAT
WOULD ALLOW US SO WE ACTUALLY
HAVE A WAY OF RECAPTURING.
A SIGNIFICANT MAJORITY OF THAT
NUMBER IN TIME TO DELIVER PAY
ACCURATELY IN ON TIME BUT FROM
THE INITIAL PAY CAL THAT'S
THAT'S THE ERROR RATE THAT I'M
TALKING ABOUT.
THAT THEN HAS TO BE MANUALLY.
FIXED AND FOR WE CAN ALL I I
GUESS THAT I WANT TO POINT OUT
THAT IT MAY BE A SMALL
PERCENTAGE BUT IT'S REFLECTS BUT
BUT THAT'S A LOT OF STUDENTS.
WHO ARE NEGATIVELY AFFECTED AND
IF YOU'RE WITH THE ONE STUDENT
WHOSE PAYCHECK?
IS NEGATIVELY AFFECTED IT'S A
BIG DEAL. TO YOU.
AND AND WE'RE TALKING IT SEEMS
LIKE HERE -- SEVERAL. THOUSAND
STUDENTS AND I AND I APPRECIATE
AND I WOULD ALSO YOU KNOW THANK
YOU.
AND EVERYONE ELSE INVOLVED FOR
ALL THE CONVERSATIONS THAT TOOK
PLACE.
IS IT IS YOUR PRESENTED HERE
WITH ALL THE DIFFERENT --
GRADUATE STUDENT ORGANIZATIONS
AND I KNOW THAT THEY APPRECIATED --
TO BUT I I AM JUST -- YOU KNOW I
I AM.
THE IRONY OF THIS WHOLE PROJECT
AND AS MUCH AS I AM HAPPY TO
HAVE IT IN RIVERSIDE -- IT IT'S
JUST -- CAN YOU TELL ME HOW MANY
pCURRENTLY HAVE THREE HUNDRED AND
SEVENTY EMPLOYEES FOUR HUNDRED
SEVENTY AND IT WILL GO UP TO
TARGET IS.
FOUR FORTY OR FORTY SO WE'RE
ALMOST THERE.
YEAH.
BUT IT ALMOST TO ME IS IN -- AND
I DON'T KNOW ALL THE DIFFERENT
PROJECTS OF THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA -- UNDER TAKES
[inaudible]
BUT MY EXPERIENCE WITH THIS.
ONE IT HASN'T BEEN.
IN A WITH THE AS MUCH MONEY AS
WITH ITS COST OVER.
THE ESTIMATES AND WHAT IT WAS
SUPPOSED TO BE COST SAVING.
IT CERTAINLY HASN'T -- DONE WHAT
IT WAS SUPPOSED TO DO.
THANK YOU MISTER MEDINA AND I
THINK YOU YOU HIT IT DOES ADD --
INSULT TO INJURY IS THAT.
LIKE MANY THESE I. T. PROJECT
THE TAXPAYERS ARE PROMISED --
THE MOON AND IS NOWHERE NEAR
THERE.
AND THEY FEEL THEY'RE KIND OF
DEALT A LITTLE BIT.
AND NOT ONLY ARE WE NOT -- ABLE
TO ACHIEVE THE SAVINGS THAT WERE
PROMISED BUT SOME OF THE LOWEST
WAGE WORKERS.
ARE GETTING PAID AND THAT'S VERY
DISTURBING RIGHT AND I'VE HEARD
THAT FROM.
PEOPLE WHO APPEAR NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA AS WELL AS ACROSS THE
THE STATE AND IT'S UNACCEPTABLE.
THESE ARE PEOPLE WITH YOUR
SALARY.
PRESENT PAUL THOMAS SALARY.
BUDGET DIRECTOR SALARIES ARE
PEOPLE HAVE A TOUGH TIME PAYING
THE BILLS.
AND SO THIS IS SOMETHING THAT --
WE TAKE VERY SERIOUSLY AND ARE
COUNTING ON THE SEATED TO DO
RIGHT BY THESE INDIVIDUALS AND
THE TEXAS [inaudible]
SO [inaudible]
YOUR QUESTIONS.
OKAY THANK YOU SOME
INFORMATIONAL ITEM [inaudible]
THANK YOU -- WITH THAT WE WILL
PROCEED NOW WITH PUBLIC COMMENTS.
A GOOD EVENING NOW A MISTER
CHAIR AND HONORED MEMBERS I
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR HEARING
OUR PUBLIC COMMENT AT THIS LATE
HOUR.
HAPPY MAY DAY SINCE IT'S STILL
MADE A NAME -- I WANTED TO SHARE%
WITH YOU THAT.
ISSUED ITEM NUMBER THREE THE
OPERATIONAL COSTS STILL SEEMS
VERY SANITIZED FOR THE
DISCUSSION GIVEN THE FACT WE
JUST REMIND TRYING TO KEEP THIS.
TO ONE MINUTE OR LESS PLEASE OF
COURSE -- I SHOULD HAVE
INTRODUCED MYSELF I'M SO SORRY
I'M AMY HEINZ SHAKE WITH UP THE
CW A LOCAL -- NINETY ONE
NINETEEN AND WE STILL HAVE AN
ISSUE WITH THE FACT THAT FORTY
THOUSAND PEOPLE HAVE STRUCK FOUR
TIMES AT THIS POINT AND IT LOOKS
LIKE UNLESS WE HAVE SOME SORT OF
RELIEF WE WILL BE STRIKING A
FIFTH TIME -- THAT IS AN
UNACCEPTABLE SITUATION -- THE
DOCUMENT BARELY DISCUSSES A
PATHWAY FORWARD TO SETTLE WITH
THOSE FOURTH FORTY THOUSAND
WORKERS AND WE'RE VERY CONCERNED
ABOUT THAT.
THIS BODY SAW FIT TO MOVE FOR
WITH HER BUDGET REQUEST LAST
YEAR IT DID NOT MAKE IT THROUGH
TO THE FINAL POINT -- IN THE
BUDGET AND WE'RE ASKING FOR THAT
SAME BUDGET REQUEST AGAIN THE
STATE SHOULD FIND THE STATE
PORTION OF THE UC OUR P. UP TO A
MAXIMUM CAP OF FOUR HUNDRED
MILLION PER YEAR FOR THE NEXT
THREE YEARS FOR A TOTAL MAXIMUM
CAP OF ONE POINT TWO BILLION.
THE STATE SHOULD TAKE THIS MONEY
FROM THE PROP TO FIND JUST AS
THEY DID THE PREVIOUS INJECTION
OF FUNDS INTO THE UC RP.
AND AS A CONDITION OF RECEIVING
THE STATE FUNDS THE UC SHOULD
AGREE TO WITHDRAW THEIR
BARGAINING DEMAND THAT THE
REPRESENTED EMPLOYEES OF UP THE
CW A LOCAL NINETY ONE NINETEEN
AND ASKED ME LOCAL.
THIRTY TWO NINETY NINE THEY
SHOULD NOT FORCE THE FOUR ONE K.
OPTION FOR NEW MEMBERS IN THOSE
BARGAINING UNITS THANK YOU.
GOOD EVENING -- MY NAME'S
ARIANNA TELEPHONE THEM A STUDENT
UC BERKELEY AND I JUST WANNA
TALK ON LIKE MY SUPPORT FOR
FUNDING OUR BASIC NEEDS -- 47%
OF YOU SEE STUDENTS HAVE
REPORTED FOOD INSECURITY AND
FOOD AND SECURITY IS A REALLY
BIG ISSUE THAT COLLEGE STUDENTS
HAVE TO FACE WHEN WE'RE TRYING
TO GET OUR EDUCATION AND LIKE.
WE'RE THINKING ABOUT LIKE HOW MY
GONNA HAVE DINNER LIKE WE DON'T
HAVE A NUTRITIOUS BREAKFAST
BECAUSE WE DON'T HAVE MONEY. TO
TO PROVIDE FOR OURSELVES -- AND
FOOD SECURITY IS MOST PREVALENT
AMONG THE MARGINALIZED
COMMUNITIES FIRST GENERATION
STUDENTS -- IN AS WELL. FOR
ABOUT 5% OF STUDENTS FACE
HOMELESSNESS WHICH IS 5% TOO
MANY -- WE SHOULD BE FOCUSING WE
SHOULD BE ABLE TO NOT HAVE TO
THINK ABOUT THOSE -- BASIC NEEDS
AND FOCUS ON FURTHERING OUR
EDUCATION AND OUR LIKE PASSIONS
LIKE HOT BEING ABLE TO COME AND
TRAVEL TWO HOURS OVER HERE TO
SACRAMENTO TO EVEN SPEAK ON
THESE ISSUES.
RATHER THAN LIKE WORKING --
THEREFORE ASKED LEGISLATURE TO
APPROVE THE FIFTEEN MILLION
DOLLARS -- AN ONGOING STATE
GENERAL FUND A PROPOSED BY THE
GOVERNOR FOR BASIC NEEDS AND AN
ADDITIONAL TWO MILLION ON
DOLLARS FOR FOR THE RAPID RE
HOUSING PROGRAM.
THANK YOU.
GOOD EVENING MY NAME IS AND CHEN
AND I'M A SENIOR AT UC BERKELEY
I'M HERE TO URGE YOU TO ALSO --
APPROVED THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET
PROPOSAL OF FIFTY MILLION
DOLLARS IN BASIC NEEDS SERVICES
I WORKED FOR TWO YEARS -- AS A
VOLUNTEER AT THE UC BERKELEY
FOOD K<c.cyan> PANTRY ON CAMPUS OR</c>
INTERACT WITH HUNDREDS OF PEOPLE
STUDENTS WHO ARE FOOD INSECURE
YOU KNOW A LOT OF THESE WERE
JUST STUDENT PARENTS WHO JUST
WANT TO HAVE THEIR KIDS HAVE
FOOD ON THE TABLE.
OR YOU KNOW LOW INCOME STUDENTS
WHO NEED TO STUDY ON A FULL
STOMACH SO STUDENT SUCCESS IN
STUDENT LOAN THIS REALLY DEPENDS
ON HAVING THEIR BASIC NEEDS MET
IT IS CRUCIAL SO AND YOU KNOW
THE HUNDRED THE HUNGER FREE --
CAMPUS PROGRAM THAT FUNDS THE UC
BERKELEY FOOD PANTRY MADE A REAL
IMPACT BY GIVING US IS AMAZING
ON CAMPUS PANTRY ON NOW WE HAVE
TO CONTINUE FUNDING AND EXPAND
SERVICES AND I REALLY DO THINK
THAT BASIC NEEDS IS A HUGE PART
OF YOU KNOW LIKE LIFE AT CAL.
THERE IS THE ISSUE OF HOUSING
WHICH IS ALSO DEFINING IS LIKE A
DEFINING -- ASPECT OF LIFE AT UC
BERKELEY AND INFILTRATES EVERY
PART OF LIFE FROM LIKE FINANCIAL
STABILITY TO MENTAL HEALTH
BECAUSE OF THE STRESS AND
ANXIETY THAT COMES WITH FINDING
AFFORDABLE HOUSING.
YOU KNOW AT BEST IT'S STUDENTS
WHO LIKE ME FOR PAYING A
THOUSAND DOLLARS A MONTH FOR A
TINY DOUBLE AN APARTMENT AND AT
ITS WORST IT'S STUDENTS WHO ARE
LITERALLY HOMELESS LIVING ON OUR
STREETS AND OUR CARS -- YOU KNOW
CRASHING AT FRIENDS KICK UP
PLACES AND SO RE HOUSING THESE
STUDENTS GETTING THEIR BASIC
NEEDS MET IS FINALLY AND I THINK
IT'S AN ISSUE OF FUNDING SO
PLEASE -- I REALLY URGE YOU TO
FUND BASIC NEEDS SERVICES AND
FUND RAPIDLY HOUSING EFFORTS
THANK YOU [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
HI GOOD EVENING I'M A FRESHMAN
AT UC BERKELEY AND I WANTED TO
JUST REITERATE MY ABOUT MY
FRIENDS SAID -- ONE IN EVERY
TWENTY STUDENTS AT THE UC
EXPERIENCE HOUSE SOME FORM OF
HOMELESSNESS.
A AND KEEPING THIS IN MIND WE
ASK THAT THE ADDITIONAL GENERAL
FUND FOR TREES SEGMENTS OF
HIGHER EDUCATION YOU SEE IT CSU
AND CUT A CALIFORNIA COMMITTEE
COLLEGES. TO BE USED TO HELP
CREATE COLLEGE FOCUS RAPIDLY
HOUSING PROGRAMS IN ORDER TO
SUPPORT HOMELESS ANDHOUSE
HOUSING INSECURE STUDENTS.
AS YOU SEE STUDENTS WE THINK
THAT THE ANSWER TO FIX THE
INEQUITY IN BASIC NEEDS FUNDING
ACOSTA THREE SEGMENTS AS NOT TO
CUT THE FUNDING FOR DO YOU SEE
BASIC NEEDS SERVICE SAYS.
BUT TO INCREASE SUPPORT -- THE
BASIC NEEDS SERVICE AT OTHER
INSTITUTIONS.
HI MY NAME IS DEREK THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR LETTING ME SPEAK AGAIN --
SO AGAIN I WANT TO TOUCH ON MY
POSITION AS A RESIDENT ASSISTANT --
AGAIN I HAVE TO TO HAVE A LOT OF
CHECK INS WITH A LOT OF MY
STUDENTS I I SUPERVISE OVER
SIXTY SIX STUDENTS -- AND ONE
RESIDENCE HALL AND CONSISTENTLY
WITH ALL MY CHECK INS THEY'VE
ALL VOICE A LOT OF CONCERNS
WHICH IS FOOD SECURITY IN
GENERAL -- CURRENTLY IF YOU ARE
INVOLVED WITH RESIDENTS -- OR IF
YOU ARE INVOLVED IN INVEST
INITIAL LIFE WHICH IS LIKE THE
DORMS THAT -- DIE STUDENTS CAN
ENROLL IN -- DURING THE FRESHMAN
YEAR THROUGH THE REST OF COLLEGE --
THEY ALL HAVE TO ENROLL IN THE
MEAL PLAN AND THE MEAL PLAN
ITSELF RIGHT NOW IS.
IT'S CAUSING PEOPLE TO BE SECURE
IN GENERAL LIKE THEY ARE THE
STANDARD MEAL PLAN ONLY OFFERS
TWELVE MEALS FLIGHTS PER WEEK
AND THAT'S CLEARLY NOT EVEN.
ENOUGH TO FEED SOMEONE TWO MEALS
PER DAY AND THAT'S NOT TO SAY
THAT -- IN GENERAL LIKE IT IF
YOU THIS PROGRAM OF AND ROLLING
PEOPLE AND THE MEAL PLAN AND TO
SQUALL'S DISQUALIFY THEM FROM
ENROLLING IN PROGRAMS LIKE HOW
FRESH TO REALLY SUPPLEMENT THE
REST OF THEIR DIET IN.
A LOT OF MY RESIDENTS HAVE
COMPLAINED THAT THEY HAD TO TAKE
OUT EXTRA MONEY TO SUPPLEMENT
THEIR OWN DIETS BECAUSE THEY'RE
LITERALLY STARVING -- AND THE
FACT THAT LIKE OUR UNIVERSITY
HOW TO CUT A LOT OF THE FUNDS
THAT GOES INTO THESE MEAL PLAN
SAYS A LOT BECAUSE WE REALLY
NEED THESE FUNDS ALSO SUPPLEMENT
WHAT GOES INTO OUR MEAL PLANS
ABOUT OUR STUDENTS CAN ACTUALLY
BE FAD -- INSTEAD OF HAVING
THESE LIKE SHALLOW MEAL PLANS
THAT SAY THAT THE STUDENTS WILL
BE ABLE TO BE FED BY IN REALITY
THERE'S ONLY TWELVE MIL SWIPES
PER WEEK WHICH IS -- MAKING
SINCE FOOD INTO CARE AND I ALSO
JUST LIKE TO RIO REITERATE ONE
MORE TIME THAT -- I JUST REALLY
WANT TO URGE YOU ALL TO MAKE
SURE THAT -- YOU DO MAKE THE ONE
TIME -- THE FOUR POINT EIGHT
MILLION AND THE STATE'S GENERAL
FUNDS THAT THE YOU SEE RECEIVED
IN LIEU OF STUDENT SERVICES FEES
INCREASES.
IN. TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN TO TO
NOT TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN
PERMANENT AND APPROVE THE FIVE
POINT THREE MILLION AND THE ON
GOING STATE GENERAL FUND
PROPOSED BY THE GOVERNMENT.
FOR UNTIL SERVICES EXPANSION AT
THE UC THANK YOU.
HELLO MY NAME'S THE CORNER NEW
AND I'M SENATOR A LOT OF THE A
AS YOU SEE IT -- WHICH IS THE
ASSOCIATED STUDENTS OF THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA WHICH
IS UC BERKELEY'S GOVERNING BODY
I JUST WANTED TO ADDRESS SOME
LIQUOR FOR CAISSONS WITH LIKE
HOW FAST I PERSONALLY USE CAO
FRESH.
AND THE PROCESS WAS GOING
THROUGH IT HAS BEEN VERY
DIFFICULT BECAUSE LIKE IN THE
INITIAL STAGES I APPLIED ON MY
OWN AND IT TOOK ME MONTHS TO GET
IT.
BUT THEN LIKE I FEEL AS IF NOW
THAT THERE INITIATIVE TO
ACTUALLY GET LIKE WORKING PEOPLE
HELPING US IN THE PROCESS IT'S
MADE IT MORE EFFICIENT.
I DID RUN INTO PROBLEMS WERE
MIKE HEALTH PRESS WAS CUT BUT
THEN RECENTLY I'VE GOTTEN IT
REINSTATED BECAUSE I HAD HELP
FROM THE CAMPUS ADMINISTRATION.
SO I DO WANT TO HIGHLIGHT THAT
IMPORTANCE AS WELL ALSO THE FOOD
PANTRY A LOT OF IT IS RUN OFF OF
DONATIONS RIGHT NOW.
AND SO ADDITIONAL FUNDING WOULD
HELP WITH LIKE -- EXTENDING THE
RESOURCES THAT STUDENTS HAVE ON
CAMPUS -- THERE'S A SENIOR THAT
WAS VERY PROMINENT ON CAMPUS
LAST YEAR -- THEY GRADUATED IN
THERE AT A TOP MEDICAL SCHOOL
RIGHT NOW THERE CALIFORNIA
RESIDENT AND THEY HAD FUNDING
ISSUES WITH TUITION WHICH IS
SUPPOSED TO COVER HOUSING AND
FOOD.
BUT THEY WHAT HOMELESS AND THEY
WERE -- THEY TOLD THE UNIVERSITY
AND THEY TOLD STUDENTS ON CAMPUS
THAT THEY WENT AND SHOWERED IN
HER STEM AND THEY SLEPT IN
MOFFETT FRUIT WHICH IS OUR
TWENTY FOUR HOUR LIBRARY.
AND THIS IS NOT AN EXCLUSIVE
NARRATIVE LIKE THIS IS VERY
KNOWN ON CAMPUS AND MANY
STUDENTS GO THROUGH THIS.
AND JUST LIKE TOUCHING ON OTHER
THINGS LIKE THEIR STUDENTS
EATING FROM LIKE TRASH CANS LIKE.
IT'S NOT DROP DRAMATIC TYPE
THINGS LIKE THESE ARE THINGS
THAT ARE BEING SEEN ON CAMPUS
ONLY WE WOULD HOPE THAT PEOPLE
TAKE EFFORTS TO LIKE.
FIND BASIC NEEDS AN MENTAL
HEALTH INITIATIVES THE LAST
THING THAT I WANT TO TOUCH ON IS
LIKE STUDENT SUCCESS AND
RETENTION THERE'S BEEN A LOT OF
TALK ABOUT HOW DO WE GO ABOUT
LIKE SOLVING THOSE ISSUES.
I FEEL LIKE THE FIRST STEP TO
THAT IS SHOWING THAT WE ACTUALLY
CARE ABOUT THE STUDENTS OF THE
MARGINALIZED COMMUNITIES.
I'M A LOT OF LOW INCOME STUDENTS
FIRST GENERATION STUDENTS
BENEFIT STUDENTS THEY FEEL AS IF
THEY'RE LOST ON CAMPUS AND
THEY'RE NOT SUPPORTED.
AND IF A GOING GET MENTAL HEALTH
RESOURCES IT'S REALLY HARD IT
TAKES UP TO A MONTH TO GET A AN
APPOINTMENT SO LIKE WE NEED TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE'RE PUTTING
MORE DIVERSIFIED STOP ON THEIR
INTERFACE.
BY SEXUAL ORIENTATION ETHNIC
BACKGROUND AND ALSO LIKE FUNDING
TING SATELLITES WHICH RIGHT NOW
ONLY RUN THREE TO FOUR HOURS BUT
THERE ALTERNATIVE LOCATIONS ON
CAMPUS THAT CAN ACCOMMODATE AND
GET MORE STUDENTS SEEN ON CAMPUS.
SO I JUST URGE YOU TO LIKE --
REALIZE THE IMPORTANCE OF AND
YOU COME BACK WITH A PLAN TO
HELP US THE ROLE CAL FEST WILL
GIVE YOU A MASSIVE AWARD HERE SO.
I'M WORKING ON IT RIGHT OUTSIDE
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
HI NEIL I AM I MEAN I'M NEAL.
IT'S BEEN A LONG DAY -- I JUST
WANT TO THANK YOU ALL FOR FIRST
FOR STICKING AROUND FOR SO LONG.
MY PEERS TALKED ABOUT THE
IMPORTANCE OF BASIC NEEDS AND I
WANT TO THANK THE CHAIRMAN FOR
BRINGING UP THE NEED FOR RAPID
RE HOUSING.
THE NEED FOR EMERGENCY HOUSING
SERVICES TURNED IT INTO THE
FIFTEEN MILLION WE WOULD ALSO
LIKE TO SEE TWENTY MILLION AN ON
GOING FUNDING FOR THE THREE
SYSTEMS.
SO SOMEONE CAME FROM THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGE SYSTEM I'M A
TRANSFER STUDENT I REALLY SEE
THE NEED FOR THIS THERE'S SO
MANY HOMELESS STUDENTS STUDENTS
ARE ON THE VERGE OF BECOMING
HOMELESS -- WHICH IS WHY WE'RE
PROUD TO PARTNER WITH THE SSA
THE JOHN BYRNE ADVOCATES -- FOR
YOUTH TO ADVOCATE FOR THE
CREATION OF COLLEGE FOCUS RAPID
RE HOUSING PROGRAMS ACROSS ALL
THREE SYSTEMS.
AND WE'RE ASKING FOR TOLL TWENTY
MILLION DOLLARS AN ON GOING
FUNDS IN ADDITION TO THE FIFTEEN
MILLION THANK YOU.
GOOD EVENING ERICA REMAIN ON
BEHALF OF THE HISPANIC
ASSOCIATION OF COLLEGES AND
UNIVERSITIES WE WANT TO LOG THE
UC FOR TAKING A PROACTIVE
APPROACH TO LOOKING AT THE
ACHIEVEMENT GAP -- THERE ARE NOW
SIX OF THE NINE UC'S ARE
HISPANIC SERVING INSTITUTIONS
BUT WHEN YOU LOOK AT THIS LIST
THERE AT THE BOTTOM.
OF THE GRADUATION RATES AND
WHILE WE AGREE THAT PROVIDING
ACCESS IS IMPORTANT EQUALLY
IMPORTANT IS PROVIDING THEM WITH
SUCCESS THE NEED TO GET OUT THE
DOOR HOLDING A DIPLOMA.
AND WE NEED TO DO IN FOUR YEARS
BECAUSE OUR AVERAGE FAMILY
INCOME IS TWENTY EIGHT THOUSAND
WHICH MEANS IF THEY GO OVER FOR
YOUR STATEMENT OF ACCOUNT.
WHICH MEANS ARE TAKING OUT LOANS
OR POSSIBLY NOT GRADUATING WHICH
MAY HELP EXPLAIN PART OF THAT
ACHIEVEMENT GAP.
AND SO WE ENCOURAGE YOU TO LOOK
AT STUDENT SUCCESS AS WELL AS
THE US THANK YOU.
GOOD EVENING.
MR MCCARTY MISTER MEDINA -- JAKE
PRINTER WITH THE CAMPAIGN FOR
COLLEGE OPPORTUNITY -- WANT TO
THANK YOU AGAIN FOR YOUR
COMMITMENT TO PROVIDING GREATER
ACCESS TO THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA AND THAT THOSE
COVERED AT A PRIOR HEARING BUT
WANTED -- TO EMPHASIZE THAT THAT
CONTINUES TO BE ONE OF OUR
HIGHEST PRIORITIES IN THE
CONTEXT OF FUNDING FOR THE
UNIVERSITY -- WHEN WE LOOKED AT --
STATE OF HIGHER EDUCATION FOR
BLACK CALIFORNIANS MOST RECENTLY --
WE FOUND THAT WHEN WE ADD SEATS
TO THE UNIVERSITY ARE BLACK
STUDENTS ACTUALLY SAW VERY
SIGNIFICANT INCREASES ABOUT WHAT
THE AVERAGE AND BAND SO IT'S A
MEANS OF ALSO DIVERSIFYING TO
STUDENTS THAT WERE HELPING SERVE
WHEN WE ADD THAT SEATS -- IN THE
CONTEXT OF STUDENT SUCCESS -- WE
ALSO WANTED -- TO PUT CALL
TENSION AND MISTER MEDINA'S
REMARKS AROUND -- DISAGREED IN
THAT DAY THAT NOT ONLY FOR THE
SYSTEM BUT ALSO AT THE CAMPUS
LEVEL HAVING THAT BE PART OF
THIS FUNDING IF YOU ARE.
TO INCLUDE THAT IN THE ULTIMATE
BUDGET AND DEFINING SOME METRICS
TO EVALUATE THAT ON AND THEN
LASTLY -- THE COLLEGE READINESS
BLOCK GRANT AND OF RELATED FUNDS
FOR THE UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA
SHOWED SOME REALLY POSITIVE --
RESULT IN TERMS OF SERVING MORE
OF THE STUDENTS COMING FROM
HEALTHY FF PLUS HIGH SCHOOLS --
THAT FUNDING THOUGH HAS.
RUN OUT SO WOULD ASK THAT YOU
CONSIDER EITHER LOOKING AT TO
ANOTHER ONE TIME APPROPRIATIONS
SO THAT WE DON'T HAVE -- TO PULL
BACK ON THAT WORK WE'RE LOOKING
AT HOW WE CAN DO THAT ON AN
ONGOING BASIS SO THAT
SUSTAINABLE AND WE CAN DEVELOP
EVEN STRONGER PARTNERSHIPS
BETWEEN.
ART SCHOOLS AND THE UNIVERSITY
OF CALIFORNIA.
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
MAY HAVE.
WON GOOD EVENING EVERYONE HAPPY
TO THE LAST PERSON SEE ALL GOOD
TO GO AFTER THIS BUT I WANT TO
KIND OF A COOL WHAT.
OF MANY OF MY COLLEAGUES AND
FRIENDS A BODY TALKED ABOUT --
WHICH ALLOWS THE COLLEGE FOR ALL
POLLUTION WERE HAPPY TO BE A
PARTNER WITH THEM WE ARE ASKING --
FOR FUNDING -- FOR THE DO YOU
KNOW AT HE DOES HAVE A PLUS
FUNDING FORMULA -- WHICH WOULD
HELP OUR STUDENTS OUT WE WERE
EARLIER TALKING ABOUT OUR
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MCCARTY YOU YOU
MENTIONED WHAT ARE SOME
SOLUTIONS THAT COULD GO TO
WATCHING SUCCESS SPECIFICALLY
WITH TANGIBLE OUTCOMES.
THIS IS ONE OF THOSE AND WE
REALLY WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT
THIS IS AN ONGOING FUNDING THAT
THAT GETS BROUGHT UP -- IN
ADDITION TO THAT -- I WON AGAIN
ECHO -- THE NEED FOR BASIC NEEDS
FUNDING OUR FRIENDS FROM THE LA
ALL TALK ABOUT.
HOW YOU KNOW IN THE REPORT
MENTIONS THAT THERE'S AN
INEQUITY FACT OVER DEVICE YOU
SEE RECEIVING FUNDING AND SEE IT
THROUGH THE COMMITTEE CALL IS
NOT RECEIVING AS MUCH?
AND AND WE AGREED THEY SHOULD
RECEIVE MORE BUT THE ANSWER
ISN'T TO CUT TO UC'S FUNDING WE
HAVE A LOT OF STUDENTS WHO ARE
HUNGRY.
WHO ARE HOMELESS WHO ARE DEALING
WITH A LOT OF ISSUES AND
DISSOLUTION TO SAYING SOME
QUESTIONS ARE GOING HUNGRY AND
OTHERS I AND IS IS NOT TO TAKE
THE FOOD AWAY FROM?
THE ONES THAT AREN'T GOING
HUNGRY EAST ALSO HELP THE ONES
WHO ARE GOING HUNGRY SO WE THINK
WE REALLY WANNA ECHO EVERYTHING
ON OUR STUDENTS WHO FROM
BERKELEY HAVE COME ALL THE WAY
THIS TIME IN THE BEING HERE FOR
THE WHOLE TIME -- WE ONE ECHO
THAT AND WHEN I ASKED FOR THE
FANS WHO WANT TO GIVE THAT.
SHOT OUT AND HATS OFF TO THE
STUDENTS.
STICK AROUND FOR FOUR HOURS AND
FIFTEEN MINUTES.
YOU SHOULD GET SOME EXTRA CREDIT.
IF YOU NEED ME TO SIGN A LETTER.
OR DO I FACEBOOK POST ABOUT IT
ABOUT YOU TAKE TO MAKE SURE YOUR
PROFESSORS NOW.
PLEASE LET ME KNOW THANK YOU.
I THANK YOU WITHOUT WILL JR